hello everyone and welcome to this
neural network full course video 2022 by
simply alone
deep learning is a field of artificial
intelligence that is rapidly growing and
has several applications to offer
deep learning is being used to build
self-driving cars virtual assistants
face recognition systems machine
translation systems as well as in
healthcare to detect diseases at an
early stage
artificial neural networks
form the core of deep learning and works
based on the structure and functions of
a human brain
neural networks are used to build deep
learning models with vast volumes of
data
it consists of several layers that
process data
find hidden information and give the
desired output
now
as per
marketsandmarkets.com
the deep learning market is expected to
reach
18.16 billion us dollars by 2023
that is growing at a cagr of 41.7
percent from 2018 to 2023.
according to another report by
alliedmarketresearch.com
the global neural network market was
valued at
14.35 billion us dollars in 2020 and it
is projected to reach
152.61 billion u.s dollars by 2030 that
is growing at a cagr of 26.7 percent
from 2021 to 2030.
now
my colleague chinmay will introduce the
topic that we'll be covering in our
neural network full course video
so over to chiangmai now
[Music]
neural networks typically used in deep
learning are computing systems inspired
by the structure and function of a human
brain it is used to find solutions to
those problems for which the algorithmic
method is expensive or does not exist
neural networks learn by example so we
do not need to program it in depth hi
guys welcome to the complete neural
network tutorial by simply learn but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update first we will
understand the basics of neural networks
and see its practical implementation
then we learn how back propagation and
gradient descent works
finally we'll understand the concepts
and practical implementation of
convolutional and recurrent neural
networks let's first look at a small
animated video to understand neural
networks better last summer my family
and i visited russia even though none of
us could read russian we did not have
any trouble in figuring our way out all
thanks to google's real-time translation
of russian boards into english
this is just one of the several
applications of neural networks
neural networks form the base of deep
learning a subfield of machine learning
where the algorithms are inspired by the
structure of the human brain
neural networks take in data train
themselves to recognize the patterns in
this data and then predict the outputs
for a new set of similar data
let's understand how this is done
let's construct a neural network that
differentiates between a square circle
and triangle
neural networks are made up of layers of
neurons these neurons are the core
processing units of the network
first we have the input layer which
receives the input the output layer
predicts our final output
in between exists the hidden layers
which perform most of the computations
required by our network here's an image
of a circle
this image is composed of 28 by 28
pixels which make up for 784 pixels
each pixel is fed as input to each
neuron of the first layer
neurons of one layer are connected to
neurons of the next layer through
channels each of these channels is
assigned a numerical value known as
weight
the inputs are multiplied to the
corresponding weights and their sum is
sent as input to the neurons in the
hidden layer
each of these neurons is associated with
a numerical value called the bias which
is then added to the input sum
this value is then passed through a
threshold function called the activation
function
the result of the activation function
determines if the particular neuron will
get activated or not an activated neuron
transmits data to the neurons of the
next layer over the channels
in this manner the data is propagated
through the network this is called
forward propagation
in the output layer the neuron with the
highest value fires and determines the
output the values are basically a
probability for example here our neuron
associated with square has the highest
probability
hence that's the output predicted by the
neural network
of course just by a look at it we know
our neural network has made a wrong
prediction but how does the network
figure this out
note that our network is yet to be
trained
during this training process along with
the input our network also has the
output fed to it the predicted output is
compared against the actual output to
realize the error in prediction the
magnitude of the error indicates how
wrong we are and the sign suggests if
our predicted values are higher or lower
than expected
the arrows here give an indication of
the direction and magnitude of change to
reduce the error
this information is then transferred
backward through our network
this is known as back propagation
now based on this information the
weights are adjusted this cycle of
forward propagation and back propagation
is iteratively performed with multiple
inputs
this process continues until our weights
are assigned such that the network can
predict the shapes correctly in most of
the cases
this brings our training process to an
end
you might wonder how long this training
process takes honestly neural networks
may take hours or even months to train
but time is a reasonable trade-off when
compared to its scope
let us look at some of the prime
applications of neural networks facial
recognition cameras on smartphones these
days can estimate the age of the person
based on their facial features this is
neural networks at play first
differentiating the face from the
background and then correlating the
lines and spots on your face to a
possible age forecasting neural networks
are trained to understand the patterns
and detect the possibility of rainfall
or rise in stock prices with high
accuracy music composition neural
networks can even learn patterns in
music and train itself enough to compose
a fresh tune so here's a question for
you which of the following statements
does not hold true a activation
functions are threshold functions b
error is calculated at each layer of the
neural network c both forward and back
propagation take place during the
training process of a neural network d
most of the data processing is carried
out in the hidden layers leave your
answers in the comments section below
with deep learning and neural networks
we are still taking baby steps the
growth in this field has been foreseen
by the big names companies such as
google amazon and nvidia have invested
in developing products such as libraries
predictive models and intuitive gpus
that support the implementation of
neural networks the question dividing
the visionaries is on the reach of
neural networks to what extent can we
replicate the human brain we'd have to
wait a few more years to give a definite
answer but if you enjoyed this video it
would only take a few seconds to like
and share it also if you haven't yet do
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon as we have a lot more exciting
videos coming up fun learning till then
i hope you're excited to learn more
about neural networks now we have
richard who will take you through the
remaining part of the course and make
you understand neural networks in detail
with that over to you richard what is a
neural network welcome to today's lesson
my name is richard kirschner i'm with
the simply learn team today we want to
discuss the very basics of a neural
network and what that is
so what's in it for you today what is
deep learning what is artificial neural
network how does neural network work
advantages of a neural network
applications of a neural network and the
future of neural networks let's start
with a brief history of the artificial
intelligence hello i am the human brain
this one's seeking enlightenment and has
sat and meditated i am the most complex
organ in the human body and i help you
to think understand and make decisions
and the secret behind all my power is a
neuron i'll get back to that in some
time ever since the 1950s scientists
have been trying to mimic the
functioning of a neuron and use it to
build smarter robots after a lot of
trial and error humans finally designed
a computer that can recognize human
speech it was only after 2000 that
humans were able to give birth to deep
learning that was able to see and
distinguish between different images and
videos so looking at that let's dive
into what is deep learning now your
first thought might be is the opposite
of shallow learning no deep learning i
like into a magic box and let's go in
there just take a look as to why it's
kind of a magic box so what exactly is
deep learning these are the images of
dogs deep learning is a machine learning
technique that teaches computers to do
what comes naturally to humans learn by
example the robot gets trained with
photos as example now this is very
different than hardwiring a computer
program so that it recognizes something
it actually learns and that's where it's
a magic box because you don't really
control how it learns you control the
aspects that go in the computer comes
back and says wait i know what you are
looks at the photograph of the dog and
it's able to identify that it saw in the
images it says you are a dog woof woof
so that's an example of deep learning
you'll notice we didn't go in we'll go
into the actually how it works behind
the scenes for a neural network but
there's a bit of filling of magic and
that's where the term deep learning
comes in and that's also the term where
i like to call it a magic box you put
these things in here into the program
and it starts running the deep learning
and you have to understand those
settings but you don't have to follow
the exactly what's going on in the deep
learning model that brings us to the
question how does deep learning do it
remember the neuron scientists managed
to build an artificial form of it that
powers any deep learning based machine
so let's talk about artificial neural
networks what is an artificial neural
network to understand how an artificial
neuron works we need to understand how
the real one works
first we have a dendrite input to the
neuron and you can see these little
hairs that come in and they receive
information then we have the cell body
information processing happens here so
it takes all these different dendrites
and information coming in from the
different dendrites and it looks at that
information and then you have your axon
which is the output to the neuron so
there goes your axon and you see it goes
all the way out and at the very end it
flanges out each one of those little
flanges connects to the dendrite or the
hairs on the next one now let's see what
an artificial neural network looks like
so an artificial neural network we have
an input layer so that could be an array
of data each one of those white dots in
the yellow bar would represent say a
pixel in a picture then you have the
lines that connected to the hidden
layers which are your weights and they
add all those up on the hidden layers in
each one of those dots kind of like a
cell does something with all the inputs
and then it puts an output into the next
hidden layer and so on into the output
layer so information processing happens
here input to the neuron output to the
neuron so you can see how they are
similar we have an input which is our
yellow bar coming in and then you liken
each of the hidden layers to being a
neuron and it passes it to the next one
and so on and then you have an output to
the next neuron or an output to the real
world a neural network is a system of
hardware and or software patterned after
the operation of neurons in the human
brain neural networks also called
artificial neural networks is a way of
achieving deep learning how does
artificial neural networks work let us
find out how does an artificial neural
network work hey siri what is the time
now it's 12 30 in the morning thanks
let's find out how she recognizes speech
here is a neural network and the
different layers on it so we have our
input layer our hidden layers and the
output layer this is the sentence that
needs to be recognized by the network
what is the time so when it comes in
each one comes in as a pattern of sound
so what is the time first let's consider
the word what and you have w-h-a-t
and you can see each one of those in the
sound bar probably looks a little
different than that just a
representation comes in as a different
pattern now we will split the sound wave
for the letter w into smaller segments
so we split off w and then we take w
when we analyze just w as the amplitude
is varying in the sound wave for w we
collect the values at different
intervals and form an array so we have
0.5 1.5 1.7 1.9 that might be the
different amplitudes coming in and we
feed the array of amplitudes to the
input layer so each one of those goes
into its own box on the input layer
random weights are assigned to each
interconnection between input and hidden
layer so remember all those little lines
i said those are special weights now
we're going to start by doing it
randomly we always start with randoms if
we start with some kind of preset
identical pattern like if you set them
all to three take forever to train it
and you're less likely to get a good
result where random works really well in
this the weights are multiplied with the
inputs and a bias is added to form the
transfer function so we make a sum of
all the weights times the value so you
take 0.5 which is your x coming in and
we're going to multiply that by w1 w2 w3
so on and then we get to the next level
we're going to add those together coming
in what's coming in so we add the weight
times x and there's always a bias added
in if you ever build your own neural
network don't forget to add the bias in
otherwise tends to not work quite as
well you need that extra layer in there
to help it weights are assigned to the
interconnection between the hidden
layers the output of the transfer
function is fed as an input to the
activation function so the output from
one hidden layer becomes the input to
the next hidden layer acoustic model
contains the statistical representation
of each distinct sound that makes a word
and so we start building these
acoustical models and as these layers
separate them out they'll start learning
what the different models are for the
different letters lexicon contains the
data for different pronunciations of
every word so we have the lexicon at the
end where we end up with the a b c d and
it identifies the different letters in
there now the term acoustic model and
the term lexicon are specific to this
domain the domain of understanding
speech certainly when you're doing
photographs and other things you'll have
different labels on here but the process
is going to be the same and finally we
get our output later following the same
process for every word and letter the
neural network recognizes the sentence
you said what is the time so identifies
a w-h-a-t and then identifies that
that's one word what is the time and so
on it's 12 30. that way siri can look up
the time and read it back to you so
let's look at the advantages of an
artificial neural network so gentlemen
could you tell me the advantages of an
artificial neural network it's amazing
how many times i've been in that
situation where i have to explain to the
people making the decisions in the
company it's amazing how many times i've
been in that space where i have to
explain to the owner of the company what
the artificial intelligence and the
neural network actually do what are the
advantages of an artificial neural
network and what it can do for them and
how it works so an artificial neural
network outputs aren't limited entirely
by inputs and results given to them
initially by an expert system this
ability comes in handy for robotics and
pattern recognition systems artificial
neural networks have the potential for
high fault tolerance artificial neural
networks are capable of debugging or
diagnosing a network on their own very
common use these days is to go through
the log files and sort them out
thousands of log files if you're in
working as an admin non-linear systems
have the capability of finding shortcuts
to reach computational expensive
solutions so we see this in banking
where by hand they have an excel
spreadsheet and then they start building
codes around that excel spreadsheet and
over 20 years they might build a
repertoire of all these functions and
the neural network comes up with the
same answers done in days weeks or even
a month for a huge bank so let's take a
look a little bit more because i
mentioned a couple applications of
artificial intelligence there but let's
dig deeper into the applications of
artificial intelligence let's look at
some of the real life this is stuff
going on right now in our world and
we're in such an exciting time with the
neural networks and the machine learning
and the artificial intelligence
development so let's take a little look
at some of the current applications
going on in real life and you can use
your imagination to dig for some new
ones that we don't have listed here
because it's so
limitless the amount of applications
that are being worked on right now or
being implemented handwriting
recognition neural network is used to
convert handwritten characters into
digital characters that the system can
recognize stock exchange prediction if
you've ever worked with stock exchange
which i have it is so fickled to track i
mean it is really hard to understand
there are many factors that affect the
stock market neural network can examine
a lot of factors and predict the prices
on a daily basis helping the stock
brokers so right now it's still intro
phase where it helps them and they
really have to look closely at it when
you realize that we generate over three
terabytes a day just from the stock
exchange here in the united states
that's a lot of data to dig through and
you have to sort it out before you even
start focusing on even one stock
traveling salesman problem it refers to
finding the optimal path to travel
between all cities in an area neural
network helps solve the problem
providing higher revenue at a minimal
cost logistics is huge just the
logistics that we talk about salesmen
traveling from town to town logistics
are used by amazon amazon loves to ship
their packages and they have empty space
on their trucks so they'll pre-ship
packages and fill that empty space on
who they think will buy it saves them a
lot of time and people are a lot happier
because they get that tomorrow instead
of having to wait three weeks image
compression idea behind data compression
neural network is to store encrypt and
recreate the actual image again so we
can optimize our compression and data
images are the biggest one but it's
using all kinds of data wonderful
application to save a hard drive and to
optimize being able to read it back out
again those are just a few and like i
said use your mind to dig deeper and
let's take it even further we're going
to go a step further here and let's look
at the future of deep learning here we
are
that's not me thank goodness wonderful
person there reading her crystal ball
i'll tell you what i see in the future
more personalized choices for users and
customers all over the world i certainly
like that when i go in there and
whatever online ordering system starts
referring stuff to me local company here
where i live that uses this where you
can take a picture and it starts looking
for what you want based on your pictures
if you see a couch you like starts
looking for furniture like that or
clothing i think it's mainly clothing
hyper intelligent virtual assistants
will make life easier if you played with
google assistant or siri or any of those
you can see how they're slowly evolving
and they're just now getting over that
hump where a virtual assistant can do
all kinds of things even pre-write your
email response for you new forms of
algorithm for learning methods would be
discovered there's always something
rolling out they've had some really cool
research in this area again this stuff
is such a we're just in the infant stage
of artificial intelligence and neural
networks and actually applying them to
the real world wonderful time to jump in
neural networks will be a lot faster in
the future neural network tools will be
embedded in every design surface we
already see that that you can buy a
little mini neural network that plugs
into a really cheap processing board or
into your laptop so the hardware is
starting to come out that goes right in
there where you can dump it on there and
that makes it also faster so because
it's on the hardware instead of the
software side neural networks will be
used in the field of medicine
agriculture physics discoveries just
everything you can imagine we see this
today where it's going from a phd
student in medicine trying to understand
t cells and understand the statistic
analysis of that to cure people to help
keep them healthy to help find out how
we heal to something that anybody can go
access and process the date on they're
working on shared data systems this
concept of it being used in these
different fields and these different
domains is huge the world's wide open
for anybody jumping out there to start
exploring them and start learning neural
networks let's dive in and say how does
a neural network work so now we've come
far enough to understand how neural
network works let's go ahead and walk
through this in a nice graphical
representation they usually describe a
neural network as having different
layers and you'll see that we've
identified a green layer an orange layer
and a red layer the green layer is the
input so you have your data coming in it
picks up the input signals and passes
them to the next layer the next layer
does all kinds of calculations and
feature extraction it's called the
hidden layer a lot of times there's more
than one hidden layer we're only showing
one in this picture but we'll show you
how it looks like in a more detail in a
little bit and then finally we have an
output layer this layer delivers the
final result so the only two things we
see is the input layer and the output
layer now let's make use of this neural
network and see how it works wonder how
traffic cameras identify vehicles
registration plate on the road to detect
speeding vehicles and those breaking the
law they got me going through a red
light the other day well last month
that's like the horrible thing they sent
you this picture of you and all your
information because they pulled it up
off of your license plate and your
picture they should have gone through
the red light so here we are and we have
an image of a car you can see the
license plates on there so let's
consider the image of this vehicle and
find out what's on the number plate the
picture itself is 28 by 28 pixels and
the image is fed as an input to identify
the registration plate each neuron has a
number called activation that represents
the grayscale value of the corresponding
pixel range and we range it from zero to
one one for a white pixel and zero for a
black pixel and you can see down here we
have an example where one of the pixels
is registered as like 0.82 meaning it's
probably pretty dark each neuron is lit
up when its activation is close to one
so as we get closer to black on white we
can really start seeing the details in
there and you can see again the pixel
shows this one up there it's like part
of the car and so it lights up so pixels
in the form of arrays are fed to the
input layer and so we see here the pixel
of a car image fed as an input and
you're going to see that the input layer
which is green is one dimension while
our image is two dimension now when we
look at our setup that we're programming
in python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like row one and
then just tack row two on to the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28 by
28 and you get a picture of this 30 by
30 shrink the 30 by 30 down to fit the
28 by 28 so you can't increase the
number of input in this case green dots
it's very important to remember when you
work on neural networks and let's name
the inputs x1 x2 x3 respectively so each
one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they get these random weights
that come through that if x1 lights up
then it's going to be x1 times this
weight going into the hidden layer and
we sum those weights the weights are
multiplied with the input signal and the
bias is added to all of them so as you
can see here we have x1 comes in and it
actually goes to all the different
hidden layer nodes or in this case
whatever you want to call them network
setup the orange dots and so you take
the value of x1 you multiply it by the
weight for the next hidden layer so x1
goes to hidden layer 1 x1 goes to hidden
layer 2 x1 goes hidden layer 1 node 2
hidden layer 1 node 3 and so on and the
bias a lot of times they just put the
bias in as like another green dot or
another orange dot and they give the
bias a value one and then all the
weights go in from the bias into the
next node so the bias can change we
always just remember that you need to
have that bias in there there's things
that can be done with it generally most
the packages out there control that for
you so you don't have to worry about
figuring out what the bias is but if you
ever dive deep into neural networks
you've got to remember there's a bias or
the answer won't come out correctly the
weighted sum of the input is fed as an
input to the activation function to
decide which nodes to fire and for
feature extraction as a signal flows
within the hidden layers the weighted
sum of inputs is calculated and is fed
to the activation function in each layer
to decide which nodes to fire so here's
our feature extraction of the number
plate and you can see these are still
hidden nodes in the middle and this
becomes important we're going to take a
little detour here and look at the
activation function so we're going to
dive just a little bit into the math so
you can start to understand where some
of the games go on when you're playing
with neural networks in your programming
so let's look at the different
activation functions before we move
ahead here's our friendly red tag
shopping robot and so one is a sigmoid
function and the sigmoid function which
is 1 over 1 plus e to the minus x takes
the x value and you can see where it
generates almost a 0 and almost a 1 with
a very small area in the middle where it
crosses over and we can use that value
to feed into another function so if it's
really uncertain it might have a 0.1 or
0.2 or 0.3 but for the most part it's
going to be really close to 1 and really
close to this case 0 0 to 1. the
threshold function so if you don't want
to worry about the uncertainty in the
middle you just say oh if x is greater
than or equal to 0 if not then x is zero
so it's either zero or one really
straightforward there's no in between in
the middle and then you have the what
they call the relu relu function and you
can see here where it puts out the value
but then it says well if it's over one
it's going to be 1 and if it's less than
0 it's 0. so it kind of just dead ends
it on those two ends but allows all the
values in the middle and again this like
the sigmoid function allows that
information to go to the next level so
it might be important to know if it's a
0.1 or a minus 0.1 the next hidden layer
might pick that up and say oh this piece
of information is uncertain or this
value has a very low certainty to it and
then the hyperbolic tangent function and
you can see here it's a 1 minus e to the
minus 2x over 1 plus e to the minus 2x
and it's very much along the same theme
a little bit different in here in that
it goes between -1 and 1. so you'll see
some of these they go 0 to 1 but this
one goes minus 1 to 1. and if it's less
than zero it's you know it doesn't fire
and if it's over zero it fires and it
also still puts out a value so you still
have a value you can get off of that
just like you can with the sigmoid
function and the relu function very
similar in use and i believe the
originally used to be everything was
done in the sigmoid function that was
the most commonly used and now they just
kind of use more the relu function the
reason is one it processes faster
because you already have the value and
you don't have to add another compute
the 1 over one plus e to the minus x for
each hidden node and the data coming off
works pretty good as far as putting it
into the next level if you want to know
just how close it is to zero how close
is it not to functioning you know is it
minus point one minus point two usually
they're float values you get like minus
point minus 0.00138 or something so yeah
important information but the relu is
most commonly used these days as far as
the setup we're using but you'll also
see the sigmoid function very commonly
used also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition ocr is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify what's written on the plate and
as it comes out you'll see the red node
and the red node might actually
represent just a letter a so there's
usually a lot of outputs when you're
doing text identification we're not
going to show that on here but you might
have it even in the order it might be
what order the license plates in so you
might have a b c d e f g
you know the alphabet plus the numbers
and you might have the one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
places so it's a very large array that
comes out it's not a small amount of you
know we show three dots coming in eight
hidden layer nodes you know two sets of
four we just saw one red coming out a
lot of times this is uh you know 28
times 28 if you did 30 times 30 that's
you know 900 nodes so 28 is a little bit
less than that uh just on the input and
so you can imagine the hidden layer is
just as big each hidden layer is just as
big if not bigger and the output is
going to be there's so many digits yeah
it's a lot there's it's a huge amount of
input and output but we're only showing
you just you know it would be hard to
show in one picture and so it comes up
and this is what it finally gets out on
the output as it identifies a number on
the plate and in this case we have 0 8
d
through
error in the output is back propagated
through the network and weights are
adjusted to minimize the error rate this
is calculated by a cost function when
we're training our data this is what's
used and we'll look at that in the code
when we do the data training so we have
stuff we know the answer to and then we
put the information through and it says
yes that was correct or no because
remember we randomly set all the weights
to begin with and if it's wrong we take
that error how far off are you you know
are you off by is it if it was like
minus one you're just a little bit off
if it's like minus 300 was your output
remember when we're looking at those
different options you know hyperbolic or
whatever and we're looking at the rel
the rel doesn't have a limit on top or
bottom it actually just generates a
number so if it's way off you have to
adjust those weights a lot but if it's
pretty close you might adjust the
weights just a little bit and you keep
adjusting the weights until they fit all
the different training models you put in
so you might have 500 training models
and those weights will adjust using the
back propagation it sends the error
backward the output is compared with the
original result and multiple iterations
are done to get the maximum accuracy so
not only does it look at each one but it
goes through it and just keeps cycling
through these the data making small
changes in the network until it gets the
right answers with every iteration the
weights at every interconnection are
adjusted based on the error we're not
going to dive into that math because it
is a differential equation and it gets a
little complicated but i will talk a
little bit about some of the different
options they have when we look at the
code so we've explored a neural network
let's look at the different types of
artificial neural networks and this is
like the biggest area growing is how
these all come together let's see the
different types of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them used this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get which where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexus or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90 so you
now can add different things in there
and it connects them together the input
features are taken in batches like a
filter this allows a network to remember
an image in parts convolution neural
network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so they
can do a face recognition on each person
applications used in signal and image
processing in this case i use facial
images or google picture images as one
of the options modular neural network it
has a collection of different neural
networks working together to get the
output so wow we just went through all
these different types of neural networks
and the final one is to put multiple
neural networks together i mentioned
that a little bit when we separated
people in a larger photo in individuals
in the photo and then do the facial
recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a cutting
edge you hear the term pipeline and
there's actual in python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just cutting edge and
it's so experimental i mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain then
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feed forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenon self
organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
it brings them all together and no the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
the dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little start-up company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python
3.6 it's always nice to tell people the
version of python because it does affect
sometimes which modules you load and
everything and we're going to start by
importing the required packages i told
you we're going to do this in karass so
we're going to import from karas models
sequential from the cross layers
conversion 2d or conv 2d max pooling 2d
flatten and dents and we'll talk about
what each one of these do in just a
second but before we do that let's talk
a little bit about the environment we're
going to work in and you know in fact
let me go ahead and open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about karass so
here we are on the cross website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s
dot io that's the official website for
cross and the first thing you'll notice
is that cross runs on top of either
tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or theano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the keras and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit we talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we were
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size there
we go that's big i can add in an r e l u
layer and then i can add in a soft max
layer in the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one set up and then i feed
the output into the next one this one i
can just add hidden layer after hidden
layer with the different information in
it which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 36
because i'm in python 36. anaconda is
cool that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing is you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit-learn
pillow and h5py
are both needed for the tensorflow and
then putting the cross on there and then
you'll see here and pip is just a
standard installer that you use with
python you'll see here that we did pip
install tensorflow since we're going to
do cross on top of tensorflow and then
pip install and i went ahead and used
the github so git plus git and you'll
see here github.com this is one of their
releases one of the most current release
on there that goes on top of tensorflow
and you can look up these instructions
pretty much anywhere this is for doing
it on anaconda certainly you'd want to
install these if you're doing it in
ubuntu server setup you'd want to get i
don't think you need the h5py and ubuntu
but you do need the rest in there
because they are dependencies in there
and it's pretty straightforward and
that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can say i have
python 30.5 on python36 i used to have a
bunch of other ones but it kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my in this case
i'm using google chrome and in here i
could go and just create a new document
in here and this is all in your browser
winner when you use the anaconda do you
have to use anaconda in jupyter notebook
no you can use any kind of python editor
whatever setup you're comfortable with
and whatever you're doing in there so
let's go ahead and go in here and paste
the code in and we're importing a number
of different settings in here we have
import sequential it's under the models
because that's the model we're going to
use as far as our neural network and
then we have layers and we have
conversion 2d max pooling 2d flatten
dense and you can actually just kind of
guess at what these do we're talking
we're working in a 2d photograph and if
you remember correctly i talked about
how the actual input layer is a single
array it's not in two dimensions it's
one dimension all these do is these are
tools to help flatten the image so it
takes a two dimensional image and then
it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you notice i'm always sipping coffee i
always have a in my case latte next to
me an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're picking specific
objects your specific it's a true or
false yes no it is something or it's not
so first thing we're going to create our
classifier and it's going to equal
sequential so their sequential setup is
the classifier that's the actual model
we're using that's the neural network so
we call it a classifier and the next
step is to add in our convolution and
let me just do a let me shrink that down
in size you can see the whole line and
let's talk a little bit about what's
going on here i have my classifier and i
add something what am i adding well i'm
adding my first layer this first layer
we're adding in is probably the one that
takes the most work to make sure you
have it set correct and the reason i say
that this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
picture is coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's a value coming out based on
the weights and the value going in and
from there you know it's uh it's if it's
over one then it's good or over zero
it's good if it's under zero then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in-depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to
two-dimensional kind of setup so it's
very aware that this is a photograph and
that different pieces are next to each
other and then we're going to add in a
second convolutional layer that's what
the conv stands for 2d so these are
hidden layers so we have our input layer
and our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two dimensions by we actually
have 64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by karas i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 as 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple whatever
the data shape you're already using is
in and we're using the activation the
relu just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
because we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog if you love both
dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't want a any kind of in-between
number coming out and we'll go ahead and
run this and you'll see it's still all
in setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might blur that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
with these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the karass website to explore them
deeper but we are going to go and run
them and now we've set up our classifier
so we have an object classifier and if
you go back up here you'll see that
we've added in step one we added in our
layer for the input we added a layer
that comes in there and uses the relu
for activation and then it pulls the
data so this is even though these are
two layers the actual neural network
layer is up here and then it uses this
to pull the data into a two by two so
into two dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our adder
flattened and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128
and we use the relu again and then
finally we reduce that down to just a
single output and we use the sigmoid to
do that to figure out whether it's yes
no true false in this case cat or dog
and then finally once we put all these
layers together we compile them that's
what we've done here and we've compiled
them as far as how it trains to use
these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it or you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing and
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255 so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the class is
we're switching everything to a binary
value batch size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 of the images as test and 80 to
train it and then finally we've set up
all our data we've set up all our layers
which is where all the work is is
cleaning up that data making sure it's
going in there correctly and we're
actually going to fit it we're going to
train our data set and let's see what
that looks like and here we go let's put
the information in here and let's just
take a quick look at what we're looking
at with our fit generator we have our
classifier dot fit generator that's our
back propagation so the information goes
through forward with a picture and it
says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the air goes backward and
reprograms all those weights so we're
training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training set up
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8 000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 25 times
but we're going to look at each picture
during each epic 8 000 times so we're
really programming the heck out of this
and going back over it and then they
have validation data equals test set so
we have our training set and then we're
going to have our test set to validate
it so we're going to do this all in one
shot and we're going to look at that and
they're going to do 200 steps for each
validation and we'll see what that looks
like in just a minute let's go ahead and
run our training here and we're going to
fit our data and as it goes it says epic
1 of 25 you start realizing that this is
going to take a while on my older
computer it takes about 45 minutes i
have a dual processor and we're
processing uh 10 000 photos that's not a
small amount of photographs to process
so if you're on your laptop you know
which i am it's going to take a while so
let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i change these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here we have 8 000
pictures we're going through so for each
epic i'm going to change this to four
thousand and cut that in half so it's
going to randomly pick 4 000 pictures
each time it goes through an epic and
the epic is how many processes so this
is 25 and i'm just going to cut that to
10. so instead of doing 25 runs through
8 000 photos each which you can do the
math of 25 times 8 000. i'm only going
to do 10 through 4 000 so i'm going to
run this 40 000 times through the
processes and the next thing i know that
you'll you'll want to notice is that i
also change the validation step and this
would cause some major problems in
releasing because i dropped it all the
way down to 10. what the validation step
does is it says we have 2 000 photos in
our trainings or in our testing set and
we're going to use that for validation
well i'm only going to use a random 10
of those to validate so not really the
best settings but let me show you why we
did that let's scroll down here just a
little bit and let's look at the output
here and see what that what's going on
there so i've got my drawing tool back
on and you'll see here it lists a run so
each time it goes through an epic it's
going to do 4 000 steps and this is
where the 4000 comes in so that's what
we have we have epic one of 10 4
thousand steps is randomly picking half
the pictures in the file and going
through them and then we're going to
look at this number right here that is
for the whole epic and that's 2411
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25. so that's roughly a
couple days a couple days of processing
well for this demo we don't want to do
that i don't want to come back the next
day plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs
gigahertz per second for a laptop it was
good about four years ago but for
running something like this is probably
a little slow so we cut the times down
and the last one was validation we're
only validating it on a random 10 photos
and this comes into effect because
you're going to see down here where we
have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let me just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and you know
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy's a
very common package i pretty much
imported on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you can use the standard
data array from python and we have cross
pre-processing import image fish that
all look familiar because we're going to
take a test image and we're going to set
that equal to in this case cat or dog
one as you can see over here and you
know let me get my drawing tool back on
so let's take a look at this we have our
test image we're loading and in here we
have test image one and this one hasn't
data hasn't seen this one at all so this
is all new let me shrink the screen down
let me start that over so here we have
my test image and we went ahead and the
cross processing has this nice image set
up so we're going to load the image and
we're going to alter it to a 64 by 64
print so right off the bat we're going
to cross as nice that way it
automatically sets it up for us so we
don't have to redo all our images and
find a way to reset those and then we
use also to set the image to an array so
again we're all in pre-processing the
data just like we pre-processed before
with our test information and our
training data and then we use the numpy
here's our numpy that's from our right
up here important numpy as in p expand
the dimensions test image axes equal
zero so it puts it into a single array
and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and uh we
have a second picture over here let's
just see what happens when we run the
second picture we can go up here and
change this from dog image one to two
we'll run that and it comes down here
and says cat you can see me highlighting
it down there as cat so our process
works you are able to label a dog a dog
and a cat a cat just from the pictures
there we go cleared my drawing tool and
the last thing i want you to notice when
we come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see it has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of 1. well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happened to come up one now when
they ran this on the server it actually
came up about 86
this is why cutting these numbers down
so far for a commercial release is bad
so you want to make sure you're a little
careful of that when you're testing your
stuff that you change these numbers back
when you run it on a more enterprise
computer other than your old laptop that
you're just practicing on or messing
with and we come down here and again you
know we had the validation of cat and so
we have successfully built a neural
network that could distinguish between
photos of a cat and a dog imagine all
the other things you could distinguish
imagine all the different industries you
could dive into with that just being
able to understand those two difference
of pictures what about mosquitoes could
you find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
back propagation and gradient descent
we're talking neural networks so we talk
about the neural network this is a
simple neural network which must be
trained to recognize handwritten
alphabets a b and c and you can see here
we have our input coming in in this case
we'll look at the letter a written out
on a 28 by 28 pixels so the handwritten
outputs are presented as images of 28 by
28 pixels and that image comes in in
this case we have 784 neurons that's 28
times 28 and the initial prediction is
made using random weights assigned to
each channel and so we have our forward
propagation as you see here so each node
is then their values are added up and
added up and so on going across and our
network predicts the input to be b with
a probability of 0.5 the predicted
probabilities are compared against the
actual probabilities and the errors
calculated so the error is simply the
actual minus predicted and you can see
here where we know it's not c so it's a
minus two we know it's not b so it's a
minus point five but we do know that it
is a
a so we go ahead and adjust that by 0.6
the magnitude indicates the amount of
change while the sign indicates an
increase or decrease in the weights the
information is transmitted back through
the network so here comes our back
propagation weights throughout the
network are adjusted in order to reduce
the loss in prediction so if we look at
this setup right here here comes our
error in this case 0.6 minus 0.5 minus
0.2 that comes up and adjusts our 1.4.9
all our multipliers in this manner we
keep training the network with multiple
inputs until it is able to predict with
a high accuracy and you can see here we
have a different a quickly switches from
cursive a to maybe more elongated a
similarly our network is trained with
the images for b and c two so let's take
a look at this uh here's a
straightforward data sets let's build a
neural network to predict the outputs
given the inputs and so we have an input
zero we expect an output of zero we have
an input of one we expect six 2 equals
12 3 should come out as 18 and 4 as 24.
and we're just doing multiples of 6 if
you take the time to look at it so in
our example we have our input and it
goes into our neural network so this box
represents our neural network one of the
cool things about neural networks is
there always this little black box that
you kind of train to do what you want
and you really don't have to know
exactly what the weights are although
there are some very high end setups to
start looking at those weights and how
they work and what they do and then you
get your output which is going to be in
this case our input is going to be x and
our output's going to be y and w is the
weight so we have a value times the
weight so if we're doing in this case
just a single neuron going through we
have x times w the network starts
training itself by choosing a random
value for w we're going to guess that w
equals three just roll the dice randomly
generate the number three for w and then
we put w equals three in here we have
our input zero or output 0 w equals 3
equals 0. so we have no error on the
first line that actually comes out
correct and then we have 1 times when we
put the 1 in we're looking for a 6 but
we get a 3 instead when we put the 2 in
we're looking for a 12 we get a six in
set so you can see here our predicted
output doesn't match the output we're
looking for and then we take this we
have our w equals three and we come up
with the second model where the w equals
six now we're going to look at how we
figure out w equals 6 in just a minute
that is part of the math behind this but
you can see here we put in w equals 6
and we build the w equals 6 chart we end
up with 0 6 12 18 24 which is the output
we're looking for and in that manner we
end up with the correct answer but we'll
go ahead and put in a third model where
w equals 9. so at this point this is one
way of doing this is just to guess what
w equals and you can see with w equals 9
we get the incorrect answers we get 9 18
27 36 we as humans can know just by
taking a look at the data that our
weight should be six but how does the
machine come to this conclusion how do
we program the computer to learn instead
of waiting for us to tell it it has the
right answer what the correct answer is
and you can imagine this is a very
simple problem if we're doing guessing w
equals three we guess w equals six we
guess w equals nine and we look at our
results and we go oh it's gotta be w
equals 6. that's the best result but as
humans we want to take that element out
and have the computer do that for us so
with that we're going to have a loss
function the loss function is a measure
of error which defines the precision
lost to comparing the predicted output
to the actual output and it's simply
loss equals actual output minus
predicted output and then we square the
whole thing so let's apply the loss
function to the input value 2 loss for
our actual output predicted output
squared and our last function for the
input of 2 we end up with an actual
output of 12 and you can see here with w
equals 3 12 minus 6 squared equals 36 so
we end up with a loss of 36 w equals 6
12 12 times 12 squared equals 12 minus
12 squared equals zero or 12 minus 18
squared equals 36 and so you can see we
have a huge loss on w equals three and w
equals nine we now plot a graph for the
weight versus loss and it always helps
to have a nice visual of what's going on
here so this graphical method of finding
the minimal of a function is called
radiant descent and this is the logic
behind this you can see as we come in
here and we go ahead and graph the loss
we have 36 for three and 36 for nine we
happen to guess six which was uh the
correct answer right in the middle and
you can see right here forms a nice
little parabola and you can see a nice
mark right in the middle and as a human
being we can look at that we go ah the
answer's six a random point on this
curve is chosen and the slope at this
point is calculated so now we're getting
away from the human aspect of just
looking at it and saying what the answer
is and we look at what's going on with
the math and so if we have a positive
slope but indicates an increase in the
weight and a negative slope indicates a
decrease in weight this time the slope
is negative hence another random point
towards its left is chosen and you can
see here we're actually kind of just
playing a little high-low game going
back and forth with the gradient descent
we continue checking slopes at various
points in this manner so we have our
input actual output w3 w6 w9 we found
our positive slope increase an increase
in weight a negative slope indicates a
decrease in weight a zero slope
indicates the appropriate weight so our
aim is to reach a point where the slope
is zero and when we talk about neural
networks you're usually processing a
massive amount of information and data
so you're not going to have
all your data nice and neat where it's
just a multiple of 6. it's going to be
messy and so we're going to keep
approaching that number but you'll never
get everything to fit at zero you're
going to get stuff all over the place
and so you're really looking for the
minimum value you're not looking for an
absolute zero because you're not going
to get it once we're talking about
gradient descent that's what we're
talking about on there is finding the
bottom of that curve even if it doesn't
go all the way to zero so how do we
apply that to our neural network well we
use back propagation back propagation is
a process of updating weights of the
network in order to reduce the error in
prediction and so the magnitude of loss
of any point on our graph combined with
the slope is fed back to the network and
you can see here here's our simple model
with just one node of x times w the
input comes in we have our x times w the
output and then we're going to propagate
that loss going the other way a random
point on the graph gives a loss value of
36 with a positive slope and we continue
checking slopes at various points in
this manner so a random point in the
graph gives a loss value of 36 with a
positive slope 36 is quite a large
number this means our current weight
needs to change by a large number a
positive slope indicates that the change
of the weight must be positive similarly
another random point on the graph gives
a loss value of 10 with a negative slope
10 is a small number hence the weight
requires to be tuned quite less a
negative slope indicates that the weight
needs to be reduced rather than
increased after multiple iterations of
back propagation our weights are
assigned the appropriate value you can
see here we have our our input we just
looked at x times six in our output and
eventually we get it that the weight is
six for the single node problem that
we're working on right now at this point
our network is trained and can be used
to make predictions let's now get back
to our first example and see where the
back propagation and gradient descent
fall into place and you can see here
we're not looking at a single node
anymore now we have 28 by 28 grid or 784
inputs coming into the first level which
has 784 nodes depending on how you build
your neural network the next layer might
also have 784 nodes or it might
continually smallen depending on what
you need and what's needed for that to
work so as mentioned earlier predicted
output is compared against the actual
output and you can see our error over
here actual minus prediction and then we
go ahead and compute our loss so the
loss of a is 0.7 squared equals 0.49
loss of b is 0.5 squared or 0.25 and so
on so now we have our first iteration on
there so weights throughout the network
are adjusted in order to reduce the loss
in prediction now of course we do that
by doing a second iteration coming
through with our different losses on
there and then weights throughout the
network are just in order to reduce the
loss and prediction again underneath the
second and we do a third iteration and
we just keep doing these iterations
going back until we get the right value
now you got to remember that when we're
doing a reverse propagation we're not
looking at just one letter a we're
looking at hundreds of letter a's and
usually we propagate that loss going
backwards we only take a small piece of
it so our adjustments are very small
because one of them is not correct we
don't want to create a bias so we talk
about back propagation we're talking
about going through over and over and
over this data until we get minimal loss
for our letter a so let's focus on the
minimal loss for our variable a and you
can see here we look at that we end up
we'll assume for below to be our graph
for the loss of prediction with the
variable a as compared to the way it's
continuing it from the second layer and
we have our loss of a for 49 for 16
for 0.04 and you can see it makes this
nice curve where we can guess where the
bottom of this curve is and i like it on
this graph that they show that the curve
doesn't rest yeah on the x axis it
doesn't rest at where y equals 0 because
you usually don't get that you don't get
a perfect fit on anything or very rarely
do you ever get a perfect fit and so the
random points chosen on the graph is now
back propagated through the network in
order to adjust the weights so we're
able to go back through the network and
readjust those weights until we find
that minimal value the network is run
once again with the new weights this
process is repeated multiple times till
provides accurate predictions the
weights are further justify adjusted to
identify b and c 2. and this is
interesting because you actually do them
at the same time so as the error goes
back you kind of find the overall error
for all the inputs coming in and then
that's what gets propagated going back
or the overall loss kind of have to step
away from that word error because it's
not just about the error it's about the
loss the weights are further adjusted to
identify b and c two and so a lot of
times you actually do them all at the
same time but you'll adjust those
weights a b and c as i was just saying
thus through gradient descent and back
propagation our network is completely
trained and we've taught it to identify
a b and c coming forward
one of the interesting things about
neural networks is the training process
takes a lot longer than the predicting
process so you can plan one of these
training neural networks doing the back
propagation to uh significantly longer
because you're going over thousands of
data points and then when you actually
run it forward it's very quick which
makes these things very useful and just
really part of today's world in
computing today we're going to be
covering the convolutional neural
network tutorial do you know how deep
learning recognizes the objects in an
image and really this particular neural
network is how image recognition works
it's very central one of the biggest
building blocks for image recognition it
does it using convolution neural network
and we over here we have the basic
picture of a hummingbird pixels of an
image fed as input you have your input
layer coming in so it takes that graphic
and puts it into the input layer you
have all your hidden layers and then you
have your output layer and your output
layer one of those is gonna light up and
say oh it's a bird we're gonna go into
depth we're going to actually go back
and forth on this a number of times
today so if you're not catching all the
image don't worry we're going to get
into the details so we have our input
layer accepts the pixels of the image as
input in the form of arrays and you can
see up here where they've actually
labeled each block of the bird in
different arrays so we'll dive into deep
as to how that looks like and how those
matrixes are set up your hidden layer
carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the cnn what is
convolution neural network how cnn
recognizes images we're going to dig
deeper into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the cnn we'll
begin our introduction to the cnn by
introducing the pioneer of convolutional
neural network jan le [ __ ] he was the
director of facebook ai research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called lenette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process
cnn is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by producing data with a
grid-like topology a cnn is also known
as a convent and very key to this is we
are looking at images that was what this
was designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in near some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using uh tensorflow
and keras in our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers are two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful of a couple rose
bushes in my yard they go into the input
layer that data is then sent to all the
different nodes in the next layer one of
the hidden layers based on its different
weights and its setup it then comes out
and gives those a new value those values
then are multiplied by their weights and
go to the next hidden layer and so on
and then you have the output layer and
one of those notes comes out and says
it's an orchid and the other one comes
out and says it's a rose depending on
how was well it was trained what
separates the cnn or the convolutional
neural network from other neural
networks is a convolutional operation
forms the basis of any convolutional
neural network in a cnn every image
image is represented in the form of
arrays of pixel values so here we have a
real image of the digit 8.
that then gets put on to
its pixel values represented in the form
of an array in this case you have a
two-dimensional array and then you can
see in the final in form we transform
the digit eight into its
representational form of pixels of zeros
and one where the ones represent in this
case the black part of the eight and the
zeros represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it and
we're going to take two matrices a and b
of one dimension now kind of separate
this from your thinking as we learned
that you want to focus just on the
matrix aspect of this and then we'll
bring that back together and see what
that looks like when we put the pieces
for the convolutional operation here
we've set up two arrays we have in this
case are a single dimension matrix and
we have a equals five three seven five
nine seven and we have b equals one two
three so in the convolution as it comes
in there's gonna look at these two and
we're gonna start by doing multiplying
them a times b and so we multiply the
arrays element wise and we get 5 6 6
where 5 is the 5 times 1 6 is 3 times 2
and then the other six is two times
three and since the two arrays aren't
the same size they're not the same setup
we're gonna just truncate the first one
and we're gonna look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that's
gonna be a little confusing remember a
computer gets to repeat these processes
hundreds of times so we're not going to
just forget those other numbers later on
we'll see we'll bring those back in and
then we have the sum of the product in
this case 5 plus 6 plus 6 equals 17. so
in our a times b
our very first digit in that matrix of a
times b is 17. and if you remember i
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 3 2 5 we move one
set over and we take 3 2 5 and we
multiply that times b and you'll see
that 3 times 1 is 3 2 times 2 is 4 and
so on and so on we sum it up so now we
have the second digit of our a times b
product in the matrix and we continue on
with that same thing so on and so on so
then we would go from three seven five
to seven five nine to five nine seven
this short matrix that we have for a
we've now covered all the different
entities in a that match three different
levels of b now in a little bit we're
going to cover where we use this math at
this multiplying of matrixes and how
that works
but it's important to understand that
we're going through the matrix and
multiplying the different parts to it to
match the smaller matrix with the larger
matrix i know a lot of people get lost
at is what's going on here with these
matrixes oh scary math not really that
scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to b so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so i'm i'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and i'm
bringing the value down into one matrix
a times b we're deucing that information
in a way that will help the computer see
different aspects let's go ahead and
flip over again back to our images
here we are back to our images talking
about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed and you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
relu isn't how it act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that a
lot of other neural networks when you're
using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used i like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only 0 and 1. now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter
is going to be derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have mini
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this so we're going to predict the first
one and slide it over one notch predict
the second one and so on and so on all
the way through until we have a new
matrix and this matrix which is the same
size as the filter has reduced the image
and whatever filter whatever that's
filtering out it's going to be looking
at just those features reduced down to a
smaller matrix so once the feature maps
are extracted the next step is to move
them to the relu layer so the relu layer
the next step first is going to perform
an element-wise operation so each of
those maps coming in if there's negative
pixels so it says all the negative
pixels to zero and you can see this nice
graph where it just zeros out the
negatives and then you have a value that
goes from 0 up to whatever value is
coming out of the matrix this introduces
non-linearity to the network
so up until now we have a we say
linearity we're talking about the fact
that the feature has a value so it's a
linear feature this feature
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw you'll look
at that and say okay this feature has a
value from negative 10 to 10 in this
case if it was one it'd say yeah this
might be a beak it might not might be an
edge right there a minus five means no
we're not even going to look at it to
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these features all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with a
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix
one more aspect to note about the relu
layer is we're not just having one relu
coming in
so not only do we have multiple features
going through but we're generating
multiple relu layers for locating the
features that's very important to note
you know so we have a quite a bundle we
have multiple filters multiple rail u uh
which brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to a
single answer this is a specific kind of
bird this is an iris this is a rose so
you have a rectified feature map
you see here we have a rectified feature
map coming in
we set the max pooling with a two by two
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time uh well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a st we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which is you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a 4x4 so
we're continually trying to filter and
reduce our data so that we can get to
something we can manage and over here
you see that we have the max
3 four one and two and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now finding the
max value and then we're pulling those
features together so instead of thinking
this is image of the map think of this
as how valuable is a feature in that
area how much of a feature value do we
have and we just want to find the best
or the maximum feature for that area
they might have that one piece of the
filter of the beak set up i see a one in
this beak in this image and then it
skips over and says i see a three in
this image and says oh this one is rated
as a four we don't want to sum it
together because then you know you might
have like five ones and i'll say ah five
but you might have uh four zeros and 110
and that 10 says well this is definitely
a beak where the ones will say probably
not a beak a little strange analogy
since we're looking at a bird but you
can see how that pulled feature map
comes down and we're just looking for
the max value in each one of those
matrixes
pooling layer uses different filters to
identify different parts of the image
like edges corners body feathers eyes
beak etc i know i focus mainly on the
beak but obviously each feature could be
each a different part of the bird coming
in so let's take a look at what that
looks like structure of a convolution
neural network so far this is where
we're at right now we have our input
image coming in and then we use our
filters and there's multiple filters on
there that are being developed to kind
of twist and change that data and so we
multiply the matrixes we take that
little filter maybe it's a two by two we
multiply it by each piece of the image
and if we step two then it's every other
piece of the image that generates
multiple convolution layers so we have a
number of convolution layers we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the relu setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
relu then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes multiple dimensions you can
have three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions uh so
right now we're looking at 2d image
dimensions coming in into the pooling
layer so the next step is we want to
reduce those dimensions or flatten them
so flattening flattening is a process of
converting all of the resultant
two-dimensional arrays from pooled
feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values 6847 and we want to just
flatten this out and turn it into 6847
or a single linear vector and we find
out that not only do we do each of the
pooled feature maps we do all of them
into one long linear vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we flatten them out and combine them
into a single linear vector going in so
after we've done the flattening we have
just a quick recap because we've covered
so much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network so far is we have our
convolution where we twist it and we
filter it and multiply the matrixes we
end up with our convolutional layer
which uses the relu to figure out the
values going out into the pooling as you
have numerous convolution layers that
then create numerous pooling layers
pulling that data together which is the
max value which one we want to send
forward we want to send the best value
and then we're going to take all of that
from each of the pooling layers and
we're going to flatten it and we're
going to combine them into a single
input going into the final layer once
you get to that step you might be
looking at that going boy that looks
like the normal intuit to most neural
network and you're correct it is
so once we have the flattened matrix
from the pooling layer that becomes our
input so the pooling layer is fed as an
input to the fully connected layer to
classify the image and so you can see as
our flattened matrix comes in in this
case we have the pixels from the
flattened matrix fed as an input back to
our toucan or whatever that kind of bird
that is i need one of these to identify
what kind of bird that is it comes into
our ford propagation network
and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix and the two matrixes multiplied
all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the relu as this activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then and the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the cnn recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice because it's
showing the little pixels and where
they're going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relu for the
pooling the pulling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification in the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps we have one two three four five
different steps going on here with sub
steps in there we're going to break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
cnn we'll be using the cfar10 dataset
from canadian institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very cutting edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment i mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in industry so great
time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script
before we go on let's do uh one more
quick look at what we have here let's
just take a look at data batch one keys
and remember jupiter notebook i can get
by with not doing the print statement if
i put a variable down there it'll just
display the variable and you can see
under data batch one for the keys since
this is a dictionary we have the batch
one label data and file names so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the images using matte plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even well there's other
ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupiter notebook i need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.pipelot
as plt and if you remember matplot
library the pie plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign matplot library inline
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as np for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch 1. so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data we need to go
a little bit of reshaping so in here we
have to go ahead and reshape the data we
have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to i had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here so we
have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
i don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
going to break it up into 10 000 pieces
and those 10 000 pieces then are broken
into three pieces each and those three
pieces then are 32 by 32. you can look
at this like an old-fashioned projector
where they have the red screen or the
red projector the blue projector and the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32
by 32 bit so that's probably how this
was originally formatted was in that
kind of ideal things have changed so
we're going to transpose it and we're
going to take the three which was here
and we're going to put it at the end so
the first part is reshaping the data
from a single line of bit data or
whatever format it is into 10 000 by 3
by 32 by 32 and then we're going to
transpose the color factor to the last
place so it's the image then the 32 by
32 in the middle that's this part right
here and then finally we're going to
take this uh which is three bits of data
and put it at the end so it's more like
we do we process images now and then as
type this is really important that we're
going to use an integer eight you can
come in here and you'll see a lot of
these they'll try to do this with a
float or float 64. what you got to
remember though is a float uses a lot of
memory so once you switch this into uh
something that's not integer eight which
goes up to 128 you are just going to the
the amount of ram let me just put that
in here is going to go way up the amount
of ram that it loads so you want to go
ahead and use this you can try the other
ones and see what happens if you have a
lot of ram on your computer but for this
exercise this will work just fine and
let's go ahead and take that and run
this so now our x variable is all loaded
and it has all the images in it from the
batch one data batch one and just to
show we were talking about with the as
type on there if we go ahead and take x0
and just look for its max value let me
go ahead and run that uh you'll see it
doesn't oops i said 128 it's 255. uh
you'll see it doesn't go over 255
because it's basically an ascii
character is what we're keeping that
down to we're keeping those values down
so they're only 255 00 to 255 versus
float value which would bring this up
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matplot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the map plot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and lets just take a look
at what x0 looks like and it comes in
i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image broken
down to the minimal pixels on there and
if we did the same thing oh let's do uh
let's see what one looks like hopefully
it's a little easier to see run on there
not enter let's hit the run on that
and we can see this is probably a semi
truck that's a good guess on there and i
can just go back up here instead of
typing the same line in over and over
and we'll look at three uh that looks
like a dump truck unloading uh and so on
you can do any of the 10 000 images we
can just jump to 55
looks like some kind of animal looking
at us there probably a dog and just for
fun let's do just one more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four uh so you can
see we pace through all the different
images it's very easy to look at them
and they've been reshaped to fit our
view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a
class
cfar helper so it's going to have an
init and a setup for the images and then
finally we'll go ahead and run that code
so you can see what that looks like and
then we get into the fun part where
we're actually going to start creating
our model our actual neural network
model so let's start by creating our one
hot encoder we're going to create our
own here uh i'm just going to return and
out and we'll have our vector coming in
and our values equal 10. what this means
is that we have the 10 values the 10
possible labels and remember we don't
look at the labels as a number because a
car isn't one more than a horse i'd be
just kind of bizarre to have horse
equals zero car equals one plane equals
two cat equals three so a cat plus a car
equals what uh so instead we create a
numpy array of zeros and there's gonna
be ten values so we have a 10 different
values in there so you have
0 or 1 1 means it's a cat 0 means it's
not a cat
in the next line it might be that 1
means it's a car 0 means it's not a car
so instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to 1. that's what
the one hot encoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this in code in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper which is a class and this is
a lot in this class so we'll break it
down here and let's just start uh oops
we put a space right in there there we
go that was a little bit more readable
at a second space so we're going to
create our class the cipher helper and
we'll start by initializing it now
there's a lot going on in here so let's
start with the init part uh self dot i
equals zero i'll come in in a little bit
we'll come back to that in the lower
part we want to initialize our training
batches so when we went through this
there was like a meta batch we don't
need the meta batch but we do need the
data batch one two three four five and
we do not want the testing batch in here
this is just the self all train batches
so we're going to come make an array of
all those different images and then of
course we left the test batch out so we
have our self.test batch
we're going to initialize the training
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part since this is all just helper
stuff but breaking it up again makes it
easier to read it also makes it easier
when we start executing the different
pieces to see what's going on so that
way we have a nice print statement to
say hey we're now running this and this
is what's going on in here we're going
to set up the self training images at
this point and that's going to go to a
numpy array v stack and in there we're
going to load up
in this case the data for d itself all
train batches again that points right up
to here so we're going to go through
each one of these uh files or each one
of these data sets because they're not a
file anymore we've brought them in data
batch one points to the actual data and
so our self training images is going to
stack them all into our into a numpy
array and then it's always nice to get
the training length and that's just the
total number of uh self training images
in there and then we're going to take
the self training images let me switch
marker colors because i am getting a
little bit too much on the markers up
here oops there we go bring down our
marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well we wanted to
look at this above and we want to look
at the images in the matplot library we
had to reshape it so we're doing the
same thing here we're taking our self
training images and based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying a 32 by 32 we're going
to switch that around so that now we
have each of our images that stays the
same place and then we have our 32 by 32
and then by our three our last are three
different values for the color and of
course we want to go ahead and they run
this where you say divide by 255 that
was from earlier it just brings all the
data into zero to one that's what this
is doing so we're turning this into a
zero to one array which is uh all the
pictures 32 by 32 by 3 and then we're
going to take the self training labels
and we're going to pump those through
our one hot encoder we just made and
we're going to stack them together and
uh again we're converting this into an
array that goes from
instead of having horse equals 1 dog
equals 2 and then horse plus dog would
equal 3 which would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of 10 where each one is 0 to 1. then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just changed colors right here this
is no different than what we're doing up
here with our training set
we're going to stack the different
images
we're going to get the length of them so
we know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand tis to throw me for a little
loop when i'm working with tensorflow or
cross or a lot of these we have our data
coming in if you remember we had like 10
000 photos let me just put 10 000 down
here we don't want to run all 10 000 at
once so we want to break this up into
batch sizes and you also remember that
we had the number of photos in this case
a length of test or whatever number is
in there we also have 32 by 32 by 3. so
when we're looking at the batch size we
want to change this from 10 000 to
a batch of in this case i think we're
going to do batches of a hundred so we
want to look at just 100 the first
hundred of the photos and if you
remember we set self i
equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create x we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialize we've already initialized it
for zero so we're going to look at x
from zero to batch size which we set to
100 so just the first hundred images and
then we're going to reshape that into uh
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3. now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
in the correct shape and then the y just
like the x uh is our labels so our
training labels again they go from zero
to batch size in this case they do sell
fi plus batch size because the cell phi
is going to keep changing and then
finally we increment the self i because
we have zero so we so the next time we
call it we're going to get the next
batch size and so basically we have x
and y x being the photograph data coming
in and y being the label and that of
course is labeled through one hot
encoder so if you remember correctly if
it was say horse is equal to zero it
would be
one for the zero position since this is
the horse and then everything else would
be zero in here let me just put lines
through there there we go there's our
array hard to see that array so let's go
ahead and take that and we're going to
finish loading it since this is our
class and now we're armed with all this
our setup over here let's go ahead and
load that up and so we're going to
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're going to do
ch.setup images
now we could have just put all the setup
images under the init but by breaking
this up into two parts it makes it much
more readable and also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup i
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch as we have to run uh
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float 64. uh nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to a 255
value or zero to one and do keep in mind
that zero to one value that we converted
the 255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow uh
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get a better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what the
first value is and then 32 by 32 by 3
that's what we reshaped our data to fit
in and then we have our y true equals
placeholder tf float32 and the shape
equals none comma 10. 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10. and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this uh hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call drop out
if you remember from our theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use keras it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct cross sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the
nist setup let me just put that in there
if you're under the tensorflow so a lot
of these already in there but we're
going to go ahead and do our own and
we're going to create our init weights
and one of the reasons we're doing this
is so that you can actually start
thinking about what's going on in the
back end so even though there's ways to
do this with an automation sometimes
these have to be tweaked and you have to
put in your own setup in here now we're
not going to be doing that we're just
going to recreate them for our code and
let's take a look at this we have our
weights and so what comes in is going to
be the shape and what comes out is going
to be a random number so we're going to
go ahead and just knit some random
numbers based on the shape with a
standard deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun
way to do that and then the tf variable
init random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with
the constant
in this case we're using point one a lot
of times the bias is just put in as one
and then you have your weights add on to
that uh but we're gonna set this as
point one uh so we wanna return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2d is
we're taking our data coming in
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32
by
32
by
3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so it's going to take this
number here and combine it with the 32
by 32. so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
preformatting and the setup and then you
have your actual convolution layer that
goes through on there and you can see
here we have a knit weights by the shape
a knit bias shape of three because we
have the three different uh here's our
three again and then we return the tfnn
relu with the convention 2d so this
convolutional has this feeding into it
right there it's using that as part of
it and of course the input is the x y
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2d coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data if you remember
correctly on the on the pool side and
let me just get rid of all my marks it's
getting a little crazy there and in fact
let's go ahead and jump back to that
slide let's just take a look at that
slide over here
so we have our image coming in we create
our convolutional layer with all the
filters remember the filters go um you
know the filter is coming in here and it
looks at these four boxes and then if
it's a step let's say step two it then
goes to these four boxes and then the
next step and so on uh so we have our
convolutional layer that we generate or
convolutional layers they use the uh
relu function there's other functions
out there for this though the relu is
the most the one that works the best at
least so far i'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was max
so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a 1 and maybe a 2 here and
another 1 here and a three here three is
the max and so out of all of these you
then create an array that would be three
and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down reducing it down as small as
we can and then finally
we're going to flatten it out into a
single array and that goes into our
fully connected layer and you can see
that here in the code right here we're
going to create our normal full layer so
at some point we're going to take from
our pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here and so we have
our input size you'll see our input
layer get shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever's coming in
uh and then input size initial weights
is also based on the input layer coming
in and the input size down here is based
on the input layer shape so we're just
going to already use the shape and
already have our size coming in and of
course you have to make sure you knit
the bias always put your bias on there
and we'll do that based on the size so
this will return
tf.mattmole
tf.matimole
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything uh we get to do
all the easy part let's go ahead and
create our layers we'll create a
convolution layer one and two two
different convolutional layers and then
we'll take that and we'll flatten that
out create a reshape pooling in there
for our reshape and then we'll have our
full uh layer at the end so let's start
by creating our first convolutional
layer then we come in here and let me
just run that real quick
and i want you to notice on here the 3
and the 32 this is important because
coming into this convolutional layer we
have three different channels and 32
pixels each
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 4 4 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max toolbar 2x2 and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the x that's
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up
so matches and we went ahead and ran
this already i think i read let me go
and run it again and if we're going to
do one layer let's go ahead and do a
second layer down here and it's uh we'll
call it convo 2.
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional 1 in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional to
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have a four by four going in let's do
eight by eight by 64. so let's do
4096
this is going to be the flat layer so
that's how many bits are coming through
on the flat layer and we'll reshape this
so we'll reshape our
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the relu for our setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it uh
the convo to flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have 1024
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also define
the full one dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in
keep probability equals whole
probability remember we created that
earlier and the full layer one is what's
coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full 1 drop out and 10 because we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 10 24 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
drop out into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have full
layer two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that
we'll see that this is a tensor object
shape question mark 10 d type 32 a quick
way to double check what we're working
on so now we've got all of our we've
done a setup all the way to the y
predict which we just did we want to go
ahead and apply the loss function and
make sure that's set up in there create
the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global tf
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups
we pointed out up here we can change the
four four and use different numbers
there they change your outcome so
depending on what numbers you use here
will have a huge impact on how well your
model fits and that's the same here of
the 10 24 also this is also another
number that if you continue to raise
that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 5 12. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it uh we're
going to feed it our labels and we have
our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this
and so the next step is we're going to
take the error we want to know our cross
entropy or our loss function how much
loss we have that's going to be part of
how we train the model so when you know
what the loss is and we're training it
we feed that back into the back
propagation setup and so we want to go
ahead and optimize that here's our
optimizer we're going to create the
optimizer using an atom optimizer
remember there's a lot of different ways
of optimizing the data atoms the most
popular used so our optimizer is going
to equal the tf train atom optimizer if
you don't remember what the learning
rate is let me just pop this back into
here here's our learning rate when you
have your weights you have all your
weights and your different nodes that
are coming out here's our node coming
out and it has all its weights and then
the error is being prop sent back
through in reverse on our neural network
so we take this error we adjust these
weights based on the different formulas
in this case the atom formula is what
we're using we don't want to just adjust
them completely we don't want to change
this weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by .001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training
variable or function and this is going
to equal our optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
and when we look at this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensorflow and then
initializes those variables
so it's kind of like a magic wand
because it's all hidden in the back end
of tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation
and you have to run that once you have
your setup going so we'll go ahead and
run this piece of code and then we're
going to go ahead and train our data so
let me run this so it's loaded up there
and so now we're going to go ahead and
run the model by creating a graph
session graph session is a tensorflow
term so you'll see that coming up that's
one of the things that throws me because
i always think of graphics and spark and
graph as just general graphing but they
talk about a graph session so we're
going to go ahead and run the model and
let's go ahead and walk through this uh
what's going on here and let's paste
this data in here and here we go so
we're going to start off with a with a
tf session as s so that's our actual tf
session we've created uh so we're right
here with the tf
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here uh and
then we have for i in range 500. so
what's going on here remember 500 we're
going to break the date up and we're
going to batch it in at 500 points each
we've created our session run so we're
going to do with tf session as session
right here we've created our variable
session and then we're going to run
we're going to go ahead and initialize
it so we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created
that initializes our our session in here
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go for i in range of 500
batch equals ch.nextbatch
so if you remember correctly this is
loading up um 100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing uh what
is that 500 times 100 is
50 000. so that's 50 000 pictures we're
going to process right there and the
first process is we're going to do a
session run we're going to take our
train we created our train variable or
optimizer in there we're going to feed
it the dictionary we had our feed
dictionary that we created and we have x
equals batch zero coming in y true batch
one
hold the probability point five and then
just so that we can keep track of what's
going on we're gonna every 100 steps
we're going to run a print so currently
on step format
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf dot equal tf
argument y prediction 1
tf.org max y true comma 1. so we're
going to look at this as how many
matches it has and here our acc uh all
we're doing here is we're going to take
the matches how many matches they have
it creates it generates a chart we're
going to convert that to float that's
what the tfcast does and then we just
want to know the average we just want to
know the average of the accuracy and
then we'll go ahead and print that out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screen's there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run
so let's see what happens on my old
laptop and we'll see here that we have
our current
we're currently on step zero it takes a
little bit to get through the accuracy
and this will take just a moment to run
we can see that on our step zero it has
an accuracy of 0.1 or 0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out he's actually reading that
backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to one the more accuracy we have
so you can see here we've gone from a
point one to a point three nine um and
we'll go ahead and pause this and come
back and see what happens when we're
done with the full run all right now
that we've
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things
first we've defined accuracy
the reason i got it backwards before is
you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal in fact that's
pretty much impos you know unheard of
and the same thing with loss if you have
a loss of zero that's also unheard of
the zero's actually on this this axis
right here as we go in there so how do
we interpret that because you know if i
was looking at this and i go oh 0.51
that's uh 51 you're doing 50 50. no this
is not percentage let me just put that
in there it is not percentage uh this is
log rhythmic what that means is that 0.2
is twice as good as 0.1 and when we see
0.4 that's twice as good as 0.2 real way
to convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50
we're just guessing equals 0.1 and if 50
roughly equals 0.1 that's we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.1028 the accuracy of 50
percent then 75 percent is about 0.2 and
so on and so on don't quote those
numbers because that doesn't work that
way they say that if you have point nine
five that's pretty much saying a hundred
percent and if you have a anywhere
between you'd have to go look this up
let me go and remove all my drawings
there
so the magic number is 0.5 we really
want to be over a 0.5 in this whole
thing and we have
both 0.504 remember this is accuracy if
we were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over 0.5 is pretty valid that means this
is pretty solid and if you get to a 0.95
then it's a direct correlation that's
what we're looking for here in these
numbers you can see we finished with
this model at
0.5135 so still good um and if we look
at when they ran this in the other end
remember there's a lot of randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights they got
.5251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own comes
up a little bit better or worse
depending on just that randomness and so
we've gone through the whole model we've
created we trained the model and we've
also gone through on every 100th run to
test the model to see how accurate it is
we will start with the course of
fundamentals what is a neural network in
popular neural networks it's important
to know the framework we're in and what
we're going to be looking at
specifically then we'll touch on why a
recurrent neural network what is a
recurrent neural network and how does an
rnn work
one of the big things about rnns is what
they call the vanishing and exploding
gradient problem so we'll look at that
and then we're going to be using a use
case uh study that's going to be in
cross on tensorflow cross is a python
module for doing neural networks in deep
learning and in there there's the what
they call long short term memory lstm
and then we'll use the use case to
implement our lstm on the keras so when
you see that lstm that is basically the
rnn network and we'll get into that the
use case is always my favorite part
before we dive into any of this we're
going to take a look at what is an rnn
or an introduction to the rnn do you
know how google's auto complete feature
predicts the rest of the words a user is
typing i love that auto complete feature
as i'm typing away saves me a lot of
time i can just kind of hit the enter
key and it auto fills everything and i
don't have to type as much well first
there's a collection of large volumes of
most frequently occurring consecutive
words
this is fed into a recurrent neural
network analysis the data by finding the
sequence of words occurring frequently
and builds a model to predict the next
word in the sentence and then google
what is the best food to eat in loss i'm
guessing you're going to say loss mexico
no it's going to be las vegas
so the google search will take a look at
that and say hey the most common
autocomplete is going to be vegas in
there it usually gives you three or four
different choices so it's a very
powerful tool it saves us a lot of time
especially when we're doing a google
search or even in microsoft words has a
some people get very matted it autofills
with the wrong stuff but you know you're
typing away and it helps you autofill i
have that in a lot of my different
packages it's just a standard feature
that we're all used to now so before we
dive into the rnn and getting into the
depths let's go ahead and talk about
what is a neural network neural networks
used in deep learning consist of
different layers connected to each other
and work on the structure and functions
of a human brain you're going to see
that thread human in human brain and
human thinking throughout deep learning
the only way we can evaluate an
artificial intelligence or anything like
that is to compare it to human function
very important note on there and it
learns from a huge volumes of data and
it uses complex algorithm to train a
neural net so in here we have image
pixels of two different breeds of dog
one looks like a nice floppy eared lab
and one a german shepherd you know both
wonderful breeds of animals that image
then goes into an input layer that input
layer might be formatted at some point
because you have to let it know like you
know different pictures are going to be
different sizes and different color
content then it'll feed into hidden
layers so each of those pixels or each
point of data goes in and then splits
into the hidden layer which then goes
into another hidden layer which then
goes to an output layer rnn there's some
changes in there which we're going to
get into so it's not just a
straightforward propagation of data like
we've covered in many other tutorials
and finally you have an output layer and
the output layer has two outputs it has
one that lights up if it's a german
shepherd and another that lights up is
if it's a labrador so identify as a
dog's breed set networks do not require
memorizing the past output so our
forward propagation is just that it goes
forward and doesn't have to be memorized
stuff and you can see there that's not
actually me in the picture dressed up in
my suit
i haven't worn a suit in years so as
we're looking at this we're going to
change it up a little bit before we
cover that let's talk about popular
neural networks first there's the feed
forward neural network used in general
regression and classification problems
and we have the convolution neural
network used for image recognition deep
neural network used for acoustic
modeling deep belief network used for
cancer detection and recurrent neural
network used for speech recognition now
taken a lot of these and mixed them
around a little bit so just because it's
used for one thing doesn't mean it can't
be used for other modeling but generally
this is where the field is and this is
how those models are generally being
used right now so we talk about a feed
forward neural network in a feed forward
neural network information flows only in
the forward direction from the input
nodes through the hidden layers if any
into the output nodes there are no
cycles or loops in the network and so
you can see here we have our input layer
i was talking about how it just goes
straight forward into the hidden layers
so each one of those connects and then
connects to the next hidden layer
connects to the output layer and of
course we have a nice simplified version
where it has a predicted output and the
refer to the input as x a lot of times
and the output as y decisions are based
on current input no memory about the
past no future scope why recurrent
neural network issues in feed forward
neural network so one of the biggest
issues is because it doesn't have a
scope of memory or time a feed-forward
neural network doesn't know how to
handle sequential data it only considers
only the current input so if you have a
series of things and because three
points back affects what's happening now
and what your output affects what's
happening that's very important so
whatever i put as an output is going to
affect the next one um a feedforward
doesn't look at any of that it just
looks at this is what's coming in and it
cannot memorize previous inputs so it
doesn't have that list of inputs coming
in solution to feed forward neural
network you'll see here where it says
recurrent neural network and we have our
x on the bottom going to h going to y
that's your feed forward but right in
the middle it has a value c so there's a
whole another process was memorizing
what's going on in the hidden layers and
the hidden layers as they produce data
feed into the next one so your hidden
layer might have an output that goes off
to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second um it's like three terabytes
a day of data so we're going to look at
one stock just analyzing one stock is
really tricky in here we'll give you a
little jump on that so that's exciting
but don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
rnn is natural language processing text
mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using rnn for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than i
if i said processing language natural
leap so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you may get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down i'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's what
gets a little confusing so here we have
xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on h t minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it ht minus one is the
old state coming out and then x of t is
an input vector at time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a
one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is you know kind of a slang
term people will know what you're
talking about usually if you say that
then we run one to many so you have a
single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have mini to one network takes
in a sequence of inputs examples
sentiment analysis where a given
sentence can be classified as expressing
positive or negative sentiments and we
looked at that as we were discussing if
it rains look for a rainbow so positive
sentiment where rain might be a negative
sentiment if you're just adding up the
words in there and then the course if
you're going to do a one-to-one mini to
one one to many there's many to many
networks takes in a sequence of inputs
and generates a sequence of outputs
example machine translation so we have a
lengthy sentence coming in english and
then going out in all the different
languages you know just a wonderful tool
very complicated set of computations you
know if you're a translator you realize
just how difficult it is to translate
into different languages one of the
biggest things you need to understand
when we're working with this neural
network is what's called the vanishing
gradient problem while training an rnn
your slope can be either too small or
very large and this makes training
difficult when the slope is too small
the problem is known as vanishing
gradient and you'll see here they have a
nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on exploding
gradient problem oh this is one that
runs into everybody when you're working
with this particular neural network when
the slope tends to grow exponentially
instead of decaying this problem is
called exploding gradient issues in
gradient problem long training time poor
performance bad accuracy and i'll add
one more in there your computer if
you're on a lower end computer testing
out a model will lock up and give you
the memory error explaining gradient
problem consider the following two
examples to understand what should be
the next word in the sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the air like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe you said
portuguese or french no you probably
said spanish the word we predict will
depend on the previous few words in
context here we need the context of
spain to predict the last word in the
text it's possible that the gap between
the relevant information and the point
where it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning long
term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms
also have a chain-like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior ls
tmss also have a chain-like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x of t
minus 1 coming in you have x of t coming
in and you've got x at t plus 1. and you
have h of t minus 1 and h of t coming in
and h of t plus 1 going out and of
course on the other side is the output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x of t
plus one are we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x of t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing sensing in the lstms and we
look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know a lot of times like you
know is as in a unless we're trying to
look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like so step one decides how much of the
past it should remember first step in
the lstm is to decide which information
to be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus 1 and then
x a t plus of course you have a bias in
there with any of our neural networks so
we have a bias function so f of t equals
forget gate decides which information to
delete that is not important from the
previous time step considering an stm is
fed with the following inputs from the
previous and present time step alice is
good in physics john on the other hand
is good in chemistry so previous output
john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our current input
so as we look at this the first step is
the forget gate realizes there might be
a change in context after encounting the
first full stop compares with the
current input sentence of x a t so we're
looking at that full stop and then
compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
john so the information on alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with john
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to john and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on john since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is a sigmoid
function and the other is the tangent h
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent h function gives a weightage to
the values which are passed deciding
their level of importance minus one to
one and you can see the two formulas
that come up the i of t equals the
sigmoid of the weight of i h to t minus
one x of t plus the bias of i and the c
of t equals the tangent of h of the
weight of c of h of t minus one x of t
plus the bias of c so our i of t equals
the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input at x of t john plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information john plays football and he
was a captain of his college team as
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute
but as a human being if i wanted to get
this information from a conversation
maybe it's a google voice listening in
on you or something like that um how do
we weed out the information that he was
talking to me on the phone yesterday
well i don't want to memorize that he
talked to me on the phone yesterday or
maybe that is important but in this case
it's not i want to know that he was the
captain of the football team i want to
know that he served i want to know that
john plays football and he was the
captain of the college football team
those are the two things that i want to
take away as a human being again we
measure a lot of this from the human
viewpoint and that's also how we try to
train them so we can understand these
neural networks finally we get to step
three decides what part of the current
cell state makes it to the output the
third step is to decide what will be our
output first we run a sigmoid layer
which decides what parts of the cell
state make it to the output then we put
the cell state through the tangent h to
push the values to be between -1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of t we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of 0 of the h of t
minus 1 and back one step in time by the
x of t plus of course the bias the h of
t equals the outer t times the tangent
of the tangent h of c of t so our o t
equals the output gate allows the passed
in information to impact the output in
the current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the next word in
the sentence john played tremendously
well against the opponent and one for
his team for his contributions brave
blank was awarded player of the match
there could be a lot of choices for the
empty space current input brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun
john could be the best output after
brave thumbs up for john awarded player
of the match and if you were to pull
just the nouns out of the sentence team
doesn't look right because that's not
really the subject we're talking about
contributions you know brave
contributions or brave team brave player
brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
it starts looking at and goes oh no john
is what we're talking about so brave is
an adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017.
and this will be a narrow set of data
we're not going to do the whole stock
market it turns out that the new york
stock exchange generates roughly three
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on in each
individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but you at
least you can give an eye you can give a
step forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm let's
dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in python36
and nice thing about anaconda especially
the newer version i remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python in different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
martha stewart's in the old cooking show
so we want to make sure we have all our
tools for you so you're not waiting for
them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end
and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system
and since we're using karass i put an
overlap here
but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the kara setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with um
shareholders or uh
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the evaluate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here crosses
a little bit more but when you're
working with some of the other packages
you might have like three lines that
might be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what i did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the pd or pandas dot read csv and
it's a google stock price train dot csv
and so under this we have training set
equals data set train dot ilocation and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at let's look at the actual file
and see what's going on there now if we
look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and i
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word pad and text editor just so
we can take a look at it certainly you
can open up an excel or any other kind
of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price
and this specifically is google this is
the google stock values from as you can
see here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original
frame let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever you hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scalar and when you look
at this you got to remember that biases
in our data we want to get rid of that
so if you have something that's like a
really high value let's just draw a
quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
um
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between
one and zero so 100 equals one or one
equals a hundred and zero equals five
and you can just multiply it's usually
just a simple multiplication we're using
uh multiplication so it's going to be uh
minus 5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by 1. so or whatever value is is
divided by 95.
and uh once we've actually created our
scale we've tolling is going to be from
0 to 1. we want to take our training set
and we're going to create a training set
scaled and we're going to use our scalar
sc we're going to fit we're going to fit
and transform the training set
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object will use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
and we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1 and then as
i is equal to 60 this value is going to
be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at 0 so this is a count of 60 so
it's actually 59. important to remember
that as we're looking at this and then
the second part of this that we're
looking at so if you remember correctly
here we go we go from 0 to 59 of i and
then we have a comma a 0 right here and
so finally we're just going to look at
the open value now i know we did put it
in there for 1 to 2.
if you remember correctly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i 2 or i comma 0. if
you remember correctly this is 0 to 59
so there's 60 values in it uh so we do i
down here this is number 60. so we're
going to do this is we're creating an
array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a 0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58. that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence uh here's
my open open open open open open what's
the next one in the series so we're
looking at the google stock and each
time it opens we want to know what the
next one zero through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npray train we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly um so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um
in this case where's that value
60 by 11 99 1258 minus 60 11.99 and
we're making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the end layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more and then you get
the leaf np dot reshape comes from and
using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different cross
modules that we need so from cross
models we're going to import the
sequential model dealing with sequential
data we have our dense layers we have
actually three layers we're going to
bring in our dents our lstm which is
what we're focusing on and our dropout
and we'll discuss these three layers
more in just a moment but you do need
the with the lstm you do need the drop
out and then the final layer will be the
dents but let's go ahead and run this
and they'll bring port our modules and
you'll see we get an error on here and
if you read it closer it's not actually
an error it's a warning what does this
warning mean these things come up all
the time when you're working with such
cutting edge modules that are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the h5py
module which is part of cross is going
to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on keras and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more end but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it really easy you don't have to
remember all the numbers that put in 60
or whatever else is in there you just
let it tell the regressor what model to
use and so we follow our stm with a
dropout layer now understanding the
dropout layer is kind of exciting
because one of the things that happens
is we can over train our network that
means that our neural network will
memorize such specific data that it has
trouble predicting anything that's not
in that specific realm to fix for that
each time we run through the training
mode we're gonna take point two or
twenty percent of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only gonna train
on the other ones and it's gonna be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence
now the next piece of code is what
brings it all together let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we come in
here we put the output layer the dense
layer and if you remember up here we had
the three layers we had lstm dropout and
dents dense just says we're going to
bring this all down into one output
instead of putting out a sequence we
just know i want to know the answer at
this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
uh five total layers now cross is a
little different than a lot of other
systems there's a lot of other systems
put this all in one line and do it
automatic but they don't give you the
options of how those layers interface
and they don't give you the options of
how the data comes in cross is cutting
edge for this reason so even those a lot
of extra steps in building the model
this has a huge impact on the output and
what we can do with this these new
models from cross so we brought in our
dense we have our full model put
together a regressor so we need to go
ahead and compile it and then we're
going to go ahead and fit the data we're
going to compile the pieces so they all
come together and then we're going to
run our training data on there and
actually recreate our regressor so it's
ready to be used so let's go ahead and
compile that and i go ahead and run that
and if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom atom is optimized for big
data there's a couple other optimizers
out there beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly atom will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rnn to the training set
we have the regressor.fit x train y
train epochs and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the x train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epics is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of x
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling the save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today this isn't big enough to cause a
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
happened if i was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case google stock imagine if i was
doing this across all the stocks and i
had instead of just the open i had open
close high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because there's a
time sequence suddenly you find yourself
with a gig of memory you're loading into
your ram which will just completely you
know if it's just if you're not on
multiple computers or cluster you can
start running into resource problems but
for this we don't have to worry about
that so let's go ahead and run this and
this will actually take a little bit on
my computer because it's an older laptop
and give a second to kick in there there
we go all right so we have epic so this
is going to tell me it's running the
first run through all the data and as
it's going through it's batching them in
32 pieces so 32 lines each time and
there's 1198 i think i said 11.99
earlier but it's 11.98 i was off by one
and each one of these is 13 seconds so
you can imagine this is roughly 20 to 30
minutes run time on this computer like i
said it's an older laptop running at 0.9
gigahertz on a dual processor and that's
fine what we'll do is i'll go ahead and
stop go get a drink of coffee and come
back and let's see what happens at the
end and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through you can see
we've run it through 100 steps or 100
epics so the question is what does all
this mean one of the first things you'll
notice is that our loss can is over here
it kind of stopped at 0.0014 but you can
see it kind of goes down until we hit
about 0.014 three times in a row so we
guessed our epic pretty close since our
losses remain the same on there so to
find out we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
a real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing that we need to do is go ahead and
read the data in from our test csv you
see i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
ilocation so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar this is the same thing we did
before we're going to take our data set
total we're going to do a little panda
concat from the datastate train now
remember the end of the dataset train is
part of the data going in let's just
visualize that just a little bit here's
our train data let me just put tr for
train and it went up to this value here
but each one of these values generated a
bunch of columns it was 60 across and
this value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data so to find out what we're looking
at we're going to go ahead and load up
our test data the test data that we
didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did it when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test csv you see i've changed
the path on it for my computer and then
we'll call it the real stock price and
again we're doing just the one column
here and the values from i location so
it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar
because this is the same thing we did
before we're going to take our data set
total we're going to do a little panda
concat from the datastate train now
remember the end of the dataset train is
part of the data going in let's just
visualize that just a little bit here's
our train data let me just put tr for
train and it went up to this value here
but each one of these values generated a
bunch of columns it was 60 across and
this value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data because that's part of the next
data or it's actually the top 59. so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our data set test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set where pended
our two different or concatenated our
two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our x test and we're
going to create that x test and for i in
range 60 to 80. so here's our x test and
we're appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put them
between zero and one well that's not
going to mean very much to me to look at
a float number between zero and one i
want the dollar amount so i want to know
what the cash value is and we'll go
ahead and run this and you'll see it
runs much quicker than the training
that's what's so wonderful about these
neural networks once you put them
together it takes just a second to run
the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplot library dot pi plot as plt
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your graph especially if you're going
to present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and the
x label is going to be time because it's
a time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about 20 percent of the
data probably less than that we have the
google price and the google price has
this little up jump and then down and
you'll see that the actual google
instead of
a turn down here just didn't go up as
high and didn't load go down so our
prediction has the same pattern but the
overall value is pretty far off as far
as stock but then again we're only
looking at one column we're only looking
at the open price we're not looking at
how many volumes were traded like i was
pointing out earlier we talk about stock
just right off the bat there's six
columns there's open high low close
volume then there's weather i mean
volume shares then there's the adjusted
open adjusted high adjusted low adjusted
close they have a special formula to
predict exactly what it would really be
worth based on the value of the stock
and then from there there's all kinds of
other stuff you can put in here so we're
only looking at one small aspect the
opening price of the stock and as you
can see here we did a pretty good job
this curve follows the curve pretty well
it has like a little jumps on it bins
they don't quite match up so this bin
here does not quite match up with that
bin there but it's pretty darn close we
have the basic shape of it and the
prediction isn't too far off and you can
imagine that as we add more data in and
look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables it might take
a little bit longer to train the data
not so good for doing a quick tutorial
like this with that we've reached the
end of this complete neural networks
tutorial i hope you enjoyed this video
do like and share it thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]
hi everyone
welcome to this video tutorial by simply
learn
in this video we will learn about an
important popular deep learning neural
network called generative adversarial
networks
yan lacoon one of the pioneers in the
field of machine learning and deep
learning described it as the most
interesting idea in the last 10 years in
machine learning in this video you will
learn about what are generative
adversarial networks and look in brief
at generator and discriminator
then we'll understand how gans work and
the different types of gans finally
we'll look at some of the applications
of gans so let's begin
so what are generative adversarial
networks
generative adversarial networks or gans
introduced in 2014 by ian j good fellow
and co-authors became very popular in
the field of machine learning
gan is an unsupervised learning task in
machine learning it consists of two
models that automatically discover and
learn the patterns in input data
the two models called generator and
discriminator compete with each other to
analyze capture and copy the variations
within a data set
gans can be used to generate new
examples that possibly could have been
drawn from the original data set
in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real
hundred rupee notes the generator which
is basically a neural network generates
fake hundred rupees notes the
discriminator network will identify if
the nodes are real or fake let us now
understand in brief
about what is a generator a generator in
gans is a neural network that creates
fake data to be trained on the
discriminator
it learns to generate plausible data the
generated instances become negative
training examples for the discriminator
it takes a fixed length random vector
carrying noise as input and generates a
sample now the main aim of the generator
is to make the discriminator classify
its output as real
the portion of the gan that trains a
generator includes
a noisy input vector
the generator network which transforms
the random input into a data instance
a discriminator network which classifies
the generated data and a generator loss
which penalizes the generator for
failing to dalt the discriminator
the back propagation method is used to
adjust each weight in the right
direction by calculating the weight's
impact on the output
the back propagation method is used to
obtain gradients and these gradients can
help change the generator weights now
let us understand in brief what a
discriminator is a discriminator is a
neural network model that identifies
real data from the fake data generated
by the generator the discriminator's
training data
comes from two sources
the real data instances such as real
pictures of birds humans currency notes
etc are used by the discriminator as
positive samples during the training
the fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process while
training the discriminator it connects
with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
the discriminator laws
in the process of training the
discriminator the discriminator
classifies both real data and fake data
from the generator the discriminator
loss penalizes the discriminator for
misclassifying a real data instance as
fake or a fake data instance as real now
moving ahead
let's understand how gans work now gans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as g of x and a
discriminator which is represented as d
of x they both play an adversarial game
where the generator tries to fool the
discriminator by generating data similar
to those in the training set
the discriminator tries not to be fooled
by identifying fake data from the real
data
they both work simultaneously to learn
and train complex data like audio video
or image files now you are aware that
gans consists of two networks at
generator g of x and discriminator d of
x now the generator network takes a
sample and generates a fake sample of
data the generator is trained to
increase the probability of the
discriminator network to make mistakes
on the other hand
the discriminator network decides
whether the data is generated or taken
from the real sample using a binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that gives the output
in the range 0 and 1.
here is an example of a generative
adversarial network trying to identify
if the 100 rupee notes are real or fake
so first a noise vector or the input
vector is fed to the generator network
the generator creates fake hundred rupee
nodes
the real images of 100 rupee notes
stored in a database are passed to the
discriminator along with the fake nodes
the discriminator then identifies the
nodes and classifies them as real or
fake we train the model calculate the
loss function at the end of the
discriminator network and back propagate
the loss into both discriminator and
generator now the mathematical equation
of training again can be represented as
you can see here now this is the
equation
and these are the parameters here g
represents generator
d represents the discriminator
now p data of x is the probability
distribution of real data
p of z is the distribution of generator
x is the sample of probability data of x
z is the sample size from p of z d of x
is the discriminator network and g of
said
is the generator network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
objective function such that d of x is
close to 1
and z of z is close to zero
it simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from the
training set as real that is one
and all the generated images as fake
that is zero the generator wants to
minimize the objective function such
that d of z of z is one this means that
the generator tries to generate images
that are classified as real that is one
by the discriminator network next
let's see the steps for training a
neural network so we have to first
define the problem
and collect the data
then we'll choose the architecture of
gan now depending on your problem choose
how your gans should look like
then we need to train the discriminator
on real data that will help us predict
them as real for n number of times next
you need to generate fake inputs for the
generator after that we need to train
the discriminator on fake data to
predict the generator data as fake
finally train the generator on the
output of discriminator
with the discriminator predictions
available train the generator to fool
the discriminator let us now look at the
different types of gans so first we have
vanilla gans
now vanilla gans have min max
optimization formula that we saw earlier
where the discriminator is a binary
classifier and is using sigmoid cross
entropy loss during optimization
in vanilla gans the generator and the
discriminator are simple multi-layer
perceptrons the algorithm tries to
optimize the mathematical equation using
stochastic gradient descent up next we
have deep convolutional gans or dc gans
now dc gans support convolutional neural
networks instead of vanilla neural
networks at both discriminator and
generator they are more stable and
generate higher quality images the
generator is a set of convolutional
layers with fractional strided
convolutions or transpose convolutions
so it unsamples the input image at every
convolutional layer the discriminator is
a set of convolutional layers with
strided convolution so it down samples
the input image at every convolutional
layer moving ahead
the third type you have is conditional
gans or sea gans vanilla gans can be
extended into conditional models by
using an extra label information to
generate better results in c gan an
additional parameter called y is added
to the generator for generating the
corresponding data
labels are fed as input to the
discriminator to help distinguish the
real data from fake data generated
finally we have super resolution gans
now sr gans use deep neural networks
along with adversarial neural network to
produce higher resolution images super
resolution gans generate a
photorealistic high resolution image
when given a low resolution image let's
look at some of the important
applications of gans
so with the help of dc gans you can
train images of cartoon characters for
generating faces of anime characters and
pokemon characters as well next
gans can be used on the images of humans
to generate realistic faces the faces
that you see on your screens have been
generated using gans and do not exist in
reality third application we have is
cans can be used to build realistic
images from textual descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals we input a sentence and generate
multiple images fitting the description
here is an example of a text-to-image
translation using gans for a bird with a
black head yellow body and a sort beak
the final application we have is
creating 3d objects
so gans can generate 3d models using 2d
pictures of objects from multiple
perspectives gans are very popular in
the gaming industry
gans can help automate the task of
creating 3d characters and backgrounds
to give them a realistic feel and we're
going to be going over the open cv
tutorial and it's going to throw in some
cross and we're actually going to be
covering a lot of ground
in this tutorial so i'll speed up for
some of it and slow down as we focus on
important aspects
we talk about opencv
we're really talking about computer
vision so what is computer vision
and i would say opencv goes way beyond
uh computer vision it goes into graphic
editors and all kinds of other things
but we're going to be focusing a little
bit on computer vision and we're going
to cover the whole slew of the editors
and all the other cool stuff that's in
there
computer vision is a field of machine
learning whose goal is to help computers
see
its end goal is to make intelligent
systems which can understand digital
images
and you can there's all kinds of
different examples from handwriting
identification categorizing of pictures
is that a dog or a cat in the picture
and all that different things those are
all part of the computer vision
cars the the new automated cars and
being able to drive down the road they
usually use aspects of computer vision
to do that
for our ais
so
what is opencv
opencv is a huge open source library for
computer vision machine learning and
image processing it can be used to
process images and videos to identify
objects faces or even handwriting of a
human
and one of the cool things is it's um
the opencv project is outside of python
but it has a high integration with
python so you can use it in other
programming languages you're not set to
just python with it and has a huge
community behind it which is really nice
that's what makes the open cv project so
great
we'll start with installing the opencv
it's pretty straightforward in python
you do a pip install opencv dash python
you can pip install opencv can trip
python headless
opencv can be installed in windows mac
os or any gnu linux distribution by
using the pip command
the first one the first command we went
over is to install the main module
packages and the second one is for the
full package and usually you want the
full package
once you start digging into it it's so
easy to use there's so much fun things
you can play with
so the most common thing is reading in
uh image in opencv and we'll do this
also in code so if i go a little quick
on the slides it's so that we can roll
up our sleeves and actually open up and
do the coding on there
so when we're reading an image in an
opencv given an image to load it in we
can use the opencv function imread the
image can be displayed using the
function i am show
and so these are your two main
categories on here
uh and so your basic thing is to read an
image in then you can manipulate it and
then you can display it depending on
what you're using it for
and then when we talk about manipulating
it the most common thing is probably
resizing images and videos so you can
read in videos and we'll look at the
command for that also and how you can
process them frame by frame
resizing is helpful in all kinds of
aspects obviously on the display you
might want to resize it so it fits the
display a certain way a lot of times
that's handled
for the size of the image if you're
uploading it to the web you might want
to have a smaller image so you're not
taking up a huge amount of memory
not as big of a deal anymore and then a
lot of times the actual web page would
handle the size of the image once you
upload it
but what if you want to process all the
images under the same
neural network well they're going to
look for the same size and that's also
as huge as to be able to resize your
images to go into that neural network so
you're not looking at different sized
images and images read in might not be
of correct size or might not fit the
screen correctly to overcome this we can
resize the image and you see it's a real
simple command in the
cv and we're actually using what they
call cv2 a lot of times people just
import cv2 as or open cv2 as cv
just to make it easy
because it might have old code or
something like that it's easy to swap
things in and move forward
and you can see here we just resize we
have our image we have our new
dimensions and then how do we resize it
the interpolation is kind of a function
in there as far as how to guess the
colors because you're combining colors
and different things and we can use a
drawing with the open cv we can draw
images in opencv allows us to draw
various things like a rectangle circles
lines you add text into the images and
that kind of thing so there's a whole
slew of different things we can do with
the opencv and we'll look at these
commands we'll glance through them
and show you how they work in the actual
software
and they have basic image functions
and
this is just so cool because so much of
this is built in you go back 10 years
and people are writing the code to do
this stuff and now it's all built in and
people are continually optimizing it so
you can do a lot of things without
having to lift the hood up and
really do the heavy lifting underneath
uh so opencv has built-in functions
which allow us to perform various
operations on our images such as
blurring resizing cascading edge
detection and cropping and there's also
motion detection and videos there's all
kinds of things
and you can see here we have blurring we
can take an image and blur it slightly
we can resize it
it's easy to crop it you know that we
can do the round
head face cropping on a web page or
whatever
or identify where the object is and crop
the background out kind of thing and you
have image transformation we talked a
little bit just a second ago on blurring
uh we can also do things like rotating
it
we can transform the image
various ways you can see here we can
shift it so we can shift it left shift
it right flip it crop it
all these are very easy to do in the
opencv package
and then i mentioned a little bit about
we start looking at motion detection and
detecting different things
there's contour detection which is built
into the open cv package which is really
nice and again this is stuff
that
usually was somebody in the back in
programming this and now you have opencv
which does almost everything for you
so a contour is a curve or a line
joining all points which have the same
color intensity contours help us find
the points which lie on the same plane
and assist in edge detection
and you can see here we've taken the cat
and done a contour detection and it kind
of looks it makes it look almost like
someone
stenciled it in there that's kind of
cool little zen art going on there
this is how the computer might using
contour detection see the cat on the
black background
and then you also can adjust the color
channels
so you can play with all the colors any
image is basically a combination of
three main colors red green blue the rgb
sometimes
a quick note which we won't cover in the
programming is when you see that rgb
it's not always in that order
there's different formats for it and so
there's also sometimes the alpha
channels you might have rgb a where a is
how transparent it is so you might
actually have four channels which
i like to work with when trying to take
the background out because the edges of
images actually have reflections
um and light is also a curve and wraps
around so there's some cool things to
know when you're messing with these
things
and the opencv allows us to split our
image into its respective color channels
and you can see here we've taken the
image of a
little landscape and we've sorted it out
into different channels and you can see
how you have it all in the blues the
reds and the greens
and there's also color spaces
color spaces are a way to represent the
color channels present in an image
they tell us the various color channels
which are contributing to a particular
hue
so again we can
pull things out based on the hue and the
images and colors on there
and blurring blurring
is very popular right now because it's
easy to find someone's face and then
blur out the background
without having to play with alpha
channels and different things for the
coloring around the you know you have
the edging of the head and the coloring
so blurring is a method used to remove
noise from an image by applying a low
pass filter over an image we smooth out
the edges and make the transition from
one color to another very smooth
and you might not be able to see the
difference in the cat video but you
start seeing smoothness and sharpness
have always been
a mainstay of editing images and things
like that over the years and so this is
all built into opencv and then there's
bitwise operations
bitwise operations are
the and or zore etc in image processing
they are used to create a new image or
for masking
and we'll
glance at masking but masking is huge
so when we get into the code we'll talk
a little bit more about masking i'll
probably
maybe offshoot for a minute on that
the operation is done between each pixel
of two images
and so you can see here we have the
square
plus the circle so if it's an and
only where the white is so where it's in
both images it then equals a new image
with just the white parts
in masking
masking is used to bring certain parts
of an image into focus by lowering the
definition over other parts this is done
by reducing the picture quality of other
parts of the image
kind of a little short on the on the
masking of what it is
so in this case the masking would either
be
the background
might be all ones and the cat and the
fence might be zeros or vice versa we
might put the cat as one in the
background as zeros
and then you can do a transformation
on either the background or the
foreground
to maybe you want to blur the background
out and make the foreground sharper
or maybe you want to make the little
circle with a cat in it
take the colors out so it's one color
masking allows you to separate your
image out and do those different things
and that's where the masking comes in
and it has a lot of uses and then
there's histograms uh histograms in an
image processing histograms typically
refer to a graph of pixel intensity
values the intensity of each pixel is
plotted in a histogram again we start
with these histograms are the beginning
of doing different identifications and
can be used for different things
you don't really publish a histogram
onto your web page of the cats because
it's just kind of silly but you can use
that data in data processing to look at
different things and pull different
things out of the picture
thresholding another important aspect of
image processing a method of image
segmentation it is used to convert an
image
of binary by setting a
threshold intensity value and deeming
all values above it as one converted to
white and below a zero black
and you can see here we were talking
about masks
in the threshold we're able to actually
create a mask of the image in this case
you have the
cats which are mostly white stand out
because we put whatever the value is
to pull those cats out and put the
background further back
edge detection just like threshold it's
another tool we can use to bring out
an image
so we can find different things on there
a lot of cool things we can do with that
you can see here we've taken a landscape
same one
we had before
and we can find the boundaries of an
image by consistency and brightness it's
used for image segmentation and data
extraction
and you can see with this image of the
buildings how
powerful it is just to pull the whole
sky out i mean you know where the sky is
there's no debate on it
so finding edge detection has a lot of
cool things it can do when you're
processing images and pulling the images
apart if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skill up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so
with that uh really the hands-on there's
so much hands-on on this
so
we're going to start with a real
basic open cv setup in python
we'll then take a look at some motion
detection i usually don't put the video
on here because my office is under
construction you can see the partially
finished wall in the back
but when we do the motion detection
we'll have the video up and show you how
to pull this video in just like i'm
doing here and utilize that in a program
you can actually start detecting motions
you could think of a wilderness webcam
or something like that all kinds of fun
things you can do with motion detection
uh and then we'll get into
melding a little bit with the opencv and
write a a short cross
neural network that will train and do
facial
identification so we're going to cover
just a slew of really cool tools that
you can do with opencv
so here's my favorite package to work in
the anaconda
i'm going to be in python 3.8
and then if you haven't yet you need to
go under environments
you can either
install them through anaconda here
or you can open up
let's see where is it 38 you can open up
your terminal and do the pip install
like we discussed earlier in the slide
and that was this slide right here pip
install opencv contrib python headless
i would just go right for the second one
because it installs everything
so it's a full package
and you just go ahead and open up in
this case pi 38
there's my terminal window and i can
simply do my pip command in here
you can also
if you're in anaconda
we can go in here let's do all sorts of
packages for opencv
and you can see here's your opencv
library opencv python opencv and i
actually installed all of these all
these are installed on my my anaconda
for the use of this
setup didn't want to miss anything uh
and then once we open this up
we're going to go in here to new
and create a new python window python 3
in this case we're in 3.8 as i told you
which is what's set up in here
and we'll start with just
opencv
general
so let's put that in here open cv
that's just a general setup on there for
doing our opencv
and uh
of course some people like to
i'm not big and looking at my own face
the whole time during these but we'll go
and put my video back up there
and when we talk about the opencv
we want to go ahead and import all of
our different aspects of what we're
going to be working on in here
and you'll see on this we have our
import cv2 and i mentioned earlier that
a lot of people when they see the import
cv2 they just go ahead and automatically
do it as cv that way if you're using
older code
it doesn't bother me too much to use cv2
but a lot of people prefer to just keep
that as an open someday they'll probably
have cv3 who knows
we want our numpy for our numbers array
sometimes that comes in we have our
matplot library kind of by default and
we'll do our map plot library in line
just because we're in jupiter notebook
that way if we do any plotting
it's not really going to affect what
we're working on i just do it as a
standard
pretty straightforward
and then before we get started let me go
ahead and pull over
we have a file set up on here with some
images in it and some videos
and just like any of our other
setups in simply learn if you need a
copy of some of these images of course
it's pretty easy to come up with your
own images and your own videos nowadays
but if you want to rerun this and set
this up you can certainly have them send
the information over there with in this
case we have the cat which is going to
be an image
we have a dog which is going to be an
mp4 uh video
and then we have we do facial
recognition we took some of our
very well known actors out there like
ben affleck elton john the musician
jerry seinfeld and other people so we
can actually train a cross setup on
there and do a
facial recognition on there and again
all of this you can send to simply learn
and say hey can i get a copy of some of
this information
and so we're going to start out the
first thing we want to do is just the
most basic thing which is
read in an image and display it
and then i'm going to go ahead and let's
see i'm going to cut this in half
i used to have this in windows 10 where
i just hit a button and it dropped my
background and everything
so we're going to look at the horrible
blue color of the windows default
you'll just have to ignore my icons up
there and so we're going to be reading
images and the reason i did a half
screen here is because
when they pop up they don't necessarily
pop up by default in front in the
jupiter notebook
so you're not even going to see them
they'd be hidden behind there
the first thing i want to do is just a
basic reading of an image in this case
we're just going to read the file
cat.jpg
there's no path in here because i went
ahead and saved it in the same folder
that the program's running in but if you
have it in a separate folder you want to
put that full path in there
and so it's real simple we have image we
have cm dot im read
or red i don't know which one they use
um i am red
and then cv i am show and that just
stands for image show and cats and then
image
cats is the title of the window that's
going to pop up and let's go ahead and
run that and you can see here we have
our window that pops up and there's our
cat
so that's really straightforward
if you're looking at that
it's there's nothing
really difficult this is why i like
open opencv so much because it's so easy
to use
and if we're going to do the image if
you remember we had dog
video going on maybe my image up a
little bit there we go
we can go ahead and play a movie and
that's that that is really cool and by
the way
when i was messing with this it does
actually store the sound file with the
mp4 so if you have the video playing and
the microphone going it will store both
of those as a second uh there's like
another channel that stores in the cv
when it's reading these things
in this case we're going to go ahead and
capture
we need to go ahead and tell it where
what file we're capturing
in in the next video we'll actually do
one of the next two sections we'll show
you how to capture the camera you're
actually looking at
but in this one we have capture cd video
capture dog.mp4 pretty straightforward
it just says here's the file we're going
to capture
and then it says while true
and this if you're doing
a lot of programming in python you
should recognize this
instead of
setting is true to true and then letting
it switch each time
we just say hey if not is true break and
that will break the
loop
and so what we're doing here is we're
going to read each frame
of the video as it goes is true frame
equals capture dot red
um if is true is false it breaks so
we're done we've hit the end of the
video and then we're going to show the
video in this case of the dog cute
little puppy
and it's going to be by frame so each
frame is showing
and you see we have a weight key here
this has to do with uh the end code in
the back so
you could probably leave it out in here
but it's usually good to leave these
particular things in
this particular key in there because it
does actually there are times when that
can affect the run time and you can see
here's our little puppers you know
smiling and having fun
and it is it's playing each of those
frames so as you're watching it it's
going through i don't know how many
frames per second probably 30 frames per
second and so it's displaying 30 frames
one after another
and if you have sound with it it by
default will play the soundtrack with
there just so you know
we don't we're not doing too much in
sound on this one that we're just
focusing on the opencv video
and then when you're done with something
you'll see me flash this up a bunch of
times we're going to have the destroy
all windows from the cv which closes
everything we got going
when we're dealing with videos
one of the issues is you have a buffer
in your video
and so you'll see us you'll see this
kind of coding where it says wake key 60
and it's just waiting an extra period of
time to make sure everything's cleared
out of memory that's all that does and
so you can see we just closed all the
windows that came in on there
and then one of the cool things we can
do
uh and we're we're going to do a bunch
of stuff with images in just a minute
but let's start with the video we can do
resizing and so we have a rescale the
frame we're going to submit the frame
we're going to send it the scale and
it's going to
compute the
height
the width and the height based on what
we send for a scale
we'll put it into dimensions and this
right here is our resize
cf resize the frame and this could also
be an image it's not you're not stuck
with just a frame when you do this kind
of resize
and then they have this is the code they
use for resizing
not a whole lot to look in there
it does come up sometimes because there
are a couple different mathematical
codes of how to blend the colors
together and make it smaller without it
becoming really chunky or really i mean
they used to just delete like if you cut
it in half you just delete every other
pixel
and then of course you're deleting
information instead of melding it
together and this moves it over that's
what this is doing right here this
interpolation equals cv enter area
and then we have the change the res
we're going to be doing a live video so
when you change the res the resolution
again there's not a whole lot to look in
here it's just um uh helping us so that
the resolution keeps it looking nice on
there
and then we have our this should look
familiar from above we do our capture we
need to set up where the video is coming
from we gotta let the cv the opencv know
what the vid which file it's using
and then it says while true this is
again just like above
if not true
if not is true break
and here's our frame resize
and then we're going to do a cv i am
show frame and we're going to do cv i am
show framed resize this should look just
like you saw before
and then we have our
this extra code here in case we need to
re break early now i'm going to run this
and we're going to get
if you have if you're looking at this
you should say oh we have
two different videos going
one of them is labeled video
and it's based on frame and one is video
resized based on frame so we're going to
end up with two completely separate
videos playing at the same time
and let's go ahead and run and see what
that looks like
you'll know one of the videos is
obviously going to be the dog because we
saw him before and you can see right
here
there the dog is resized
and we could easily take this
scale
yeah we'll go this way just a little bit
and instead of 0.5 maybe we want to do
0.25 because we want it to be like a
little little um thumbnail on there let
me run that and you can see how it
nicely rescales it down to a quarter of
the size
and then i'm gonna keep the split screen
uh you'll see why in just a second let
me go ahead and destroy the windows and
clean up our desktop that we're working
on and we're gonna go back to image
editing uh so we're gonna go through a
bunch of image different editings you
can do on here
now this next part
we're zooming through
there are so many things you can do with
the opencv
first we're gonna just draw a blank box
i'm going to run this here's my blank
box it's got nothing in it
and we can take if you notice i've
created blank oops there's my blank we
filled it with zeros so this is a 500 by
500 by 3 channel there's actually can be
four channels if you have the alpha
which is the see-through
and this will handle an alpha channel
but you have the three channels in here
and you create a nice blank box that's
just playing black and in there and then
if we can do a blank box we can actually
take go back in here there we go we're
gonna take this blank box and we're just
going to uh fill it i'll leave it called
blank
we'll run this and i'm putting in from
200 to 300 that's actual pixel counts
remember this is a
500 by 500 box
and we're going to do from 200 to 300
and 300 to 400 that's the upper left and
bottom right corners
of the array and we're going to send to
0 0 255 which happens to be green
and this is rbg
be a little careful because the some of
the formats switch the order from red
blue green to different colors
and if we run this you can see here
we've actually added oh i guess i did a
um
a red box for some reason i thought that
was a green color i must have it
switched around on there
but you can see right here that we can
actually go in and we can change any
pixel in here and it works like a numpy
array which is really nice because now i
can edit
my blank box here and do different
things in the blank box and fill it in
there and draw lines
we'll go ahead and
a rectangle like i said some of this
is going to be quicker to pasting in
here and showing you
we're going to take a rectangle and
oops it's hard to see here
create the shape let me open this up a
little wider there we go
and in the rectangle
we're going to use blank
i'm going to
show it we're going to give it a new
window that's what this is doing down
here if i left this blanket just put the
rectangle on top of everything
and we're going to use blank as our
basis
starting at 0 0
and you can see our different dimensions
and thickness minus one and there's my
weight key on the bottom and let me go
ahead and run that
oops i should've done an im show
uh which it did but was behind our
chrome
you can set where appears on the window
we should probably do that on here uh
but you can see it opened up a new
window this window is called rectangle
this one's called blank and so these are
two completely different windows that
we've set up on here if i had changed
this to blank it would have just put the
rectangle on top just like it did the
red square earlier
and we can do a lot with this we can go
ahead and draw let's see a circle a line
and then put some text on here and we'll
take the same blank setup
since that's our basis right here is
blank
and we'll go ahead and create all of
those and let me go ahead and paste that
in here and you can see here we have
our cv circle it's going in on the blank
we have our dimensions of the circle let
me just
bring these down a line so you can see a
little bit better what we're looking at
there we go
um and then we're gonna do the color on
this the thickness minus one and this is
uh basically a radius of the circle kind
of set up i'd have to look up to
remember the exact
what these different numbers represent
um but you have the the different sizes
of the circle we have a line here we're
going to draw a line
blank
in this case we have
uh 300 400 255 and you can see a set up
in here this is again
the color the starting point the end
point and a thickness of three
so a lot of this is pretty
straightforward and this is going to
open up a new window called line because
that's what we called it instead of
putting it on the blank
and then we'll do text
now on each one of these we're adding
the line to blank
so it's in the original blank square
that we've called blank
but on each one of these we're putting
it opening it up in a new window we
could easily continue to put them in the
same window and you could turn it into a
video or some other kind of thing
and you can see down here hello my name
is jason my name isn't actually jason
and we have our location that we're
going to print jason on there and
the font and the size and the color and
dimensions of it and then show text and
let's go ahead and run so you can see
how all these show up on here
and if i open up my screen a little
wider you can see that we have our code
and we did certainly put add a circle on
here here's our circle we added a line
on here here's our line and we've added
text on here hello my name is jason
probably should have picked a different
color instead of matching it with the
square box we put on there
and just like all of this we want to go
ahead and clear the data
keep a nice clean screen and i'm not
sure why it keeps printing this stuff
underneath let me go fix that
and then the next section we want to
cover
is going to be uh your gray scales
and blending and masking and stuff like
that
and let's go ahead and clear our little
palette i don't know what else to call
it
it's a good name for it palette
and here we go you'll remember this one
we're going to load our image in this
case we're going to load the image park
and we're going to display park
we get that nice view of the park that's
what we did before and there's so many
things that are built in to open cv on
here uh one we can grayscale it and
we're just going to take and you can see
here we're converting
blue green red remember i said there's
three channels you got to be a little
careful what order they're in
i can never remember i have to actually
pull it up every time i go in here
because i jump around between so many
editors and software it's just the
nature of dealing with pictures
sometimes but you really have to make
sure you catch that and double check it
um and so we're just going to this is
just a conversion and that's what the
cvt stands for color
and then we'll display this in
gray gray skeleton and you can see it
did a nice job there's our park
oops if i can grab it
and there's the grayscale on there
and then we can do such things as blur
so i can come in here we can go ahead
and
this uses cv gaussian blur
and there's a lot of settings as far as
how the blur works
and then you can see here we've got
border default cv border default seven
seven i believe that has to do with the
square in the pixel reigns
when you do a lot of blurring then you
start messing with it and we can see
here's the park up here
we went ahead and grayscaled it oops
there we go
gray not responding because i hit the
wrong button on this
and blur there's our blur on there so we
have a couple different setups on that
there's also edge cascade
some of these you just pretty much you
really have to know your editing on
videos i'm not a huge
video editor
so when i do a lot of this stuff i'm not
really sure what it is i'm doing
like i know a blur is obviously but i
don't know what edge cascade is
uh except for now that it comes out you
can clearly see that it draws lines
dealing with where the different colors
meet and how they connect
that's a really neat tool it puts a nice
matte literally creates a nice mask of
the edging and you can see where you
could use this to pull out in this case
the sky quite easily from the whole
picture
and there's dilated let me go ahead and
run that and see what that looks like
let's give it a second to pop up to the
top
and keep in mind that the dilated used
the edge
as our input so we took
the canny the blur oh there we go yeah
candy blur
dilated use the candy so we have our
blurred coming in from the canyons
quite the terminology there if you're
trying to follow it all we have a
roading
let me just show you some of the
settings on there
we have the number of iterations for
doing a routing so let's go ahead and
run this one
and you can see how it changes the
settings uh or the view on there and
this brought in the dilated and then
eroded it back into
i'm guessing it kind of sharpens it
from the from the blurriness we saw in
the one before the dilated
and then of course probably one of the
ones that i use the most
and i use the resize
and the reason i use this a lot is
because i work in data science and so
if i have it coming in as a certain size
on there
if the if the
neural network is processing an image
with a certain size
all the images coming in have to be that
size and so we have here
resizing our image
and let's go ahead and run that and you
can see how we took the
in this case we used the original image
and we just resized it to a smaller view
on there
and if we can resize the image we can
also crop it
again data science loves cropping this
is you could literally
crop pictures and resize them and rotate
them and make that your new import for
doing categorization
and we'll actually show you how we can
automate that when we get to the facial
recognition cross part of this tutorial
but we can see here we can also crop it
and we just take the picture and crop a
small piece off of it there
and just like we did before let's go
ahead and clean our pallet start it over
again
and again we're just chugging through
these uh these are commands
that depending on what you're doing
depends on what you need
so if we're looking at um
changing it to grayscale
sometimes processing something in
grayscale and cross is easier it's able
to pull out the dimensions better
blurring that's more of a display kind
of thing where you're going to display
it with a slight blur
finding the edges that's kind of cool
you can actually come in there and maybe
use those edges to help you find
something in the foreground and in the
background
dilated give it a little blurry a look
eroded bring it back into sharpness
resize it and crop it
all those are things that are just neat
tools to have at your fingertips and
easy to use some of them might be more
for a website and bringing up icons and
cropping the head shot or something like
that where others are are kind of more
generally used in just about any
industry
another feature is
being able to translate
transmatt float32 remember a lot of
these things
let me just full screen this here real
quick we have our image coming in and
then we can translate it a 100 in
different directions on here
there's so many different things we can
do with this so as we go through this oh
my goodness i
hit a button on here okay give me just a
second there we go
okay so let's go to translates on
translate on there and we have the cat
and you can see how we translated it
down instead of the full image of the
cat that we had before
we can also rotate
uh rotation like i mentioned earlier is
a fun thing to do
and we'll actually do that when we do
the cross thing because you can process
the same image at different angles and
then you've just multiplied your input
as far as doing identification
in this case you can rotate on here we
have the angle the rotation point
none
i believe it puts it in the center i'd
have to look that up and then you have
the image shape height width uh rotate
point is none width height so this is
actually going to put the rotate point
in the middle
if we send it a none to this little
routine that they put together in the
back
and then we're going to warp
this is the actual command here warp a
fiend
uh and you have the image you have your
rotate map and you have your dimensions
on here
and if we go ahead and plug that in and
we put the rotate in
image at -45 let's see what happens and
we're going to run that
and you can see how it nicely rotated
the cat's head although it's a little
creepy the way it looks like it cut the
cat's head off on there
maybe move it
it down a notch just so you can't see
the the cutoff point
and we already did the resize but we'll
run that again so you can see how it
gets resized on here
and be aware when you resize them i do a
lot of resizing for the
putting it into
neural networks or into some kind of
machine learning setup
but it does squish it it squishes it and
stretches it and so if you're doing this
for say display and re-editing you might
want to be a little careful about that
make sure that you maintain the same
ratio unless you intentionally want the
cat to look taller and thinner
and we can also go ahead and flip it
as you can see here we just flipped it
upside down
uh minus one you can probably flip it a
couple different ways i'm curious to
minus two does
shoot same thing
um
maybe if we put minus
and a one is no well one is just
flipping it all the way to the opposite
side from left to right
uh so you can see here we can flip it
around a little bit that's kind of a fun
thing to have
one of those things you might have a
hotkey for if you're doing some kind of
picture editing and giving a lot of
choices
and we also already did the
see there we go cropping
as you can see here where we a cropped
image
equals the image and we just pick out
the pixels we want and then we can show
the cropped image over here and it's
just a cropping of the face in this case
we grab 200 to 400
as the upper left corner and 300 to 400
as a bottom right corner
and let's clear our palette again
and then we're going to do
contour detection
and there is
so much that goes into all this i mean
we're flashing through a lot of things
and you can see how you might combine
them and use them for different things
so we're going to go ahead and get our
cap back up as our image
and let's go ahead and do
image shape we're going to take an image
shape and we're just going to create a
blank screen for it so this is just a
blank screen here based on the shape of
the cat
and strangely enough
uh this is done a lot the reason that we
would create a blank thing is you can or
a blank image
is you might start filling in
information on there and using that as
your template for different things
and so it becomes almost it becomes a
mask of sorts there's an actual mask in
the program a little bit different but
you can imagine if this is your blank
screen you start with you might add
circles or squares or whatever on there
and we can do the same thing here with
we can convert our picture to gray we
did that earlier which is always kind of
fun to see the the cat comes back
and being that i'm missing with a lot of
uh different feeds and stuff like that
it's uh you can see you got another
responding going on there when you do a
lot of this stuff that's what you'll
start seeing more of that
as you mess with it it'll eventually
come in you just got to give some time
there it is there comes in my gray one
on there
and we have the gaussian blur so we can
take it and blur the image
and in this case we fed it the gray one
so you can see the the very clear mouth
underneath on the gray one and then the
more blurry one on top on there
if you remember we did earlier um
come back on here
candy edges so again we're doing
detections and things like that looking
for different things
and there's another feature called cv
threshold and or the thrust cv threshold
and in this case we're going to send it
the gray picture and let me just pull
the coding down here
um there we go
and you can see here we're going to do a
cv threshold based on binary um
let's set up on here we'll go ahead and
just run this you can see what this
looks like run
there we go that's that's actually
really cool how it picks up on that on
the threshold you can see how it just
turns it into almost a black and white
image that can be a lot of fun too and
we can also look at the contours in the
opencv
so we talk about that we have our let me
just open this up all the way so we can
see the code
we're going to return the contours and
the
hierarchies
and we're going to pull this off of
canny the candy one that we sent up up
here earlier
and
we have the retrieve list and chain
approximate samples there's a lot of
options in here that we can follow
let's go ahead and run that
let's go back down here where are you
up there we go
and when we run this
uh we get a nice setup on this it says
hey there's 74 contours found on here
um and that's that's actually
turns this starts turning this into a
math on whoops which one did we feed it
uh we fed it the
candy up here so we start to look at
these different setups get this out of
the way
where's canny there's candy in the back
and you can see that this drew 74
different uh like line connections on
here so now we're starting to actually
turn this into almost a mathematical
formula on this
and when we're looking at these we'll go
ahead and do draw contours
and here's our contour let's return the
contours up here
and we're going to put this on the blank
remember how we did the blank earlier
so we're actually going to take the
blank as remember i told you you could
use it like a
a base that set up on there and we can
now redraw the contours but in this case
uh we change the color
so now we're drawing the contours in red
so that's just kind of a fun thing you
can do on there to
change the uh literally change the
appearance and the setup on there
and let's go of course clean up our
setup and destroy all our windows and
move on to the next section
and we're going to look at color spaces
and let's start with
in the color spaces we're going to
read an image in
and i'm going to go ahead and show
the image park let me just run that
oops i forgot to put a
the wake key in there a lot of times the
weight key just helps because i'm
pushing all these graphics out through
a single kernel because i'm working in
jupiter notebook and things get hung up
and so waiting that extra 60
milliseconds can sometimes really help
sometimes as we start flashing these
pictures up and down you'll see there's
no response and other things come up
that really is just because we're
pushing so much out there
now one of the interesting things on
this is we imported matplot library and
so matplot library
can now easily be integrated with
our
imagery and you just see all we gotta do
is just dump the image into the matplot
library and now i have the image here
showing on my matplot library setup
one of the things you're going to notice
on this is the colors all look off well
again you see that and you see that
they're supposed to be the same thing
and you should jump and say oh uh one of
these is rbg the other is gbr or
bgr or something like that and so it's
reading the
the
reading the colors in a different order
that's all that means and you have to do
a transformation at some point to fix
that
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
we're going to go back and grayscale it
again we're going to take our image of
the park
um we'll put it into gray
run there we go
and in here we can convert our color and
this is what we're just talking about we
can convert the color scheme let me go
and run this
and you can see here we swapped the
scheme out and then i'm curious because
we did
up here plot it
what does this look like when we plot
this new color down here this new scheme
what does that look like on our setup
let me go ahead and just go down
there we go
and we call this hsv
so go down here instead of image i'm
going to plot
hsv
and let's run that
and still
way off on color schemes
you can see we can really mess up with
this hsv is another type of color scheme
i was curious because i did not think it
would come up correctly but i wanted to
see if it would
and we can also do a conversion to
what's called
there we go
bgr blue green red to lab
and lab is just another color scheme on
here
and so you can see when we swatch the
color screen it has some really cool
effects as far as
what it looks like in their view
lab ranges from
it's kind of luminosity
and then it has like uh then the
channels coming in
so it's a little bit different setup on
this but really you have to just play
with these to see what they look like we
talk about all these different color
schemes and all these switches on here
now the one that we were talking about
earlier
i mentioned was the bgr to rgb because
we use the bgr we'll just run this
and we see the color change on that
and then we'll go back up because i'm
still curious
um
okay there we go copy
if this is the same that matplot library
uses and we'll just type in rgb down
here
because that's what we called our figure
and we'll run this and it will display
it oops it comes up there and gives us a
problem because capitalization
whoops
rgb there we go so let's go ahead and
run that
and that looks pretty close to the
original uh so this is when we're
converting between matplot library and
from the opencv
we really want the blue green red to red
green blue that's the conversion you
want to use to get to the original
picture on there
and then we can also convert from
hsv to the lab like i said these
conversions
you have to look them up most the time
but it's important to start recognizing
them so the very fact that you're in
here looking at this we're talking about
blue green red versus lab
versus the um
where was it h
hsv setup on there when you're dealing
with pictures that come in in all
varieties and so really being able to
switch between them is important on here
so let's go ahead and take that
particular setup conversions and we'll
go ahead and clean up our pallet
hopefully that will save us some
problems down the road
and we're going to start looking at the
color channels
uh and with this we'll go ahead and
reload the park back up we'll display
that just remember what the original
picture looked like
and then
for right now let's go ahead and take a
blank
screen
and create ourselves a blank zeros
basically same shape as our park image
d type
new integer eight
don't really usually that's the default
anyway so you don't really need to even
put that in there but it's good to have
and this is an
interesting line here that opencv allows
you to do
a cv split image and this basically just
takes the three channels in your numpy
image and you could use the numpy code
and figure it out i'm sure and splits it
into blue channel green channel and red
channel
and what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and
there we go
we're going to do a cv merge blue green
and red
and what we're doing is we're merging
the uh blank one
as far as blue
the blank green blank uh blank blank red
so these are the new channels as we
combine them that's what this merge
thing does this is kind of fun because
you could merge you could take like your
cat with just the red whiskers
merge that with something um and then
kind of mess with the images as to far
as like you know what sticks out what
sits back on there you get pretty
creative with the
imagery and then we're just going to go
ahead and show blue green red
we'll just do all these at once
and you can see here
the same image
oops there we go i'll take it a second
to pull it down
and we can now
see uh it's either black or blue red or
blue or you know the different colors in
here green or black
kind of fun i mean really pull out the
different colors and see how you can
mess with them on there
and then if we go ahead and
just do a quick print of these shapes
let me go run
you can see here that as you expected
you'll have the image shape which is 427
640 by three well it's only 640 by 640
so each one of these is just the color
of just the one color that's all we're
showing on here
the fact that we use the shape on here
is very similar to your numpy and these
are actually numpy in the back end
so if you haven't messed with numpy
um
real powerful setup on there you can
dive in there and do a lot of stuff in
numpy that comes back right into this
over here
and then we'll merge them back in
shoot there we go and we see the
original picture give it a second to pop
to the front
and you see here we merge the colors
back we separated the colors we merge
them back same image and that's what we
expect on this because we didn't mess
with any of the colors
let's go ahead and destroy all that so
we have another clear setup
and let's go in and look at some more
alterations we can do with um
blurring and and altering the image in
different ways
for this we'll go back to our cat
picture uh here's our image cv am red
cat jpeg and if we run that and view it
there's our cat
i guess we got tired i guess the guys in
the back got tired of the cute puppy
running around
and the first thing we'll go ahead and
give a shot on here is uh averaging
these are different ways we can blur the
image
so if we average it it takes the average
pixels based on
three by three and if we change this to
30
just for fun
you can see how it really blurs it on
there
so this is like a 30 by 30 pixel each
pixel averages around it and we'll go
back to 10
kind of a little bit of fun stuff you
can do on there and you can see that
because i'm doing the average blur it
knows to go to this frame right here
that's why i can so easily jump in here
and just make some changes on that
that is a lot of fun when you're messing
with videos because you can so easily
throw that into
your
interface
set up on there and be able to mess with
it and here's our gaussian blur
and the gaussian blur is very similar uh
but the
pixels that are closer are given more
weight and let's just jump this up here
to 30.
we'll run that
and whoops it didn't like 30 i guess i
jumped too high for it uh let's do
let's do five
there we go uh you start to see the
blurring on there and then
the one let's change that and see what
that does doesn't make a huge difference
on this until you start messing with
let's see
waited there we go run
you start to see it starting to blur
more and more depending on how we do the
weight and how it kind of
blends outward gaussian's nice because
it adds a little bit more blending to it
where this just blurs it where the
average just blurs it out
again those are the kind of things you
almost have to play with them a lot
to start seeing how they change
and there's also the medium blur
let's go ahead and run that one
as it comes up there we go
uh and the median works almost identical
to the average uh it's very similar on
there
there are some differences and you
really have to start looking at what is
the difference between an average and a
medium value
because that's what this is based on
this is based on the median value
if we do it run 10 there we go there's
our median i hope it didn't like the 10
i'm not sure why i must have been too
high of a value for it
run
whoops
let's try 0.5
there we go um okay so and this has to
be an integer for the medium blur and
you can see it's similar to the average
but there is a difference in the way the
math actually functions in the
background uh
sometimes it comes out a little
different
and there's also a bilateral
filter
a lot of these you use to smooth
sharp edges if something looks really
sharp you can smooth it and this is
literally what they're doing when they
say smooth something
and you're messing around with
photoshop
these are the kind of changes that are
happening in the back end
uh and then we have our bilateral let me
go and run that
and the bilateral
you should that is one that's really
important to remember
because it works like the gaussian
but it it's like a gaussian filter on
top of a gaussian filter
and one gaussian filter
smooths out like blotches like if you
want something to have smooth skin
but keeps the sharp edges
and so when you're messing with this and
you're doing a lot of work
remembering the bilateral filter is
really important if you're doing images
especially
if you look at my complexion i really
need it i should be doing the bilateral
on that one
that's the kind of thing that you'd be
using to really bring up people's
features while smoothing out all that
fuzzy noise that shows up on their skin
and blemishes
and again let's go ahead and clear our
palette
run
another
cool feature
so we can do bitwise
setup on here and i'm going to create a
blank
set up
just so you can see what it's going on
there here's our blank box 400 400 400
it has a rectangle we're going to do
from the blank copy and then we're going
to do a circle
um the circle is going to be
200 200
set up on here
so we're just building a circle and a
rectangle like we did before let me just
show you all the numbers on there so you
can see what we're doing oops let me
maximize it all right there we go
let me
ah always a question do you do it before
or after the comma it really depends on
what i'm working on and who i'm working
with i do whatever they want
so if it's uh sometimes it looks nice to
have the commas in front and sometimes
afterwards when you're splitting rolls
it's purely visual on here
uh so we're gonna have we're gonna go
ahead and do build ourselves a rectangle
in a circle here and let's just go ahead
and display those three things if you
don't know which
which parts are overlapping so they have
to be the same size
and we can see over here let me just
pull this over
we have our rectangle in our circle
and we can do just like we do with um
any kind of bitwise functionality and
let me pull i guess see if i can pull it
over here without losing
uh information on the screen
i always wish the screen was ten times
bigger than it ever is it doesn't matter
how big my screen is
so here we have the bitwise and this is
where the two regions intersect and it's
like you expect you can see the white
circle on the square but where they
where they're both at but not where
uh
the black part is so it's only it's the
and they have to have both white on both
the square and the circle
and just like that we can also do the or
and hopefully your mind's already jumped
ahead if we're doing the or cv bitwise
or rectangle in the circle
we have the combination of the two as if
you just pasted one over the other in
this particular case
and
we have
nor
or zors is called
control v
so it's not x nor
or not y
and if you look at that that kind of
makes a pretty pattern on there not x
not y
not x and y not not
but that's a zoro on there you can see
how the zor comes up on there uh and
then of course there's just the bit wise
knot on there
i'm going to run that one and you can
see here where the not set up on that
in this case it just inverses the circle
from black to white
and just like before let's go ahead and
clear our palettes we start with a clean
palette over here also keeps my computer
running smooth
and we have we're now into masking oh my
gosh i use masking so much
and if you go into any program out there
that does any kind of editing masking
comes up so we want to go ahead and work
with our masking on this
and for masking let's bring the cat back
sure is a cute cat in this case we have
a bunch of cute kittens
in fact a bucket of cute kittens that's
a little scary
and we'll go ahead and create a blank
page on here
and this is really interesting in fact
i'm going to stop here and actually do
a draw and i want you to notice right
there oops
right there is the two
the shape and this is a numpy shape so
what are we talking about with this
numpy shape well this numpy shape is
zeros or ones we're really looking for a
black and white image a lot of times we
talk about mass we're talking about true
false and that is the same as in numpy
like a true false mass just like you
have a numpy
and we'll go ahead and create the blank
image over here and it's just like you'd
think it's a black
and then we can easily do both the
circle and rectangle
and you can see here we did an image
shape
this isn't too important right now
because we're going to create the mask
separately in just a second
but you can see where we're creating
our image here there we go so you can
see all the different things in the
window and it's going to create both a
circle and a rectangle mask on here and
let's go ahead and do a
bit wise
we're going to create the mask out of
the bit wise out of the circle and the
square we'll go ahead and run that so
you can see what the mask looks like
and in fact let's let's go back to
let's clear up our um things he gets our
palette here we'll just go run that
we're going to play with the
let's see where are the kittens
gotta have our cute kittens on our
display
there we go there's our kittens come
back okay our bucket of kittens
that cracks me up a bucket of kittens uh
and here's our mask run you see we have
an interesting mask showing on there
and then i'm gonna we're gonna take and
uh combine these
let's see here we go
and we're going to do a bit wise where
we have the image the image and masked
equals mast
uh so here's a bit wise set up on here
and let's see what that looks like
and that it's just kind of fun i've
created this mask adding all these
things together and you can see how
easily we can actually just kind of zero
in there and show just the kitten on the
mask
so that's that's a lot of fun and you
can also reverse this and have an image
without the kitten on there just a black
hole where the cat was
so those are both things that can happen
on here
let's go ahead and clear our setup
and masks can get so complicated you can
see we added two masks together a square
and a circle and got a half circle on
there
um i tell you i've gotten into
so many layers of masks that i can't
even track what's going on anymore
so you gotta be a little careful with
your masks and how you add them together
and bring them together
but there's a lot of things you can do
with them you could just as easily swap
the green channel in for one um so you
have just certain areas where you have
like just a circle it's just green or
maybe the whole background is green and
one area is actually full color
so there's a lot of cool things or you
can mask
take the mask of the
of a black and white image and then mask
a section of it in color i've seen that
done to make some really cool photo
photographs
histograms not something i normally
think of when dealing with photographs
but you can do a histogram of the
information on there
so let's bring back the kittens because
they're just so cute
and let's uh grayscale it
bring them back in our gray-skilled cats
and then what we can do with this
is we can go ahead and do a grace a
histogram on the grayscale
boy we can get so much into histograms
because histograms have so much cool
data that you can bring in
uh so a lot of times you can take images
of something you can start looking at
the number of pixels
the bins that they fall in different
setups as it pulls in but you can see we
have a grayscale the histogram of the
grayscale here
and just like we do the grayscale we can
also do a histogram of the
colored scale too
boom there we go and the same setup we
got our plot figure our title we're just
doing a histogram we're just going to
throw in the colors uh blue green red
um and then we just go through each of
the colors and we go ahead and mask them
and then plot them on here and me just
pull that over so you can easily see
what's going on and the same thing with
the grayscale all we did was come in
here and just drop the grayscale right
on here
with the setup and so we have our figure
bins and a number of pixels
and if we plot the red uh
histogram of the colors uh you can see
here some really kind of fun patterns
and you could analyze these patterns
on different things to
i don't know about kittens um i don't
really think of kittens with histograms
i don't really wouldn't really do a
histogram of a cat
but you could see if this image was like
a heartbeat image or something like that
the histogram would really be showing
and telling you exactly what's going on
and we'll keep the cute kittens up there
and look at thresholding
so we have the threshold the thresh
and the you can do a threshold on here
as far as
there we go let me just bring that down
so you see some of the numbers that go
into there and we're going to use the
grayscale
and just do a simple thresholding view
on here and what we're looking at is the
colors that come forward you can do
different thresholds on different colors
um
and here we're just saying hey if it's
uh
because we're dealing with grays
if the certain color is over 150 or 255
you can see we have a nice or if it's
over 150
then it just turns it black otherwise
it's white and so we create a nice
threshold and you could actually turn
around and use this as a mask back on
the original picture
and it would bring the cats out and make
some interesting pictures on there
but that's a basic threshold on there
there's what they call an inverse
threshold
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that looks like so you have an idea
we'll run
this and this is just you'll see right
here up here we had
threshold gray
very similar
but when we get down to there we go
thresh binary uh inverse there's a key
that changes it so it's still still is
thresh in inverse equals the same
call the same module cv threshold is
just how do we process it on the end and
if we run that if you guessed it inverse
means inverse then you are correct give
it a second to pop back up here on top
there we go
so very similar to the original thresh
inverse but opposite and also makes for
kind of a cool picture you could imagine
taking either one of these and doing
some cool things with them over the
original pictures
and then finally there's an adaptive
threshold on here
and the adaptive threshold let me just
pull that over here
there we go uh
it doesn't quite show up on this uh we
have adaptive threshold gaussians we're
going to use the gaussian if you
remember gaussian means that it is
slow
to bring it up
slow that's not even quite the right
word
there we go okay i wanted to bring that
over so you could see a little bit
better
gaussian means it's adaptive so that the
weight closest to the pixel is very
different than as you get further and
further away as far as adaptive
threshold
and then the adaptive is based
more on the difference between the
pixels as opposed to
the grayness on there
and let's go ahead and we run it let's
take a look on this and see what that
looks like
and we can see just quite the wild
imagery again it almost makes it like a
black and white etch etching or
something like that so it has a really
cool effect
so
a lot of these things are designed
to help find
edges which is our next section we're
going to go over is
pulling out the edges and finding the
edge detection
and so you can see how complicated it is
it's not an easy thing to find the edges
on these pictures what is the edge what
are the colors how do you find that with
the histogram we saw in the color scheme
how they did a certain setup and you
might be able to pull that information
and use it to find an edge
and so there's a whole thing on edge
detection
this is so central to a lot of stuff
being worked on now
because
well let's face it if you're doing like
any kind of imagery you want to know
where the edges are so you can draw a
box around it whether you're trying to
program it to do a facial recognition as
we'll do in the third section we're
going to cover we're in the first
section
but let's go ahead and bring back our
park
run that
and we're also going to do a nice gray
picture on here oops let me put um
the weight key back in there i don't
know why it does not
when i run it without giving it that
extra 60 milliseconds or whatever to
pull it in there it sure gives me a lot
of problems on on this machine
and again it's because i'm doing the
jupiter notebook
when i put this into a widget or
something like that and start using
opencv or use as a backend for code i
don't see these kind of problems it has
a lot to do with just using it in
jupiter notebook
and so let's start with the uh
sobel uh the sobel x or
the solo line detection on here we're
gonna put in
our grayscale setup on here
um there's a lot of different settings
on the subalx subaly
and combining them back together uh so
let's go ahead and take that
and we want to go ahead and show oops i
forgot to bring my shows over
and i'm doing sobel first and the reason
i wanted to do sobel first
is because the other one is based on the
math behind sobel
that we're going to hit the the second
one which is a um
which happens to be the uh laplacian
and so this works on the intensity
from one pixel to the next
and it kind of creates a formula for it
and as you can see as we get into the
intensity from one set up to the other
let me bring this down
uh we can start to see some lines in
here we have from the y direction and
the x direction and we combine them and
you can see there's an interesting kind
of pattern set up in here
now for a scene like the park it's not
really pulling it in that good
and
like i said each one of these has a
different
strength to it
with this one you might do images a
little bit better
close-up shots
but let's look at the laplacian now the
application is very similar how it works
in the background as a sobel as far as
intensity but you take that formula for
generating the intensity on there
and whoops
what happened there
okay uh we take that intensity for that
laplacian
there it is
and they use the second derivative
and you can see how it really transforms
the edges on this image
and there's a lot of things we could do
with this if you remember from earlier
we talked about taking out noise
blurring
if you use some of those features on
here like the foreground would just
disappear with the right blurring
technique or the right transposition
technique
and it really becomes an art form uh
trying to jump between all these and
figure out which one is going to work
for your picture
and your
up on there um and then you run the
histogram to kind of maybe find some try
to find a mathematical thing behind it
it's really a challenge to take the
background out or bring the background
in and sort those things out
and all these tools are slowly being
built and that's what open cv works so
good
uh just because to just to address that
and then we already did the canny setup
we'll go ahead and run the
line detection under kanye
and the kanye literally combines all of
the different math functions of our
[Music]
of the
labylation
and the sobel set up and you can see
here does a really good job of drawing
lines and putting in areas on there
and again this is just a starting point
one of the cool things you can do with
here is blur it and then
like get rid of the bumps in the
beginning and clean it up and do all
kinds of things to create a mask on
there
and let's go ahead and clean up our
screen or pictures and images
and then we're going to dive into uh the
next the second step stage of this
which is motion detection now we covered
a huge amount in all these tools
uh that they have on there from our
canny edge detection
to
bit wise mapping to
masking that's a lot of stuff to cover
some of those tools we're going to use
in the next setup or the next two one of
the next two setups but we're going to
start with motion detection
uh which is kind of fun if you have a
web camera or you have
there's all kinds of reasons you could
use it an outdoor webcam that's my what
i've always wanted to put one up there
to because i live up in the mountains
it'd be fun to track the animals going
by but you could also use the motion
detector to track somebody coming into
an area and then do facial recognition
on them
so you can see the motion detector
has a lot of cool tools on there and the
fact that we're going to grab from the
camera
is really helpful also so let's go ahead
and go in here and open up a new let's
see
new
python 3
and we'll go ahead and rename this real
quick
open cv
motion
detector there we go
so let's dive into our
motion detector and there's
so many we're going to use a lot of the
tools we looked at earlier
so
let's go ahead and start by importing
our
opencv and we went ahead and just did
opencv to remember last time i said
sometimes we leave it as cv
or import
cv2 as cb and so on we're just going to
import it as cv2 in this one
and we're going to do date time for
tracking
we have this thing called static back
it's a
we want to be able to reset something to
none and so having it as a global
variable here makes sense
and then i'm going to have current
motion
and motion list
and what it is is the current motion is
going to have a start time and an end
time that's when it detects a motion
going on
and then the motion list is just going
to keep tagging those on so we have a
new one and an ending one
now we're looking at a lot of code here
so the first piece of code that's i
really want to draw your attention to
is this one right here um cv2 dot
capture video
and then the number is if you had
multiple videos in here you can actually
capture actually capture the video off
the different video cameras and so we're
looking for the main default one
that's going to be set up in here
this is actually kind of cool because i
always had the idea of having uh the
front-facing camera and a side-facing
camera so that you could flip between
them and do different things as far as a
final edit and that kind of thing
but this is the video
it's looking at this camera we're just
setting this up right now for which
camera to look at
now when we're dealing with video
uh we're kind of creating an infinite
loop and so at some point we have to put
a break in it and we'll we'll do that
we'll show you that break here in a sec
in fact
i'm going to skip between the two
and skip the code in the middle so you
can see the beginning and the end and so
we have an infinite while loop and we're
going we're going to stack images as the
video goes and display them
and then when we get to the end of this
infinite while loop we need a way out
in other words you don't want it just to
go on forever until you hit the escape
key
you could do that if you want
but we like to actually add something in
there and we'll go ahead and do
here we go
this
we're going to tag on the end here
uh key weight
key q2 and then just break
now
this won't work like this unless we're
actually displaying a video and that
video screen is highlighted
all this does says is if we are active
in the active video screen when we do
the display when we get to that uh break
now i kind of jumped ahead because we
actually have to create a display in the
middle but i wanted to put this all
together so you could see it all in one
shot here
we have our while loop we're working
with
we're going to go ahead and initiate our
frame outside of here says hey this is
video
whenever i do video this is what we're
looking at then we're going to read the
video and you'll have two returns on
here check and frame and the frame is
nothing more than the image coming in
that's what that is and the check is hey
is do we have an image coming in um if
you remember from earlier we played the
dog video
it came up with check would come up
false when you got to the end of the
video
because this is an indefinite loop we
never do anything with the check uh we
don't have to worry about that too much
so here's here's our kind of our wrapper
and we're going to add a couple more
things before the end of the break on
this
uh
and then we're going to initialize
our motion
so up here i initialized the current
motion as having nothing in it so this
is a current motion there's no action
going on we haven't started an action
there's no end to the action
and then when these fill up we'll put
them into the motion list
and so we're going to go ahead and add
in our motion equal to zero so we're
initializing the motion in the loop and
it starts out and says there's no motion
going on
now
we're going to go ahead and do some fun
stuff here and this stuff comes these
next lines of code come off of what we
just went over
we're going to grayscale it uh very
straightforward so whatever is coming in
the camera is going to have a grayscale
to it
and then we're going to do a gaussian
blur this makes it easier to find the
changes
we're looking for sharp edges that are
moving that's how we're going to do our
motion detector
and if everything's a little blurry
that means the edges are going to stick
out when they move
because everything because they're kind
of blurring it to those edges
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a
if static back is none static back
equals gray so we're going to
assign our very first value to the first
frame that comes in that's all this is
doing on here
and then continue on there
now i'm kind of zipping through these
steps i'm going to go back through them
in just a second so it'll make a little
bit more understanding as we go
a difference between static background
and the current frame which is a
gaussian blur
so we want the difference between the
two frames this is just kind of a fun
abstract way of finding hey what's the
original frame and how much has it
changed
and then if there's a change and you're
going to hopefully already have guessed
that there's some problems with this
piece of code
right
here and i've run into this what if your
image is your outdoor cam and the grass
is blowing in the wind
or the lighting changes because the sun
rises and sets
so it might work great in a room that
has consistent lighting not so good for
a wilderness cam and you've got to start
thinking about these things and there's
ways around it
if there's a change between static
background and the current frame is
greater than 30 it will show
white color so this is kind of fun where
here's our first threshold we're looking
for a threshold between the background
and the foreground
so we're starting to find a little bit
there on the setup and then we're going
to go ahead and take
our threshold frames the difference from
the background and the foreground
and we're going to put that into
the thresh
frame copy
into a fine contours and we're going to
use the chain approximate sample for
finding the contours
so this is going to find some contours
for us and then what we want to look at
is on the contours
so we're counting lines we're counting
how many contours or how many lines are
in here and if there's over 10 000 of
these lines that are the difference
between the initial frame and the new
frame
then the motion's going to be one
wow that's a lot to unpack
so let's go back up here and just go
over that real quick i did each line as
we went in there first thing we're doing
is we're converting it to gray why it's
easier to see gray you can see the
differences in movements and things like
that in gray a lot better than in color
next we're going to blur the gray
this just makes it so it's easier to see
the changes going on
we've reset our static back to none so
we initialize our background to gray
so if it's none then we want the static
back to be
whatever the gray value is of our first
frame so when i turn the camera on i'm
going to be outside the camera so you
can see the back wall of my office which
is
still under construction
just a wall socket and some weird stuff
back there
and that's what i'm going to use for my
basic setup and then when i go back in
and move around or actually just be in
it and just try to hold still move
around a little bit
and then we have the difference between
the static background and the gray frame
so this is the gray frame coming in
versus aesthetic background
and then we take that and we make our
threshold
and we basically create a bunch of
lines we find the contours of the
threshold the difference between those
and so that's where we get our nice
lines and if we have enough lines on
there then that means we have a motion
equals one
so that's a lot of fun motion equals one
so the next stage is if we have a motion
equals one
we want to track it
and so uh we'll go ahead and do that
here just throw that one in
and it says hey if this is a motion
equals one
and our current motion that we're
looking at and our zero slot has nothing
in it
and the motion equals one then we want
to go ahead and stamp the date time in
there
so now we're tracking the start of
movement we have the beginning of
movement
and we can do a bunch of really fun
things and this next part we're going to
use
for a bounding rectangle
and this is going to come up in a
display we're going to show you in a
second this this one
like you know tracking the current
motion
uh you know it's it's kind of cool you
can you it's either zero one
really looking at the contour area
and figuring out how much value to put
this at we put it at ten thousand that's
really part of the opencv
another thing with the opencv is we're
going to start looking at these contours
and we're going to create a rectangle
around them
and then cv2 rectangle
we're just going to take the frame and
write a rectangle right on top of that
frame
now
if for some reason
i stopped moving
we want to know about that so now we've
created a rectangle around movements
we've detected our motions
if it didn't detect any motions and
there's nothing going on
then we want to go ahead and take and
append
the end time so if motion equals 0 and
current motion equals
zero is not equal to an empty set
then we've had movement going on and the
current motion of one needs to equal the
date time
we'll go ahead and just tag the current
motion right on top
and then the current motion is reset to
an empty set
so that's all it is is we're just
creating an array
of the emotions
and this is just kind of fun right now
um we're going to go ahead and do
displaying the images we'll start with
uh image gray frame
and there's our gray on there and if you
remember up here
we drew a box on it so you're going to
start seeing the rectangle
on the frame
coming in and then we're going to go and
display start displaying the gray frame
because we converted everything to frame
we want to go ahead and display the
differential
so you can see what what's going on in
there and why that looks different
we want to spray both the
threshold frame and the color frame so
we're going to do all of these up here
there we go okay
so we basically are showing up
everything that we put together so that
it's going to show up on the screen in
little boxes
and then we have our key weight and i
said i need to fill some more stuff in
here
well if we're in the middle of detection
of motion and i hit the q button
it'll be nice to know that it'd be nice
to tag that on to the end
so we'll go ahead and tag that on to the
end here
and if motion equals one and current
motion of zero is not equal to an empty
set then current motion of one equals
date time now
and motionless append the current motion
and then break that takes us out of
the loop completely
and then once we hit the break uh we'd
like to see what's going on with our
motion this that's what it's all about
is the motion list
so do a quick display on our motion list
i don't want to go past 30 if i do too
many start and stops
this is important let me go ahead and
highlight this right here
we want to release the video
and of course destroy all our windows
okay and that's just cleaning up always
good to clean up on there
um
and these are nothing more
let me go back up to the top here we go
we've already talked a lot about the
show
so we're showing the gray frame that we
created
we're showing the difference frame that
we created we're showing the threshold
frame
and then we're showing the actual uh
color frame that's actually coming in
the frame that's coming in
so wow that's a lot to break down let's
go ahead and run it hopefully i didn't
miss something when i was coming over
here
and we should see it coming through it's
setting up it's accessing the window
and i have to minimize excess behind it
and there we are
still moving there we go move back and
forth this is kind of cool because you
can see as i move back and forth look at
the lines around my face
especially on the
difference frame you can see where it's
putting nice contours on there and
setting it up
so i need to go ahead and click on one
of these boxes because i moved the mouse
on the other one and we'll push the q
button
and then we'll bring back up our
opencv and you can see here every time i
start and stop
it puts a start time and an end time and
we could have easily put the frame count
you can put just about anything you want
on there
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
one more time
and then move
and hold still
then click on then then go and hit the q
and we can see here that instead of
having
there we go boom
that it it picked up on a number of
different start and stops on here one
two three four five six seven starting
stops
so not bad you know a little motion
detector um again you can see up here
where we're capturing the video we're
looping through and finding the video on
each one
and then we do all of our fun
transformations on creating the
grayscale and gaussian blur
anything to make it cleaner as far as
counting up the threshold lines to see
whether we should make it a motion or
not
and then of course we tacked the emotion
the motion on there
we added these little boxes around the
contours
that was kind of fun because you could
see as i moved how it changed and
there's still like this weird blur in
the background
and then of course if we stop it tags on
an in value
and here's all of our displays
and voila we have a motion detector or
at least a start to one
you got to mess with it a little bit
there's obviously you might want to do
like every
one of the tricks that i use is where
you have the static right here
is we revert to the gray static view
this one is if it's um
you might just revert this to a new
frame every so many frames uh that kind
of thing so there's a little bit of lots
of play in here that you can do with
this
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more that puts us on
this demo which is facial recognition
so let's go ahead and create a new oops
where's our new there we go new
python 3
and you could see how you can combine
the motion detector with the facial
recognition detector
so there's a lot of really cool things
we can do here
this will be
cross
open cv
facial
recognition recognition rename
there we go
and so to start with let's go ahead and
import our information on here
we're going to import our cv2 as cv
again this is a personal preference
i go back and forth on this there's a
lot of reasons to do it this way if they
update it and it's backward compatible
if it's not backward compatible that's
going to cause problems
but that's going to be fine we have a
lot of files going on with this so as we
start messing with the cross and you
want to have access to these files
let us know we can send you
you know compress them down and send
them just put a note into the
send a note over to the simply learn
team and they can help you with that
so the first thing we're going to start
with
is the beginning we have face detection
um we've got a picture of a lady a group
of five people image
we have a grayscale grayscale the people
um let's go ahead and run we'll go ahead
and move this off to the side again like
we've been doing
and run it
there we go and of course it appears
right behind here
move it off to the side
and give that a second to pull in
as of now we haven't done anything as
you can see we just have two blank gray
screens
now because these aren't loaded all the
way if you try to exit out of them uh
they'll just kind of lock the system up
with it when you're connected with the
jupiter notebooks so we want to go ahead
and just destroy all the windows let me
run that and see that they are gone
and so we have our two our uh
gray people gray those are gray boxes
that's what the gray people are in there
and we're going to bring in the what's
called a cascade classifier
and when you look at the cascade
classifier
it's going to load the xml hard face
file right there
this is real important this is all
pre-built it's looking for edges that
are common in faces that's what this
means
i mean look at the har-face xml like
it's looking at the edges is what it's
doing there is all kinds of really fun
stuff they have let me just bring this
over from the github this is the opencv
data our cascades
github and if you go into here
you can see we have
eyes
let's see what is this eye tree with
eyeglasses
frontal cat face i guess a lot of people
like to identify their cat in photos
uh frontal face frontal face so there's
a lot of different full body left eye
right eye
there's a russian numbers you can also
create your own so there's a lot of
stuff you can do with an h with a har
cascade file
we're going to load that up specific to
detecting faces in here so that's what
this part is about
let's go ahead and apply that
and so you can see we create a faces
rectangle uh har cascade detect
multiscale
we're going to put our gray into there
the what we loaded the picture in there
and then it has some
scale factor many neighbors there's a
lot of different things you can do with
this a lot of times these are pretty
much the default
default works pretty good on a lot of
this stuff and then if you want to dig
in deeper into why one would work more
why you need more information
you can go back into the opencv but it's
good to know about the horror cascade
detect multi-scale
and then when we're processing these the
first thing we want to know is we want
to print
how many number of faces found you want
to make sure we're not looking at a
crowd of 500 people with a ton of
different faces on there
and just because let me go and put this
back up here
just because we like to see
we have to have a view of it we're going
to go ahead and create
square it off so it so it has just the
face in there create the face rectangle
and then we're going to go ahead and
show those images
i'm like if you're like me i like to see
what i'm looking at
so let's go ahead and run this
and when we run this let me go ahead and
put this back into half screen
uh the first thing we do is you notice
the number of faces found is one
uh that's really what we're looking for
is we want to make sure there's just a
single face on here and you can see here
there's our group of five people that
says it's actually just one person it
found in there
again
you can see it has a nice image of the
person coming up in the different scales
and colors
and
this is the one we really want to look
at as you can see right here as it puts
a rectangle
right around the face this is really
nice because now if you are processing
this you're processing the face or maybe
you're processing the background it can
be used for either one to pull the
background out from the face and blur it
or take the face and center it so
there's a lot of different things you
can do here if you know this is a face
and then you remember from previous we
did edging you can now draw an edge and
find that edging around her head knowing
that the center of the face where nose
is and then you could blur the
background you'll see that in a lot of
newer zoom and
uh webex kind of things where they blur
the background out so people can't see
what's behind you when you're on one of
those meetings
now we're going to go ahead and clear
this
again
this thing is set up in jupiter
there's ways to get around this but for
the most part it's just good to clean up
after yourself because we're
extending it out there so we'll go ahead
and destroy all the windows
the next two steps or our final two
steps are
to go ahead and create a model and train
it so we want to train our model and
then actually apply it
use it for something
and we're going to go in here let me
just hold this up
and we got here is we have
our people we're going to look at
pictures of ben affleck elton john jerry
seinfeld madonna
mindy kaling
these are really easy to pull up images
because these are you know famous actors
i don't recognize any of them no i'm
kidding
i actually know all of them
and we've got it in here we've got it
set up in one of the files and we're
just going to print the directory so you
can take a quick look at that and see
what we're looking at here
um
this is where it goes to let me go and
pull that up so you can see what the
actual files look like
and you can see here is um coming
drilling down into it let me just go
under ben affleck and you can see it's
all these pictures this is what we're
looking at is different head shots of
ben affleck on here
one of the things to notice is that at
some point we probably need to resize
because some of these photos are a
little bit wider a little bit taller
and that squishes things and expands
them
so a lot of these detections when we
start looking at faces is actually doing
its best to
do the same thing compress and expand
them into
and train it on those different shapes
and we'll go ahead and load our
h-a-r-h-a
cascade back in here with our face xml
that we had before
being that we're in jupiter notebooks
it's probably still listed in there
we want to go ahead and
create an empty array of features and an
empty ray of labels
and we'll show you what that does here
in just a minute this is for tracking
our different features in here
so let's go ahead and we have our
features and our labels let's go ahead
and create the data this is what we're
doing here
so we have our person and people here's
our all our people it's going to go
through each one we have our path which
is our directory always good to double
check those make sure you go in the
right direction
we can actually print the path out so
that as we go we know we're looking at
the full path
kind of a troubleshooting thing usually
at this point i've already deleted a lot
of these things out of here and you can
see that
the guys in the back were
when they were doing it they forget
where they put the files or where
they're going to get some kind of weird
error and then you're like oh yeah yeah
yeah i moved there i moved the program
over one or something like that
and so we need to go ahead and create a
label
um people.index person so we're creating
a label for our training scenario
and then for each image in the os list
directory per person we're going to look
at each one of those images
then we'll take that and we'll create
the
image path image
array
and here's our reader where we're going
to read in the image
here we are in opencv we're going to put
that into a grayscale
faces rectangle so we look at the find
the faces on there and create a
rectangle around it
that's what this part is this is all
from what we did before you already saw
this programming in here
and so we are basically taking our
features
and filling it up with um the different
faces
just the face
we don't want to look at the whole body
shot if you remember from the image one
of them had them leaning against a tree
some of them are close up some of them
are far away so we really all look just
at the face
and then we're going to go ahead and
append our label so we have our
features these are each one of our
images and the label then corresponds to
each one of our
actors
so once we've done that we have our
setup on here and this is
for training purposes that's what we
really want to do is we want to create
our trainer
let me come back down here
create our trainer we want to create we
want to train our model
so here we come in down here we have our
features
we're we're gonna print that the
training is done so it's gone through
and it's it's cleaned up all the
features all the setup in here
then we have our face recognizer
this is
the heart of what's going on
the face recognizer uh it's an lbh face
recognizer crate so we're creating a
neural network right here
that's the model
and then we take our face recognizer and
we train it with our features and our
labels so now we have those different
images and we're going to train them on
this model here
and then we'll go ahead and just save it
save features.npa features and save
labels we're just saving everything
that's all this is down here
and this is interesting because there's
so many things we can do down here let
me just go ahead and run this
and you can see it's going through and
it's opening up each of the files
and then it goes through the training's
really quick there's not a lot of data
in here you know what a dozen pictures
of each one
this isn't like going through
seven gigabytes of information that
takes a day to process in one of these
neural networks and trains them or two
or three days in the case of a project
i'm working on
this is just a small amount of data
so it processes rather quickly
some of the things you can do on here
is
to increase increase the data just with
these images
as you can
tilt them you can take them and tilt it
by 15 or 10 percent remember earlier we
were looking at all those different
commands
that is one of the tricks they use for
training
a setup and not knowing what angle the
person is going to be at they might only
have 12 pictures and then if you
tilt it 15 degrees and 30 degrees in
each direction
you've now increased it by five by a
factor of five so now you have about 60
pictures that you're doing for each
person so there's a lot of cool things
you can do as far as as your training
set up
we've now created our
face recognizer it's trained it's ready
to go so the next step is to go ahead
and use it and let's see what that looks
like
so so and create our face recognizer
recognition setup and we're going to
reload this here's our people again same
as before of course you can just leave
it up there since with jupiter notebook
it automatically brings a lot of this
stuff in and then we have our features
about pickles truce we're loading up our
features here's our labels we're going
to load our labels remember we saved
them up here
and then we go ahead and take our face
recognizer and we're going to create
that and then we're going to just read
the face trained at the y the
yml file we created so we're just
loading back up what we had up here
that's all that is
this is really good to know about
because this makes it very portable
this way if you're using it in one
location obviously you can download it
you know all your security cameras track
your neighbors as they walk down the
sidewalk next to your house
and then we're going to just read a
image in
and this one we're just going to take
right from the
ben affleck
and we're going to do the first
the ben affleck number one image in
there that's all that is
and we'll go ahead and create our
grayscale image and we'll show that just
because it's good to see whatever we're
working with
so this is taking our image in
converting it to a
grayscale
show person in grayscale
detect the face in the image this is
nothing new this is from before we're
doing the mahar cascade detect multi
scale
set up on there
and then we want to go ahead and create
that rectangle around it once we create
that rectangle around it
then we want to go ahead and
do a prediction on it let's go ahead and
do that there we go um
so here's our our faces rectangle and so
we're going to create that
with our faces roi
and then here's the key right here
uh here's our faces recognizer predict
it's going to return the label and the
confidence on here
and then we're going to go ahead and
print that label
with the confidence of and it'll show
the confidence
and then we'll go ahead and put some
text on there and print it out it's
always nice to
see what's going on and then another
rectangle on there so we just are we're
just showing the image again so as it
comes down
this is a key though as we want to print
out and find out what's the chances of
this label being correct
now right about now
you should be guessing that it's going
to get it correct and you're going to
guess is going to have a very high
confidence rating
and the reason you want to guess that is
because we didn't take this image out
and switch it around
in other words this image was part of
the training and so i should have a very
high confidence and have it correct
that's already in the model
and let's go and see what happens we'll
go ahead and run this
and you can see the label says hey it's
been afflecked with the 99.53
and if we bring up the images here
whoops
let me go ahead and half screen this
again so we can see what we got going
here
and
for whatever reason it doesn't want to
put them on top hold on
i lost my images
there it is and you can see
peered up on my far left monitor which i
don't know why i went there that was
kind of weird and then there's the
grayscale behind it
and you can see here we were able to
identify
ben
affleck with a confidence of 99.53
now what is keras
before we move on to keras let's take a
look at tensorflow tensorflow is a
software library which was created by
google to implement large-scale machine
learning models and to help solve
complex numerical problems tensorflow is
an end-to-end open source machine
learning platform which you can think of
as an infrastructure layer for
differentiable programming it combines
four key abilities
first efficiently executing low level
tensor operations on cpu and gpu or tpu
computing gradient of arbitrary
differential expressions scaling
computation to many devices and
exporting programs to external runtimes
such as servers browsers or mobiles
but what does keras have to do with all
of this keras is nothing more than a
high level deep learning api which is
written in python for neural networks it
has multiple backend neural network
computations and it makes implementing
neural networks easy
as we know keras is a powerful and easy
to use free open source python library
for developing and evaluating deep
learning models
keras is a high level api of tensorflow
2
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with a focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing and shipping machine learning
solutions with high iteration velocity
keras empowers engineers and researchers
to take full advantage of the
scalability and cross-platform
capabilities of tensorflow 2. you can
run keras on tpu or on large classes of
gpu and you can export your keras model
to run in the browser or on a mobile
device keras provides a python interface
for artificial neural networks keras
acts as an interface for tensorflow
library and it helps in implementation
of commonly used neural network building
block layers such as objectives
activation functions and optimizers and
a host of tools to make working with
images and text data easier to simplify
the coding necessary for writing deep
neural network code
basically it wraps efficient numerical
computation libraries such as theano and
tensorflow and allows you to define and
change neural network models in just a
few lines of code in fact tensorflow and
keras are so tight together that even in
tensorflow the official get started with
tensorflow tutorial we use high level
keras apis embedded in tensorflow
instead of just using tensorflow by
itself
some of the important features of keras
include keras being a high level
interface which uses theano or
tensorflow for its back end
keras can run smoothly on both cpu and
gpu
it supports almost all the models
required for you to create a complete
neural network
and it is extremely modular in nature
which means it is incredibly expressive
flexible and apt for innovative research
so why do we need keras
first of all keras is an api which is
designed for human beings not for
machines which means that it follows
best practices for reducing cognitive
load it offers consistent and simple
apis it minimizes the number of users
action required for common use cases and
it provides clear and actionable
feedback upon
user error it is extremely powerful and
easy to use and it also wraps numerical
computation libraries such as theano and
tensorflow and allows you to train and
define neural networks in a few lines of
code
this makes keras easy to learn and use
as a keras user you can be more
productive allowing you to try more
ideas than your competition faster which
in turn will help you win machine
learning competition this ease of use
does not come at the cost of reduced
flexibility because keras integrates
deeply with low level tensorflow
functionality it enables you to develop
highly hackable workflows where any
piece of functionality can be customized
or reused easily
building a model in keras let's take a
look at the basic pipeline which you
will have to follow when you are using
keras to define a neural network first
of all you will have to define a neural
network you will have to select the
activation functions and the various
mathematical operations that are gonna
be taking place in your neural network
along with the different weightages
next you will use keras to compile your
network which is basically you will use
keras to build it
after this you will fit to your network
you will fit all the training data that
you have to your network
and use your testing data to evaluate
how the network works
finally you will use this network to
make predictions
this entire five-step pipeline can be
executed in keras within two to three
lines of code neural networks which
would have taken people days or even
weeks to make can be executed in keras
in a couple of hours
now users of keras
the first use of keras is to productize
deep models on smartphones deep models
require a lot of computation power to
run but with the help of keras we can
literally make deep models a product
which can be sold and executed on
smartphones
the next use of keras is in distributed
training of deep learning models
distributed training means that we can
split our deep learning model into
different paths and train it on systems
all across the globe this makes training
of our deep learning model extremely
fast along with saving time we are also
saving on the computational power of our
system as it is not only our system
which has to run such a heavy program by
distributing it across various systems
all the resources required to train a
deep learning model go down
significantly before we can see the
differences between these platforms we
first need to know what exactly each of
these platforms are let's start with
tensorflow
what is tensorflow tensorflow is a low
level software library which is created
by google to help implement machine
learning models and to solve complex
numerical problems
tensorflow is nothing but a free and
open source software library for machine
learning
it can be used across a range of tasks
but has a particular focus on training
and inference of deep neural networks
tensorflow is a symbolic math library
based on data flow and differential
programming it is used for both research
and production at google
what do you mean by data flow it
basically means that we perform
calculations by converting every element
into graphical form
the variables of the graph are called
tensors and mathematical operations are
called operators
here in the computational graph shown
you can see that x y and 2 are the
variables they will also be called
tensors and division multiplication and
addition are the operators
this graph basically shows us the
calculation that is going to occur in a
machine learning model
where x and y are going to be divided
and y and 2 are going to be multiplied
the results of these two calculations
are then going to be added to give us
the final output i told you that x y and
2 are also called tensors
what exactly are tensors tensors are
multi-dimensional arrays with a uniform
type all tensors are immutable like
python numbers and strings which means
that you cannot update the contents of a
tensor you can only create a new tensor
next let's look at the api keras
what exactly is keras keras is a high
level deep learning api written in
python for easy implementation and
computation of neural networks keras is
an open source software library that
provides a tensorflow interface for
artificial neural networks keras acts as
an interface for the tensorflow library
which means that it runs on top of
tensorflow
up until version 2.3 keras supported
multiple back-ends
including tensorflow microsoft cognitive
toolkit
or cntk
r theano and played ml
as of version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
as a version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
designed to help enable fast
experimentation with deep neural
networks in it focuses on being user
friendly modular and extensible
keras is a high level api of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with the focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing
and shipping machine learning solutions
with high iteration velocity keras does
not perform its own low level operations
such as tensor products and convolution
it relies on back end engines for that
even though keras supports multiple back
end engines its primary back-end engine
is tensorflow and its primary supporter
is google which means that keras acts as
nothing more but a wrapper class around
tensorflow theano cntk played ml or
mxnet which are low level apis next we
will look at pi torch what exactly is
pytorch
pytoch is a low level api which is
developed by facebook for natural
language processing and computer vision
it is a more powerful version of numpy
it is an open source machine learning
library based on the torch library used
for applications such as computer vision
and natural language processing
primarily developed by facebook's ai
research lab it is free and open source
software released under the modified bsd
license although the python interface is
a more polished and the primary focus of
development pytorch also has a c plus
plus interface python is a widely liked
language because it is easy to
understand and write pytorch emphasizes
flexibility and allows deep learning
models to be expressed in basic python
pytorch is mainly used for natural
language processing
and for computer vision
now let's move on to the differences
between tensorflow keras and pytorch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of api
there are two main types of apis a low
level api and a high level api api
stands for application programming
interface
a low level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have more detailed control
to manipulate functions within them on
how to use and implement them
while a high level api is more generic
and simple and provides more
functionality with one command
statements than a lower level api high
level interfaces are comparatively
easier to learn and to implement the
models using them
they allow you to write code in a
shorter amount of time and to be less
involved with the details
in this case tensorflow is a high and
low level api
pure tensorflow is a low level api while
tensorflow wrapped in keras is a high
level api
keras in itself is a high level api
which uses multiple low level apis as a
backend and simplifies the operation of
these low level apis
pi torch is a low level api
the next criteria that we'll be looking
at is speed
tensorflow is very fast and is used for
high performances
keras is slower as it works on top of
tensorflow not only does it have to wait
for tensorflow to finish implementation
it then starts its own implementation
meanwhile pi torch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis
now keras is a wrapper class for
tensorflow and has added abstraction
functionalities on top of tensorflow
which make it slower than tensorflow and
pi torch in computation speed both
tensorflow and pi torch are almost equal
and in development speed keras is faster
as it has built-in functionalities which
can significantly reduce your
development time
the next difference is on the
architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile keras has a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in keras significantly easier pie touch
on the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to keras tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pytorch is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes
data sets and debugging
tensorflow works with large data sets
due to its high execution speed and
debugging is really hard in tensorflow
due to its complex nature
meanwhile keras only works with very
small data sets as its speed of
execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in keras as they are
relatively simpler and by torch can
manage high level tasks in higher
dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both qrs and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development as we said before tensorflow
works with many
hard concepts such as computational
graphs and tensors which means that
writing code in tensorflow is very hard
it is generally used by people when they
are doing research work and really need
very specific functionalities
keras on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pytorch is easier than
tensorflow but is still comparatively
hard than keras it is not
very easy to learn for beginners but is
significantly more powerful than just
plain keras ease of deployment
tensorflow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensorflow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis
tensorflow serving provides
out-of-the-box integration with
tensorflow models but can be easily
extended to serve other types of models
and data
in keras model deployment can be done
with either tensorflow serving or flask
which makes it relatively easy but not
as easy as you as it would be with
tensorflow and pie pytorch
pytorch uses itouch mobile which makes
deployment easy but again for tensorflow
deployment is way easier as tensorflow
serving can update your machine learning
back end on the fly without
the user even realizing
there's a growing need to execute ml
models on edge devices to reduce latency
preserve privacy and enable new
interactive use cases in the past
engineers used to train models
separately they would then go through a
multi-step error-prone and often complex
process to train the models for
execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pytorch mobile by allowing a seamless
process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pi torch ecosystem it provides an
end-to-end workflow that simplifies the
research to production environment for
mobile devices
in addition it paves the way for privacy
preserving features via federated
learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use keras tensorflow or pytorch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user friendly than any other deep
learning api however and is easier to
learn for beginners
pytorch on the other hand is the
preferred deep learning api for teachers
but it is not as widely used in
production as tensorflow is it is faster
but it has lower gpu utilization
at the end of the day
the framework that we would suggest that
you use is tensorflow
why
while pytorch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production
pytorch's ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky solutions and smaller scale
models
but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models in addition the
tensorflow board visualization features
offers a nice way of showing the inner
workings of your model to say your
customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like keras is much easier to
start with than plane tensorflow but if
you want to do something with keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so we're going to dive right into what
is cross we'll also go all the way
through this into a couple of tutorials
because that's where you really learn a
lot is when you roll up your sleeves so
we talk about what is cross cross is a
high level deep learning api written in
python for easy implement implementation
of neural networks uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pi torch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different
neural networks uh is really powerful
it's really powerful to to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crosswords by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user-friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api specifications and under that you'd
have like tf cross for tensorflow thano
cross and so on and then you have your
tensorflow workflow that this is all
sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in python
that's usually your left your remainder
or multiplication uh you might have the
operator of x to the power of 0.3 and it
uses useful for calculating derivatives
by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to hand write everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems
specify input and outputs and make sure
all nodes are connected and so this is
really nice as you come in through is
that as your layers are going in there
you can get some very complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense your layer
one as an activation now they're using
the relu in this particular example and
then you have your name layer one layer
dense relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
and this is really where things are at
this is new make sure you update your
cross or you'll find yourself running
this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by three
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one node for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want to send it through the same neural
network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the date up
and how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel
you have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at crust
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands-on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and
showing people especially shareholders
it really helps because it's a nice
visual so let me go and flip over to our
anaconda and the anaconda has a lot of
cool two tools they just added data lore
and ibm watson studio cloud into the
anaconda framework but we'll be in the
jupiter lab or jupiter notebook i'm
going to do jupiter notebook for this
because i use the lab for like large
projects with multiple pieces because
multiple tabs or the notebook will work
fine for what we're doing and this opens
up in our browser window because that's
how jupiter dope so jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sklearn or your site kit if
you're installing sklearn the sk learn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experienced no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
uh so we want to do for i and range and
we want to go ahead and create if you
look here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
uh let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples a pin
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1 000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
so we have our so it just randomizes it
that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow
and you want to randomize it just to
make sure that that you know the input
doesn't follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar uh
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh and then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.791
so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
tensorflow
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
careful don't quote wikipedia on these
things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down
uh
we're gonna import from tensorflow the
cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow across
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
your data when you first do it atoms as
good as any atom is usually there's a
number of optimizer out there there's
about there's a couple of main ones but
atom is usually assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day you know
at the end of the story how good does
your model do and we'll go ahead and
load all that and then comes the fun
part um i actually like to spend hours
messing with these things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here i'm
going to explain that in just a second
we have a model and it's a sequential
model if you remember correctly we
mentioned the sequential up here where
it goes from one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be our
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is uh usually it's just dense and
then you have your input and your
activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting
because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10 h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh oops let me do this uh rayleigh
there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept to build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so you can do
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when i say spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data it's probably 80 of your
programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to go ahead
and
train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
[Music]
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate's set
to point o
uh
set to 0.01 uh depending on what you're
doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit so you'd want
to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keras how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epochs
and
put the verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
um here's our loss
now if you remember correctly up here we
set the loss let's see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how how much does the
error go down is the best way to look at
that and you can see here the lower the
number the better it just keeps going
down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is
more important because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up over fitting and
under fitting models
we went ahead and went through uh 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going um to be honest i
usually uh uh the first time i run it
i'm like oh that's cool i get to see
what it does and after the second time
of running it i'm like i'd like to just
not see that and you can repress those
of course in your code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we are already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model as we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they're
going to have
symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want a
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max
for prediction so it just goes to 0 1
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
uh rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this is no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms symptoms
no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matplot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
what we do have here is we're going to
do a plot confusion matrix there's our
cm our classes normalize false title
confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted that ten of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no uh
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a
i spent a lot of time on some of the
parts but you can see here is really
simple
we did the random generation of data but
when we actually built the model coming
up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the
oops there we go okay so implementing a
neural network with cross after creating
our samples and labels we need to create
our cross neural network model we will
be working with a sequential model which
has three layers and this is what we did
we had our input layer our hidden layers
and our output layers and you can see
the input layer
coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
uh and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
so the blue ones
we want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so i had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now uh saving and loading models with
karass we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down we randomized some data we created
the
cross setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
karass so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time
and this might be important if you're at
the front of a store this is something
today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask
and let's start with a little bit on the
data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with a
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
it might run in a three seven i'm not
sure i haven't i kind of skipped three
seven and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
three eight
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the
they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code
and we'll open up a new python three
oops python three
it's working on it there we go
um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's
safe mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them uh so we have in here
we go alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images
are like a
a square grid and then each value in
there has three values for the three
different colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die
they find that they actually create more
of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
dense input we did that in the other one
so that should look a little familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category zero one doesn't
really mean anything it's like true
false
label binarizer the same thing
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup and tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the
second piece when we reload up the data
and hook it up to a video camera we're
going to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matte plot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epics to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate uh to the
negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001 usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
and now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite let me
go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're mostly squares you'll see some
that are slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even eight gigs
would easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is
do they have a mask on zero do they not
have a mask on one so this is the same
as what we saw up here without mask one
equals
the second value is without mass so with
mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual
linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data and we'll go ahead
and make sure it's going to be random
and we'll take 20 percent of it for
testing and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean
well if i rotate the data around and i
zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it um is able to it's
kind of like increasing the number of
samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or all those little shifts cause a
problem if you're doing just a standard
set of data so we're going to create an
augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so that you can better train your model
and so we go and run this and then we're
going to
load and then we need to go ahead and
you probably would have gotten an error
if you hadn't put this piece in right
here um i haven't run it myself because
the guys in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults
just saying hey we're going to auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware that with this kind of
imagery we're already augmenting it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flattened so we're flattening
the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images
and the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a dropout
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here they
discovered this a while back
we have another dense mode and this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is the relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model
so again we're still building our model
here we'll go ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers.trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first set of 30 data
before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and is jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased if you have a
higher accuracy on your testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's overfitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either zero or one it's uh
zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
0 or 1 coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
um so that's pretty high set up on there
you know you three people are going to
sneak into the store who
are without a mask and it thinks they
have a mask and there's going to be
three people with a mask that's going to
flag the person at the front to go oh
hey look at this person you might not
have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking in to the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
um
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end
and this is an important step because
we're gonna this is just cool i love
doing this stuff uh so we're gonna go
ahead and take our model and we're gonna
save it uh so model save
massdetector.model we're gonna give it a
name we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
save the model they upload the model now
they can use it for whatever and then if
i get more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics we only did the you
know only shows just the one epic coming
in here but you can see right here as
the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
scikit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our loss and our accuracy
come together and also up here and this
is why i'd run it more than just two
epochs as you can see they still haven't
converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going what we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobile net v2 import pre-processing
input so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of this stuff stuff's going
on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little open cv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
uh and then we have of course time and
just our operating system so those are
the things we're going to go ahead and
set up on here
and then we're going to create this
takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
uh so we're going to detect and predict
the mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and and create
a mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're going to send that in there and
i'll show you in a second where that is
but it's going to be under face net
uh and then we go ahead and initialize
our list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mass network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections we're going to filter out
weak detection by ensuring the
confidence is greater than the minimum
confidence
so we've set it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimum confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
uh so we create a box around what's
going to we hope it's going to be the
face extract the face roi convert it
from bgr to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order um i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cvt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the opencv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32
so these different images of where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different path depending on
where you have it or however you want to
do it and how you saved it on the last
one where we trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
video setup
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked up
and then you know starting video you're
going to print it out
here's our video source equals 0 start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there
let me close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual
stream we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask
l0225 and you know it's going to make a
lot more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we see the data coming down
here and we're waiting for the pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
ah
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat uh
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask let me
go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into the video
camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic
demo up above for just pulling in a
cross and then we went into a cross
model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application
sequential models in cross
so what is cross
cross is a high level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level back-ends like tensorflow
fano
pi torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language
and then it sits on neural networks in
this case uh the ones listed were
tensorflow thano and pi torch which can
all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very
user friendly as far as neural network
software goes as a high level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations
the nodes and data flow in a graph
correspond to mathematical operations
and variables
you'll hear a lot
some of the terms you might hear are
node and edge the edge being the data
flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on cross and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does
it is the core component of a neural
network is what's important to know on
this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation power by using a low level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
back end or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create
it's a lot a lot of back-end programming
this is like the old computers when you
had to tell it how to dispose of a
variable and how to properly re-allocate
the memory for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with keras is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you would could spend hours on
just trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives uh in this little
video
but understanding uh a derivative is the
rate of change so if you have a
particular function you're using in your
neural network
a lot of them is just simple uh
y equals mx plus b your euclidean
geometry where you just have a simple
slope times the intercept and they get
very complicated they have the inverse
tangent function for activation as
opposed to just a linear euclidean model
and you can think about this as you have
your data coming in and you have to
alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross you'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer
to get that parallel processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks uh
you usually have to pre-process your
data so that it's between minus one and
one or zero and one into some kind of
value that's usable that occurs before
it gets to the neural network
in fact eighty percent of data science
is usually in prepping that data and
getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in
so each connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
to figure them out and figure out what
they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer so you have used for plain stack
of layers where each layer has one input
and one output
tensor and this is what tensorflow is
named after is each one of these layers
is like a tensor
each node is a tensor and then the layer
is also considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about
this is something this is a teapot this
is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different sequential in this case means
it goes from the input to layer 1 to
layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers you can
have another model where you have an
input coming in and it splits and then
you have one set that's doing one set of
uh nodes maybe they're doing a yes no
kind of node where it's either putting
out a zero or a one a classifier and the
other one might be regression it's just
processing numbers and then you
recombine them for the output
that's what they call a cross the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do it and do a demo on here
uh today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo in whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupyter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a
new python project python3 i'm in python
3.8 on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sklearn or sitekit it's not actually
sklearn you'll need to go ahead and
install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other append is a
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sklearn or
scikit this is the site kit set up sci
kit
even though you use sklearn to bring it
in it's the scikit and then our cross we
have our preprocessing the images image
data generator
our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these uh different optimizers we didn't
even use these in the actual demo you
just have to be aware that they are
different optimizers and the digger the
more you dig into these models you'll
hit a point where you do need to play
with these a little bit but for the most
part leave it at the default when you're
first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have drop out they have
flattened they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers and we get to
the model we're going to talk about them
a lot of times when you're just starting
you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your drop out your flattened
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally uh import random is rn
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd2 is
uh we have our tqdm
the
tqdm is for um it's a progress bar
just a fancy way um of adding when
you're running a process you can view
the bar going across in the jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to be able to shuffle some files
again these are all different things
pill is another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything
if you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this light we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
uh you multiply 150 times 150 times
three
that's how many nodes input layer is
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in and then
you have your hidden layers a lot of
times they match what the image size is
coming in so each one of those is also
just as big and then we get down to just
a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
and then we want to go ahead and we need
to assign labels remember we defined x
and z
so we're just going to create a uh
definition here
and the first thing is uh return flower
type okay
it just returns it what kind of flower
it is i guess a sign label to it
but we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here
the first one
is we're just appending right on to our
numpy array the image
we're going to let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string a pin the label on there and i
want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones
this is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory
print length of x so here we go let's go
and run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there
to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
and then of course you can see this nice
bar here this is the bar going across is
that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily when you're building
your own model or something like that
but if you're going to display this to
other people
adding that little what was it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you've
got to figure out how to handle them
and so when we get all the way down to
the
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just gonna um hope
it wasn't there it is there's our error
i knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
uh just skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay i lost
three points who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right along and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there in
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
uh and then we can go ahead and just
take a quick look and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
let's see what we got here
looks like
we're going to do like five of each of
them i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data uh no matter what you're
doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip that is that resize
to 150 by 150
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
uh
and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just going to lea is a label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma 5 x here's our
array
x so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform z
that's our z array we created
um and then we have y which equals that
and then we go ahead and do to
categorical we want five different
categories
and then we create our x uh np array of
x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
zero one two three four five as the
output and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those color arrays
range from zero to 250. so when we take
the x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from 0 to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between 0 and 1.
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much and so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data in y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split
and we're just going to go ahead and do
the test size at about a quarter of the
data 0.25 and of course random is always
good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the uh or i train it on two of
those parts with one being the test and
i rotate it so i come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
xtranex test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep um all this prep
and then we finally get to the exciting
part
this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going and you have
everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential um they
have the api which is across the cross
tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional
2d network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is their own neural
network and this basically
becomes like a
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
uh we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five
it's a two d so it has your x y
coordinates
and when we look at this five by five
remember each one of these is is
actually looking at five by five by
three
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different
pixels
and padding is just um
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by three pixels
and then we have to pull it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d um
layer
we have to bring this back together and
pull this into a neural network
and then we're going to go ahead and
repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters and so
each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we add we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by 3.
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the pixels and
everything is just flat
and then the dense
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
softmax
is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um i should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values uh
so as your x as it adds in all those uh
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between 0 and 1 and has a
nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
and if we come down the seven popular
activation functions non-linear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
[Music]
oops let's make sure we can find the
specific to relu
so this is a leaky relu
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your relu loses some nodes they just
become inactive
but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the rayleigh you can see
the rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the leaky
railway over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the sig is the exponential
one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice funky curve
that comes in that has a whole different
meaning and captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here
128
epix 10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epochs 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
so there's different ways to reduce
the values and verbose verbose equals
one means that we're going to show
what's going on
um
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to zero you don't have to watch it
train the model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing most the time you
can actually just ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can randomly horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data if you're short data you
can start flipping like a horizontal
picture and it will generate it's like
doubling your data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias
that is the downside of that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go
and we're going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice uh
learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one
uh there's there you really don't this
is how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that
it doesn't really matter does the same
thing and we'll go ahead and just run
that
and you can see while it's running right
here uh we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to 25.
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25. this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process uh because we are training 150
by 150 by 3 pixels across uh six layers
or eight layers whatever it
was that is a huge amount of processing
so this will take a few minutes to
process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are
and um if you set the verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic 10 epic so we
went through all the data 10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there that's a lot of data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the
270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing
in on this particular computer um i
actually have what is it uh uh eight
cores with 16 dedicated threads so it
runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to find
out how good the models are doing and
what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over uh takes
about a day and a half to test each
model
um it takes four days to do the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out uh get an idea
of how the different setups are going to
do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data and
figure out what it costs to do a large
set of data and what kind of model you
want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns this into
something that
we can use and so the accuracy is what
percentage of guesses in this case is
categorical so this is the percentage of
guesses are correct
value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy um just rounds
it off basically and so a lot of times
you come down here and you go okay we're
doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case 68.59
accuracy
that's a very usable number and it's
very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance and knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here is when we get
to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here and it
starts crossing as far as the um
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together
right around five and six you start to
see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
see but you know that right around here
if you're saving your model after each
run you want to use the one that's right
around five epics because that's the one
that's going to have the least amount of
bias so this is really important as far
as guessing what's going on with your
model and its accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here
i show somebody this kind of model i say
this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70 accuracy whether it's going to be
a dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see
where the errors are coming from and
what problems are coming up image
classification using cross
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
uh what's in it for you today
what is image classification
intel image classification data
creating neural networks with keras and
the vgg-16 model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather
it is a nighttime or daytime shot what
the image represents etc you can see
here we have mountains looking for
mountains well actually doing some
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classify them based on these features
and you can see here where it has like
what computer sees and it says oh yeah
we see mostly forest maybe a little bit
of mountains because the way the image
is
and this is really where one of the
areas that neural networks
really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the
neural networks get better and better at
what they do with different tools we
have out there
so intel image classification data
the data being used is the intel image
classification data set would consist of
images of six types of land areas
and so we have forest building glaciers
and mountains sea and street
and you can see here there's a couple of
the images out of there as a setup in
the in the
intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with cross
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks
as shown below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they haven't listed max pooling uh so
you have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and the input layer is actually
before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network
then you have a max pooling that pulls
those the the convolutional neural
networks returns
in this case they have two of those that
is very standard with convolutional
neural networks
one of the ones that i was looking at
earlier that was standard being used by
one one of the larger companies that
came from which one for doing a large
amount of identification had two
convolutional neural networks each with
their max pooling and then about 17
dense layers after it we're not going to
do that heavy duty of a of a code but
we'll get you ahead in the right
direction and that gives you an idea of
what you're actually going to be looking
at when you look at the flattened part
and then the dents we're talking like 17
dense layers afterwards
i find that a lot of the stuff i've been
working on i end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
vgg16 is a pre-trained cnn model which
is used for image classification it is
trained on a large varied data set and
fine-tuned to fit image classification
data sets with ease
and you can see down here we have the
input coming in uh the convolutional
neural network one to one one to two and
then pooling and then we do two to one
two to two convolutional network then
pooling three to two and you can see
there's just this huge layering of
convolutional neural networks and in
this case they have five such layers
going in and then in three dents going
out or
more
now when they
took this setup this actually won an
award back in 2019 for this particular
setup
and it does it does really good except
that again
we only show the three dense layers here
and as you find out
depending on your data going in and what
you have set up
that really isn't enough on one of these
setups and i'm going to show you why we
restricted it because it does take up a
lot of processing power in some of these
things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
the first classification
and then we'll go into the vgg g16 and
show you how that's set up
now i'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like
now i'm running in the anaconda here uh
you'll see that i've set up a main
python 3 8. i always put that in there
because this is where i'm doing like
most of my kind of playing around
this is done in python version 3.8 we're
not going to dig too much into versions
at this point you should already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
setup is the numpy the pandas
your sk your site kit which is going to
be the sk learn your seaborn and i'll
show you those in just a minute
um and then i'm just going to be in the
jupiter lab where i've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple cool things to note
in here is that
one i use the the
anaconda jupiter notebook setup because
it keeps everything separate
except for cross
cross is actually running separately in
the back
i believe it's a c program
what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and i'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
and when we look in here a couple things
to note is here's our
oops
i thought i grabbed the other drawing
thing uh but here's our numpy and our
pandas right here and our operating
system this is our scikit you always
import it as sk learn for the
classification report
uh we're going to be using well usually
import like seaborne brings in all of
your pie plot library also
kind of nice to throw that in there i
can't remember if we're actually using
seaborne if they just the people in the
back just threw that together
and then we have the sk learn shuffle
for shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the seaborn is pretty much
built on
cv2
if you're not familiar with that that is
our image
module for importing the image
and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders this tqdm is really kind of
cool it's an extensible progress bar for
python and i'll show you that too
remember data science is not i mean
almost this code when i'm looking
through this code i'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody i'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
so we need to go ahead and import those
different
set up on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes
uh now we remember if we had mountain
street glacier building c and forest
those were the different images that we
have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of ifri
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up
here uh and then we have the number of
uh classes
and the print the class names and the
labels and we'll go ahead and set the
image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural networks
they take one size data coming in and so
when you're working with images you
really want to make sure they're all
resized to the same
setup it might squish them it might
stretch them that generally does not
cause a problem in these
in some of the other tricks you can do
with
if you if you need more data
and this is one that's used regularly
we're not going to do it in here is you
can also take these images and not only
resize them but you can tilt them one
way or the other crop parts of them
so they process slightly differently and
it'll actually increase your accuracy of
some of these predictions
and so you can see here we have mountain
equals zero that's what this class name
label is street equals one glacier
equals two buildings equals three c4 4s
equals five
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is zero through five
a lot of times we do this instead as um
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out
so the next thing we really want to do
is we want to go ahead and load the data
up
and just put a label in there loading
data
just just so you know what we're doing
i'm going to put in the loading data
down here
make sure it's well labeled
and we'll create a definition for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on
and if you once you download you can go
download this data set uh send a note to
the simply learn team here in youtube
and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here
so you have the right whatever wherever
you saved it a lot of times i'll just
abbreviate the path or put it as a sub
thing and just get rid of the directory
but again double check your paths
we're going to separate this into a
segment for training
and a segment for testing and that's
actually how it is in the folder let me
just show you what that looks
like so when i have my lengthy path here
where i keep all my programming simply
learn this particular setup we're
working on image classification
and image classification
clearly you probably wouldn't have that
lengthy of a list
and when we go in here
you'll see sequence train sequence test
they've already split this up this is
what we're going to train the data in
and again you can see buildings 4th
glacier mountain c street
and if we double click let's go under
forest
you can see all these different forest
images and there's a lot of variety here
i mean we have winter time we have
summertime
so it's kind of interesting
you know here's like a fallen tree
versus
a road going down the middle that's
really hard to train and if you look at
the buildings
a lot of these buildings you're looking
up a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one i want to
highlight this one it has trees in it
let me just open that up so you can see
a little closer
the reason i want to highlight this is i
want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a forest
so this kind of imagery makes it really
hard for a classifier and if you start
looking at these you'll see a lot of
these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground
weird angles
really a hard thing for a computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data
one we have to have the path the
directory
we're going to come in here we have our
images and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the labels in another
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders in
fact let me do this let me
there we go
as we look at this we're just going to
loop through the three six different
folders that have the different
landscapes and then we're going to go
through and pull each file out
and each label
so we set the label we set the folder
for file and list
here's our image path
join the paths
this is all kind of not general stuff
so i'm kind of skipping through it
really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our cv2 reader so it reads the
image in
uh it's going to go ahead and take the
image and convert it to
from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a cv2 thing
almost all the time it imports it and
instead of importing it as a standard
that's used just about everywhere it
imports it with the bgr versus rgb
rgb is pretty much a standard in here
you have to remember that with cv2
and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've said that we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images and
we're just going to pin the image append
the label
and then the images it's going to turn
into a numpy array this just makes it
easier to process and manipulate
and then the labels is also a numpy
array and then we just return the output
append images and labels and we return
the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory uh
we haven't talked too much
there'd be a different setup in there
because there is ways to feed the files
directly into your cross model
but we want to go ahead and just load
them all because
really
for today's processing and what our
computers can handle that's not a big
deal
and then we go ahead and set the train
images train labels test images test
labels and that's going to be returned
in our output append and you can see
here we did
images and labels set up in there and it
just loads them in there so we'll have
these four different categories let me
just go ahead and run that
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before
we imported just go back up there
shuffle here we go here's our sk learn
utilities import shuffle
and so we want to take these labels and
shuffle them around a little bit
just mix them up so it's not having the
same if you run the same process over
and over uh then you might run into some
problems on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do
a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and i
showed you
what that was going on we can go ahead
and just display them here too
and i tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here um
this thing is like when i'm working on
code and i'm looking at this data and
i'm trying to figure out what i'm doing
i skip this process
the second i get into a meeting and i'm
showing what's going on to other people
i skip everything we just did
so
and go right to here where we want to go
ahead and display
some images and take a look at it
and in this display
i've taken them and i've resized the
images to 20 by 20.
that's pretty small uh so we're going to
lose just a massive amount of detail and
you can see here these nice pixelated
images
i might even just stick with the folder
showing them what images were processing
uh
again this is
yeah be a little careful this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea
in fact let me try without resizing it
and see what happens oops so i took out
the image size and then we put this
straight in here
one of the things again this is um
but the d there we go one of the things
again that we want to
know whenever we're working on these
things
is the cv2
there are so many different
image classification setups it's really
a powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the pie plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a
u integer 8 format because it comes in
as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there
and so this is just basically we've
split up our we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
or
the plot figure size is 20 by 20
and then we're doing 25 so 5x5 subplot
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images
and
really when you're showing people what's
going on this is what they want to see
so you skip over all the code and you
have your meeting you say okay here's
our images of the building
don't get caught up in how much work you
do get caught up in what they want to
see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun
here's our model this is where it gets
exciting
when you're digging into these models
and you have here
let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2d
and
2d is an image you have two different
dimensions x y and even though there's
three colors it's still considered 2d
if you're running a video you'd be
convolutional neural network 3d if
you're doing a series going across
a time series it might be 1d
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on
to dig into um we have our input shape
so everything's been set to 150 by 150
and it has of course three different
color schemes in it that's important to
notice
activation
default is relu this is
small amounts of data are being
processed on a bunch of little
neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional null networks are
being strung up on here
and then the
3x3 uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at a little three by
three square on each image
and so that's what's going on here and
with convolutional neural networks the
window floats across and adds up all
these numbers going across on this data
and then eventually it comes up with a
30 in this case 32 different
feature options that it's looking for
and of course you can change that 32 you
can change the three by three so you
might have a larger setup you know if
you're going across 150
by 150 that's a lot of steps so we might
run this as 15 by 15.
there's all kinds of different things
you can do
here we're just putting this together
again that would be something you would
play with to find out which ones are
going to work better on this setup
and there's a lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be the second part i mentioned earlier
and i can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers
one is the activation is a relu they use
a relu and a soft max here um
it's a whole a whole setup just
explaining why these are different
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact
there's just a ton of these and you can
build your own custom activations
depending on what you're doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations
there are two or three major thoughts on
these activations and
rayleigh and softmax are
ray lew
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b
x 2 plus c x 3
plus a bias
with soft max this belongs to the party
of um
it's activated or it's not except it's
they call it soft max because when you
get the the to 0 instead of it just
being zero
uh it's actually slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
there's a whole series of these
activations
another activation is the tangent
where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area
where you have from minus one to one or
exponential which is zero to one
so there's a lot of different ways to do
the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here
we're looking at the convolutional
neural network um and we're doing the
two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks stacked on
top of each other each with its own max
pool underneath let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
we're we're gonna use the atom uh
optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there there's some other
optimizer but i think atom is a default
um i don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the
once you get a model that works really
good you might try some different
optimizers but atoms usually the most
and then we're looking at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
law we want to
maximize the loss of error
and then we're going to look at accuracy
everybody likes the accuracy i'm going
to tell you right now
i start talking to people and like okay
what's what's the loss on this and then
as a data science yeah i want to know
how the lot what's going on with that
we'll show you why in a minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
uh and then we're going to run the fit
and i wanted to do this just so i can
show you
even though we're in a python
setup in here where jupyter notebook is
using only a single processor
i'm going to bring over my little cpu
tool
this is eight cores on 16 dedicated
threats so it shows up as 16 processors
and actually i got to run this and then
move it over
so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to do go through the epics and
we said i set it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different
threads available
so it does a really good job of doing
that
this is going to take a while if you
look at here it's
eta
2 minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds so
this is roughly two and a half minutes
per epic
and we're doing five epics
so this is going to be done in roughly
15 minutes
i don't know about you but i don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching the green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and
there we go uh there was our 15 minutes
it's actually less than that
uh because i did when i went in here
realized that uh
where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip
fit
and here's our epics so i did four epics
so a little bit better a little more
like 10 to 11 minutes instead of
doing the full
15. and
when we look at this here's our model we
did we talked about the compiler uh
here's our history we're going to cl
history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a minute
and we're looking at is we have our
epics
here's our validation split
so as we train it uh we're weighing the
accuracy versus
you kind of pull some data off to the
side
uh while you're training it
and the reason we do that is that
you don't want to over fit
and i'll we'll look at that chart in
just a minute
here's batch size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time
the larger the batch it actually
increases the processing speed
um and there's reasons to go up or down
on the batch size because of the
the the smaller the batch
there's a certain point where
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once
so i yeah 128 is kind of big
depends on the computer you're on what
it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images
and our train labels going in telling it
what we're going to train on
and then we look at our four epochs here
here's our accuracy we want the accuracy
to go up
and we get all the way up to 0.83 or 83
percent now this is actual percentage
based pretty much
and we can see over here our loss we
want our loss to go down really
fluctuates 55 1.2 0.77 0.48
so we have a lot of things going on
there
let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our team in the back did a wonderful
job of putting together
this basic plot set up
here's our subplot coming in we're going
to be looking at
from the history we're going to send it
the accuracy and the value
accuracy labels and set up on there
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss so you can see what this
looks like what's really interesting
about
this setup and let me let me just go
ahead and show you because
without actually seeing the plots it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of uh
of the data using the pi plot library
and i want you to look at this this is
really interesting
when i ran this the first time i had
very different results
um and they vary greatly and you can see
here our accuracy continues to climb
um
and there's a cross over here
put it in here
right here is our crossover
and i point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy
we're like oh yeah i got .8
we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um
as our value
as a training set versus the value
accuracy stays the same and so that this
is the one where actually really want to
be aware of and where it crosses
is kind of where you want to stop at
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here we
did one epic and look how it just
flat lines right there with our loss
so really
one epic is
probably enough
and you're gonna say wow okay point
eight percent um certainly if i was
working with the shareholders
telling them that it has an 80 accuracy
isn't quite true and and we'll look at
that a little deeper it really comes out
here that the accuracy of our actual
values is closer to 0.41
right here
even after running it this number of
times
and so you really want to stop right
here at that crossover
one epic would have been enough
so the date is a little overfitted on
this when we do four epics
and uh whoops there we are
okay
my drawing won't go away um let's see if
i can get there we go
um for some reason i've killed my
drawing ability and my recorder
all right took a couple extra clicks
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
our actual test loss so you see where it
crosses over that's where i'm looking at
that's where we start overfitting the
model
and this is where
if we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model
we would start taking a look at the
images and start rotating them uh we
might start playing with the
convolutional neural network instead of
doing the three by three window
we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things
so let's go ahead and take a look at our
our test loss now remember we had our
training data
now we're going to look at our test
images and our test labels
for our test loss here and this is just
model evaluate just like we did fit up
here
where was it
one more
model fit with our training data going
in now we're going to evaluate it on the
and this data has not been touched yet
so
this model's never seen this data this
is on
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we
already know what it is from the labels
we have
and this is what i was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
0.48
or 4847
so this 49 of the time
guesses what the image is
and
i mean really that's the bottom dollar
uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49 work do we need to
upgrade the model more
um
in some cases this might be uh
oh what was i doing i was working on uh
stock evaluations
and
we were looking at what stocks were the
top performers
well if i get that 50 correct on top
performers
uh i'm good with that um that's actually
pretty good for stock evaluation
in fact the number i had for stock was
more like um 30 something percent as far
as being a top performer stock
much harder to predict
but at that point you're like well
you'll make money off of that so again
this number right here depends a lot on
the domain you're working on
and then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more uh as far as
looking at the different setup in here
and one of the
from sk learn if you remember actually
let's go back to the top
uh we had the classification report and
this came in from our sk learn or scikit
setup
and that's right here you can see it
right here on the
see there we go
classification report right here sklearn
metrics import classification report
this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff
depends on who you're working with
so when we start looking at
precision
you know this is like for each value i
can't remember what one one one was
probably mountains so if 44
is not good enough if you if you're
doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not i'm only 44 accurate
not a good deal
you know i would not go with that um
so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for facebook yeah you know
44 i'm guessing the right person i hope
it does a little bit better than that um
but here's our main accuracy this is
what almost everybody looks at they say
oh 48 that's what's important um again
it depends on what domain you're in and
what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow i got my there it goes i
thought i was going to get stuck in
there again
this time we're going to be using the
vgg16
and remember this one is
all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here
uh and so we need to go ahead and um
import all our different stuff from
cross we're importing the main one is
the v
g 16 set up on there
just aim that there we go
um
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the vg g16 setup on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here
inputs model inputs outputs model inputs
i'm not going to spend as much time as
they did on the other one
we're going to go through it really
quickly
one of the first things i would do
is if you remember in cross you can
treat
treat a model like you would a layer
and so at this point i would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg-16 model and create a new model with
all those things in there
and we'll go ahead and run this
because here's our model coming in and
our setup
and it'll take it just a moment to
compile that
what's funny about this is i'm waiting
for it to download the package since i
pre-ran this
it takes it a couple minutes to download
the vgg16 model into here
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then i told you it's going to create
another model too and the people in the
back did not disappoint me they went
ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part um
this is worth stopping for i told you i
was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we we have our model 2
coming in and we've created a model up
here with the vgg16 model equals model
inputs model inputs and so we have our
vgg16
this has already been pre-programmed
and then we come down here i want you to
notice on this
right here
layer model 2 layers minus 4 to 1 x
layer x
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff onto it
and so
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing
by using
model up here as a layer
we could have the input go to this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on
this whole setup
this whole block of code from 13 to 17
has been added on to our vgg16 model
and we have a new model uh with the
layer input and x down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it
and that was a lot to go through right
there when you're building these models
this is the part that gets so
complicated
that you get stuck playing in and yet
it's so fun
it's like a puzzle how can i loop these
models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers
we're just copying layers over and
adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like i said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer i've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the straight
model over
you run into issues
it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss
pretty straightforward just like we did
before you got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history
the history is going to be
a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff
we're going to have to go ahead and it's
going to light up our setup on here and
this is going to take a little bit to
get us all set up it's not going to just
happen in a couple minutes so let me go
ahead and pause the video and run it and
then we'll talk about what happened
okay now when i ran that these actually
took about six minutes each um
so it's a good thing i put it on hold we
did four epics i actually had to stop it
says at 10 and switch it to forks i
didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
and our loss numbers going down
and just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658
so our accuracy is going down or you
know 26
um 34
35
and you can see here at some point it
just kind of kicks the bucket again this
is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on
programming these different neural
networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy
history we built that nice little
subroutine up above so we might as well
use it
and you can see it right here
there's that crossover again
and
if you look at this look how the how the
uh the red shifts up how the uh
our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
epic um we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
we're just to it's just going to
baseline this one actually shows with
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts over fitting
and right about now you should be saying
uh oh uh something went wrong there i
thought that
um
we went up here and ran this
look at this we have the accuracy up
here it's hitting that 48 percent
and we're down here
you look at the score down here that
looks closer to
20 percent not nearly
anywhere in the ballpark of what we're
looking for
and we'll go ahead and run it through
the uh the actual test features here and
there it is
we actually run this on the unseen data
and everything
0.18 or 18 percent
um i don't know about you but i wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
i thought this was supposed to be the
supermodel the
model that beats all models
vgg16 that won the
awards and everything
well the reason is is that
one we're not
pre-processing the data so it needs to
be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here
and that would actually greatly change
the outcome on here and then we went up
here we only added a couple dense layers
we added a couple convolutional neural
networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in as
far as how it's going to train
and so
uh this is one of those things where i
thought it would have done better and i
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say why didn't this work why
am i getting only
18 here instead of 44
or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in
uh and again you can make your own
training data so it's not that we have a
shortage of data it's that that some of
that has to be switched around and moved
around a little bit and this is
interesting right here too if you look
at the precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else
so for some reason it's not seeing
uh the different variables in here so
it'd be something else to look in and
try to track down
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where i'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in
where's the setup on there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why
and we went through the very basics of
convolutional neural networks along with
the
vgg-16 import and how you can get
started with that
and again the art is the data going in
and learning to play with it find out
what works
thank you all for watching this full
course video on neural network tutorial
by simply learn i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you